Hallo Wolfgang! Hallo Stefan, du wirst doch nicht einfach husten.
Eigentlich unterdrücke ich es natürlich.
Wir sind ja auch nicht in der Kölner Philharmonie. Was hast du denn gegen das Husten?
Also ich habe den vielleicht größten Pianisten unserer Zeit einmal mehr erlebt
in der Kölner Philharmonie und es wurde entsetzlich viel gehustet.
Das hat mich derart geärgert, dass ich gestern twitterte, dass Sokolow wieder
genial war, aber das Publikum aus Dummheit und Verlegenheit hustet und es nicht
mehr in der Lage ist, sich selbst zu beherrschen.
Jetzt hat das natürlich bei Twitter einiges losgetreten und alle haben sich
darüber lustig gemacht, die nie in Konzertsäle gehen, denn die,
die in Konzertsäle gehen, wissen ganz genau, was ich meine.
Wir haben gestern sage und schreibe zehn Musiker aus dem klassischen Bereich
geschrieben, unter anderem einen Opernsänger, den wir beide kennen.
Die haben gesagt, vielen Dank, dass du sagst, für Musiker ist es schwer,
das so drastisch anzusprechen, weil sie natürlich auch ihr Publikum nicht gänzlich verlieren wollen.
Aber dieser Opernsänger schrieb mir dann auch noch, es ist ja auch eine Unsitte
geworden, dass Leute einfach die gesamte Overtüre durchquatschen.
Und erst wenn gesungen wird, die Oper für sie beginnt.
Und ich habe da mal doch einige Anmerkungen zuzumachen. Also man muss sich das
so vorstellen, man ist in der Kölner Philharmonie, da passen etwa 2000 Leute
rein. Das ist auch voll, weil Sokolov sehr berühmt ist.
Sokolov spielt Purcell, das ist ein englischer Barockkomponist und er spielt
ihn alleine auf einem Steinway.
Es ist also sehr ruhig in dem Saal und bei einer Philharmonie hat man es natürlich
mit einem sehr hellhörigen Raum zu tun.
2.000 Leute und dann wird aber nicht nochmal verstärkt.
Es wird natürlich nicht verstärkt. Es ist nur das Klavier und der Raum ist aber
so, dass man auch dort, wenn man gut bei Stimme wäre, ohne Mikrofon sprechen
kann und gesungen wird natürlich auch ohne Mikrofon dort.
Das heißt aber, dass das Publikum sich äußerst zusammenreißen muss, weil natürlich...
Überall der Saal hellhörig ist und ich will zunächst mal sagen,
das ist nicht, weil mir das so vorgeworfen wurde, bei Twitter irgendein versnobbtes Ding.
Ich saß ja zwischen diesen ganzen Snobs gold behangen, die auch in der teuersten
Kategorie gesessen haben, die dumm herumhusten.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich jetzt die, weiß ich nicht, die die marginalisierten
ermahnt habe mit diesem Tweet, sondern ich sitze ja zwischen einem Publikum,
Dem es, glaube ich, relativ gut geht.
Und dieses Publikum hat einfach nicht mehr den Respekt vor den Künstlern und
den anderen Menschen, die anwesend sind, dass man sich zurückhält.
Ja, es kann Hustenanfälle geben, die man nicht unter Kontrolle hat,
die sehr plötzlich aufkommen.
Dann aber muss man zu einem Taschentuch greifen, um das zu dämpfen.
Was aber stattfindet, ist, dass die Leute dort sitzen, Ich mache das mal vor, in dieser Weise husten.
Das knallt durch den ganzen Saal. Dann halten Sie die Hand leicht vor den Mund,
was das verstärkt, statt ein Taschenbuch zu nehmen.
Es sind auch gerade bei Purcell sehr leise Passagen.
Es war erstaunlich zu hören, wenn es lebhaft lauter war, wurde nicht gehustet.
Wenn es stiller und harmonisch herausfordernd, wird gehustet.
Es ist also eine Verlegenheit.
Man weiß ja eigentlich gar nicht, wie soll ich damit umgehen und dann macht man mal.
Und das hörst du natürlich, wenn es in Reihe 30 geäußert wird,
auch noch in Reihe 5. Es ist überall zu hören. Und ich finde einfach,
dass Gesellschaft nur funktionieren kann über Affektkontrolle.
Unsere Gesellschaft ist darauf ausgelegt, dass wir uns, wenn wir mit anderen
Menschen sind, Wir haben bei Corona immer diese Sätze gehabt,
Rücksicht auf die anderen nehmen. Das gilt aber nicht nur, wenn man in einer Pandemie ist.
Man versucht, den anderen nicht zu stören. Es ist auch nicht ein Ding,
weil ich dann ... Alter weißer Mann beklagt sich, okay, Boomer schreiben dann Leute.
Ich war mit zwei Freunden dort, wovon der eine sich mit klassischer Musik sehr gut ausgeht.
Der andere geht eher selten ins Konzert, hat das aber auch sehr genossen und
beide haben sich natürlich daran gestört, dass gehustet wurde.
Ich habe zwei Bekannte getroffen, beide 24 Jahre alt. Das erste,
was die sagen ist, es ist ja furchtbar, wie gehustet wird. Es ist also nicht
irgendwie ein Boomer-Ding oder so, sondern ich würde vielleicht eher sagen,
da haben die Boomer ein bisschen viel gehustet in dem Konzert.
Na gut, kleine Gegenrede von mir in zwei Facetten. Zum einen,
ich war jetzt in Don Giovanni.
Du hast geschrieben, kenne ich schon und ich habe nachgeschaut,
ja, es läuft ja auch schon seit sechs Jahren oder so. Und ich war wirklich schwer begeistert.
Ja. Wir saßen natürlich in Reihe zwei, also da, wo man noch viel von der Bühne
mitbekommt und nicht allzu sehr dem Publikum ausgeliefert ist.
Ich habe aber Erzählungen gehört, ab Reihe zehn wird es schon kritisch.
Also da sind die Sänger dann doch sehr weit weg.
Und es war, ähm, klar, es passiert dann immer so bei Mozart und so weiter,
dass Szenenapplause gegeben werden, ungefähr fünfzehnmal.
Also es war wirklich kaum zu ertragen. Man sieht ja dann auch die Sänger,
es ist ja eingeplant, der Dirigent hält dann kurz an und die Sänger so gucken
dann kurz eher skeptisch als kritisch und warten dann fünf Sekunden, bis sie weiter singen.
Aber es war eben auch, und das war auch lustig vorher zu sehen,
weil wenn jetzt schönes Wetter ist, trifft man sich ja schon vor der Oper und
verbringt draußen noch ein bisschen Zeit statt schon drin.
Und es gab doch sehr viele Gruppenfotos draußen von jungen Menschen,
die dann irgendwie Schule, Studium, keine Ahnung, so in diesem Altersrange sich
da auch noch mal aufgereiht haben. Alle sehr schön angezogen,
natürlich immer so weiße Blusen und so weiter.
Und ich hab mir dann irgendwie gedacht, Affinitäten.
Ich hab mich auch ein bisschen für das Publikum mitgefreut, dass es sich so
freut, weil ich durchaus.
Ich bin auch gerne in Gesellschaft, ich sag ja nicht.
Ja, aber ich meine es auch ganz so auf andere Regio-Schiene bedacht,
dass das Publikum dann nicht beim Husten, aber auch mit Applaus vielleicht nicht
ganz an sich hält und sich einfach kurz erlöst und auch mitteilt,
dass es das hier gerade toll fand, klar, so ein Szenenapplaus,
so störend er sein kann, ist er dann doch, er sucht sich seine richtige Pause.
Es ist ja, es gibt ja schon noch Nummern bei Don Giovanni, also man kann applaudieren,
das würde jetzt beim Tristan natürlich nicht passieren. Also bei Ragnar ist
das durchkomponiert, da ist das nicht vorgesehen und bei vielen anderen Opern
auch nicht, weil da geht das natürlich schon noch.
Wann ja mal die eine oder andere Szene endet und dann ist das auch und das sind,
also ich habe festgestellt, auch in der Oper Frankfurt,
die ja nun eigentlich sehr gediegen,
ruhig, es ist Programm auf der Bühne und alle wissen Bescheid,
ich fand es auch ganz interessant, das mal ein bisschen anders zu erleben,
also sichtbar Menschen, die nicht die ganze Zeit in der Oper sind und auch deren
Freude so mitzusehen, das sind
sozusagen die positiven Störungen und die negativen Störungen, das Husten.
Also ich bin ja hier, wenn wir so Podcasts aufnehmen, mehrere Stunden bewaffnet.
Zum einen mit Tabletten, Haltstabletten, die Halskratzen, Hustenreiz und Heiserkeit lindern.
Außerdem mit einer Flasche, in der ein sehr dicker Schlauch hängt,
in der ich dann vorher immer blubber. Klingt ungefähr so.
Falls man das hört, also man pustet Luft ins Wasser und nachdem mir meine Leukopädin
das empfohlen hat und ich es dann in einer Arte-Reportage über einen Rapper gesehen hatte,
der das auch macht und ich bin ja sowieso in so semi-medizinischer Behandlung
durchgehend, aber auch immer mal wieder, als nächstes steht eine Magenspiegelung
an, weil es so Sachen gibt wie Stillenreflux und so.
Also es gibt durchaus Magensäure, Ungereimtheiten, die sich in der ...
Also mehr dann so in der Halsgegend, in der Speiseröhre abspielen,
wo sie nicht hingehören. Was bedeutet meine Stimmbänder zum Beispiel?
Schleimen einfach zu. So komisch das klingt. So wenn ich zwei Stunden lang hier
zu Hause arbeite oder im Büro bin und nicht rede und dann ruft mich jemand an,
muss ich wirklich erst mal meine Stimmbänder befreien.
Dann wichtig, nicht räuspern, sondern abhusten und so weiter.
Also ich merke das auch immer wieder in der Oper, dass ich schon bevor ich es
merke, ganz leise Räusper, bevor sie sich sozusagen aufbauen.
Also man kann, wenn man da entsprechende Defizite hat, durchaus damit umgehen lernen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie das ist bei so älteren Publikum, das 70 Lebensjahre
auf dem Buckel hat, ob man denen das nicht doch nicht verübeln kann.
Also klar, man kann das Taschentuch nehmen.
Und es sind andere Huster. Ich kann keine Aufnahmen von Hustern mitbringen.
Es wird auch irgendwann kleinteilig. Ich stelle fest, dass in manchen Passagen nicht gehustet wird.
Es gibt von Axel Hacke einen Text aus der Süddeutschen von 2014.
Da schreibt er, wie er aus seinem Buch vorliest. Und einen Pianisten dabei hat,
der kleine Variationen spielt.
Er beschreibt, dass, wann immer der Pianist einsetzte, Wenn der Pianist wieder
fertig ist, wird nicht mehr gehustet, dann hört man ihm still zu.
Also es hängt auch sehr damit zusammen, dass es eine Überforderung gibt und
diese Überforderungs-Übersprungshandlung ist dann das Husten oder das energische
Räuspern. Und da kann man sich auch zusammenreißen.
Es funktioniert nur so. Es ist ja auch besonders schade, wenn man 50 Euro für
eine Karte ausgibt, sich Monate drauf freut und dann bekommt man das Konzert verhustet.
Ist einfach nicht akzeptabel und ich finde auch, dass die Leute sich zusammenreißen können.
Also ich habe auch, ich rauche ja Zigaretten und ich habe auch mit Heuschnupfen
zu kämpfen und trotzdem lege ich da nicht los.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Abhilfe in Form dieser,
völlig einfach verfügbaren und nicht rezeptpflichtigen Tabletten,
die einfach den Hals wirklich sehr beruhigen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, die liegen in der Oper nicht aus. Du kannst Brezel in
Champagner und Programmhefte kaufen, aber keine Tabletten, die sollten dort verfügbar sein.
Ja, bei manchen Opernhäusern kann man auch Bonbons kaufen. Ich finde,
es sollte immer bei jeder Aufführung, egal ob Konzert oder Oper,
jemand vorher auf die Bühne kommen und sagen, passen Sie auf,
Husten ist sehr störend und dann das mit dem Taschentuch erklären und so weiter.
Es gab jetzt Sir John Elliott Gardiner, der ist in diesem Monat passiert,
der zu Gast war in der Elbphilharmonie.
Und am ersten Abend wurde derart viel gehustet, dass er dem Intendanten gedroht
hat, dass er, wenn das beim zweiten Konzert wieder stattfindet,
er das Konzert abbricht. So kam der Intendant selbst auf die Bühne und sagte,
bitte nehmen Sie das ernst, wenn jemand hustet, bitte nicht nachmachen.
Das ist auch ein sehr guter Satz, denn viele Leute denken, ach ja,
Husten ist eigentlich auch mal eine schöne Idee.
Ich langweil mich gerade, per se hab ich eh keine Ahnung von, also huste ich mal.
Und das hat dann wohl besser funktioniert, gerade die Elbphilharmonie ist ja sehr, sehr hellhörig.
Es gibt Anekdoten von Warenbäum, der einmal aufgestanden ist,
ein Taschentuch aus seiner, aus seinem Sakko zog und den Leuten zeigte,
wie man hustet mit Taschentuch.
Man hat von Alfred Brendel, dem Pianisten, die Äußerung, was er sich denn einmal
wünschen würde, ein Konzert ohne Husten. Also es ist ein großes Problem und
ich würde auch sagen, dass es schon sich nicht nur in diesem Konzertsaal zeigt, sondern generell.
Ist eine Privatisierung des öffentlichen Raumes zu erleben, Privatisierung in
der Form, dass die Leute sich wie in ihren privaten Räumen in der Öffentlichkeit verhalten.
Das beginnt mit Schuhe ausziehen im Zug, das geht weiter über zum Beispiel die
Kinokultur, dass dort in den Multiplex-Kinos einfach durchweg Leute mit dem
Smartphone sitzen und das mit beleuchten.
Und das sind jüngere Leute, während die älteren Leute im Programmkino sitzen
und dort einfach ihre Wohnzimmersituationen, Glauben vorzufinden und kommentieren
dann jede Szene einfach mit.
Also sitzen dort zu zweit und kommentieren, wie sie das zu Hause tun.
Ja, sie sitzen zu Hause, gucken Traumschiff und dann sagen die,
ach hier, das ist doch die Isabel Varell.
Nee, nee, das ist die Barbara Wusso. Ja, aber die Isabelle Varel hat auch Locken.
Ja, die hat auch Locken. Und diese Kommunikation findet jetzt im Programmkino statt.
Ja, okay. Abschließend, du hast eben Bonbons gesagt. Ich will nochmal ausdrücklich
sagen, es geht hier um Tabletten. Ich empfehle sehr Tabletten.
Denn beim Bonbon denkt man immer so an, es ist eh schon knisternd eingepackt.
Und danach ist es eigentlich so ein Zuckerwürfel mit Geschmack.
Ja, das Knistern ist ja auch so eine Sache.
Genau. Und diese Tabletten hier, die sind in einem Metallding mit Plastikdeckel.
Also man kriegt das völlig geräuschlos auf und zu.
Man holt sich eine raus. Es sind Tabletten ohne Zuckerzusatz,
ohne alles. Und sie haben auch
diese wirkliche eben nicht systemisch verändernde, Also deswegen kein.
Es ist keine Medizin, es sind alles vorübergehende Folgen, aber man hat einen
sehr schönen, sehr weichen, wie Pflaumen im Mund, es schäumt einfach so ein
bisschen und bleibt aber auch.
Also man kann da durchaus, das ist nicht gedacht für, oh ich merke,
ich habe einen Hustenanfall, ich muss jetzt schnell und dann knistert man so
rum, sondern bevor die Show beginnt, nimmt man so eine Tablette und dann ist
einfach zwei Stunden Ruhe.
Fabelhaft.
Das sollte man durchaus mehr thematisieren.
Und auf dieser Verpackung sind sogar schon Noten drauf.
Ja, das ist ganz ausdrücklich für Sprecher und Sänger gemacht,
die nämlich ihren Hustenreiz, während sie die Stimme benutzen,
damit unterdrucken können.
Fürs Nichtbenutzen funktionieren die auf jeden Fall super.
Das finde ich ja interessant, wenn man beim Philharmoniekonzert ist,
dann sitzen da hundert Orchestermusiker, ich habe da noch nie einen Husten sehen.
Ich habe auch noch nie auf der Bühne jemanden Husten oder sich Räuspern sehen,
sondern die wissen, wie es geht.
Die scheinen das ja auch zu schaffen. Also man kann da durchaus Vorsorge treffen
und man sollte das in Podcasts, aber insbesondere an der Eingangstür würde ich
sagen, mach das Ticket 50 Cent teurer und dann gibt es so eine Tablette vorher dazu.
Ja.
Irgendwie so.
Und die können einfach den Clip hier aus dem Podcast vorspielen.
Zum Beispiel. Und dann sind alle gut unterrichtet.
Gut. Andere Veranstaltungen, die stattfanden.
In Frankfurt warst du.
In Frankfurt. Es gibt einen Laden, der heißt heute Zoom, der war mal woanders.
Ich weiß immer nicht genau, warum Veranstaltungsorte umziehen,
den Namen aber mitnehmen, so dass Menschen, die denken, ah, ich gehe mal in
Zoom, plötzlich auf der Hauptwache stehen, obwohl das irgendwo im Osten der
Stadt ist und dann ist es irgendwie zu spät. Na jedenfalls, es gibt ein Zoom.
Das eigentlich für Konzerte genutzt wird, so range sportfreunde stiller habe
ich da glaube ich zuletzt gehört, haben da gespielt und das war mal der alte
Technoladen von Sven Veldt.
Benjamin von Stuttgart-Bache ist da hingekommen und hat eine Lesung gemacht
und damit ist auch schon das ganze Programm erklärt. Es war die langweiligste
Veranstaltung ever. Ich bin auch vorher gegangen, weil Babysitter und so weiter
nach zwei Stunden war immer noch nicht Schluss.
Und es drehte sich im Grunde nur darum, dass uns uns Frankfurter Benjamin von
Stuttgart-Bache noch mal gesagt hat,
das ist übrigens der Laden von Sven Veth und wir alle so, ja,
das ist sehr subversiv angemerkt und auch sehr klug, aber das wissen wir jetzt
schon und du hast es jetzt uns auch 17 mal gesagt, gibt es nicht irgendwas zum Buch zu sagen?
Es stellt sich raus, Benjamin von Stuttgart-Bache tourt gerade und ich kann
mir das nur wie folgt erklären als Szenario.
Der Verlag sagt, hier und das ist der Vorschuss, wir kriegen von dir ein Buch und 20 Lesungen.
Dann sagt er, okay. Dann stehen die 20 Lesungen an und dann kommen Anwälte zu
ihm, seine, und sagen, du darfst auf der Bühne auf gar keinen Fall irgendetwas sagen.
Es gilt das geschriebene Wort, das steht zwischen den zwei Buchdeckeln.
Darüber hinaus wird hier nichts gesagt.
Denn nicht nur wir beobachten, was da auf der Bühne passiert,
sondern auch die Anwälte der Gegenseite.
Und du weißt, das ist ein Milliardär und so weiter, der erscheut wahrscheinlich gerade keine Bühnen.
Also sitzt man da zwei Stunden und denkt sich, wow, das ist ja wirklich die
lameste Veranstaltung, die ever auf der Bühne stattfindet.
Er kommt auf die Bühne, alles ist ironisch, es wird 20 Minuten dafür aufgewendet
zu sagen, ich darf auf der Bühne rauchen, ihr da unten nicht,
aber wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr euch auf den Bühnenkante setzen,
dann dürft ihr auch rauchen.
So, ist natürlich ein neckischer Hinweis, kann man dann auch machen,
hat in Frankfurt hat keiner gemacht, aber braucht 20 Minuten.
Dann, die nächsten 20 Minuten, werden uns irgendwelche Namen genannt,
die er sich ausgedacht hat, man hört dann auch aus Erzählungen,
das ist auf jeder Veranstaltung so, er vergaukelt erstmal, was in seinem Buch
drin steht, denn wir kommen natürlich alle hin und wissen, Freund ist Döpfner
und so weiter und wir wollen eigentlich was erfahren oder auch nicht oder sehen, wie er damit umgeht.
Nein, es geht erst mal um Torben und Bernd und überhaupt. Und es werden so ein
paar Boomer Witze gemacht. Okay, jetzt nächsten 20 Minuten rum.
Dann geht es 20 Minuten darum, dass ja die Veranstaltung in Ingolstadt vor 40
Leuten in die Hose ging. Aber hier in Frankfurt muss man sich ja keine Sorgen
machen. Also das, was jeder Comedian am Ende seiner Karriere auf der Bühne nochmal
abzieht, Städtewitze über die anderen Veranstaltungen.
Und natürlich war in Ingolstadt, wenn er dort gewesen ist, die Kühle war auch voll.
Da war's Mannheim, was blöd war und so weiter.
Und dann werden diese völlig sinnfreien,
nichts mit dem Buch zu tun habenden und auch in keiner Sekunde von ihm selbst
ernstgenommenen Witze,
was auch immer, er hat ja auch keine Moderation neben sich oder so, er ist völlig alleine,
einfach nur unterbrochen mit jetzt lese ich euch meine Textstelle vor,
die ich noch nie vorgelesen hab, was natürlich totaler Quatsch ist,
ist, er liest einfach die drei zentralen Stellen des Buches vor.
Also er bekommt das Buch von Rose, die Lewinsky-Biografie, wo drin steht, nimm die Frauen ernst.
Also diese Beauftragung, ich nehme jetzt diese Frauen ernst.
Dann liest er als zweites diesen Auszug, wie er mit den Frauen chattet und wie
sie ihm ihre Geschichten erzählen.
Und dann fügt er nochmal an, wie er ja selber auch schon mal Opfer vor 20 Jahren
zu Beginn seiner Karriere im Medienbetrieb und so weiter wurde,
eines sexuellen Übergriffs, den er damals gar nicht so gedeutet hat.
Er selber dachte, er hätte einen Fehler gemacht, dabei wurde er ihm zugetragen.
Also es sind sozusagen die Schlüsselstellen des Schlüsselromans,
um zu sagen, Leute, ich habe dieses Buch aus Gründen geschrieben,
es ist nicht nur Unterhaltung oder wie auch immer. auch immer,
wenn ich sage, es ist ein Schlüsselroman oder wenn es heißt,
es ist ein Schlüsselroman, auch wenn ich dann immer alles anders behaupte.
Und das war's. Ich musste dann nach zwei Stunden gehen. Er ist ja dann in so
einer Plauderlaune, aus der er dann irgendwie nicht rauskommt.
Keine Ahnung, wie lange es noch ging.
Es gibt doch eigentlich noch einen Special Guest oft.
Nie. Also die Erzählungen sind bis zu den letzten Jahren, wenn er so diese Dialogbände
macht, dann spielt das Buch gar keine Rolle, sondern er macht auf der Bühne einfach Halligalli.
In dieser Runde gar nicht. Also es war wirklich ganz betrüblich zu sehen, auch ärmlich.
Und ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es doch alles in allem,
nachdem mir das Buch ja sehr gefallen hat, ich habe es ja sehr gelobt im Salon,
drumherum so ein lebloses,
schwanzeingezogenes Garnichts stattfindet, sondern irgendwie,
finde ich, stellt er sich seiner Verantwortung, seinem Selbstauftrag dann doch nicht.
Also ich bin so rausgegangen aus der Veranstaltung, war natürlich auch nicht
alleine. Deswegen hat sich das Gespräch da gleich so hochgeschaukelt im Sinne
von, ja, das war ja echt mega mies. Können wir uns das irgendwie erklären? Nee, nicht so richtig.
Deswegen nur meine Vermutung. Da sitzen irgendwie rechts drei Anwälte und links
drei Anwälte, die voneinander wissen, aber sich nicht kennen und dann kann das sein.
Ja, so ist es möglich. Ich glaube einfach, dass er da gar nicht so viel inhaltlich
zu bieten hat. Ich war ja sehr viel kritischer dem Buch gegenüber.
Das kann auch sein.
Man kann das alles im Salon nochmal nachhören und vielleicht eine Sache,
er hat einen sehr hohen Vorschuss sicherlich bekommen, astronomisch hoch vermutlich.
Aber ich glaube, dass das Buch am Ende für den Verlag kein großer Gewinn ist.
Denn dieses Buch ist jetzt nach sehr wenigen Wochen schon nur noch auf Platz
8 der Spiegel-Bestsellerliste.
Das heißt, was...
Er eigentlich hätte verkaufen müssen, wird er vermutlich nicht erreichen.
Wir haben das da mit einem kurzen Strohfeuer zu tun gehabt. Alle,
die Stucki kannten, haben sich draufgestürzt und noch ein paar weitere.
Aber es hat sich dann doch nicht so verbreitet, denn Bücher funktionieren ja
ab zu einem gewissen Punkt tatsächlich über Mundpropaganda.
Und wenn sich aber nicht wirklich herumspricht, das ist jetzt der Roman,
den man lesen muss, dann lässt das auch ganz schnell wieder nach.
Und man hat das bei anderen Autoren, die auch einen guten Anschub haben,
Aber dann muss das Buch auch bei der Leserschaft funktionieren,
sonst geht es nicht durch.
Während wir im nächsten Salon ja über ein Buch sprechen, das seit Wochen auf
Platz 1 der Spiegel-Bestsellerliste Sachbuch ist.
Ich hatte von diesem Buch gar nichts mitbekommen, seitdem du mir davon berichtet
hast, dass wir das doch lesen könnten, sehe ich es jeden Tag irgendwo besprochen, diskutiert.
Und zwar der Osten, eine westdeutsche Erfindung.
Das werden wir also im nächsten Salon lesen von Dirk Oschmann,
das so ein Debattenbuch der Stunde ist. Ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, das steht noch aus.
Ingo Schulze sagt hier als Blurb geliefert, wer über den Beitritt und die Folgen
sprechen will, wird um dieses Buch nicht herumkommen.
Und du warst jetzt auch schon bei Oschmann in Frankfurt. Jetzt darfst du aber
noch nicht zu viel spoilern.
Nein, ich habe auch das Buch noch nicht gelesen. Wir gehen da nochmal drauf
ein. Es war eine Veranstaltung, die fand im Rahmen 175 Jahre Paulskirche.
Wir wissen ja aus den Tagesthemen, das erste gewählte demokratische Parlament
und sagen Nein, ist natürlich nur das erste freie gewählte Parlament von Demokratie
war 48 noch nicht allzu viel zu hören.
Aber die Stadt hat einiges bemüht. Waren auch so ein bisschen die Amtseinführungsfeiertage
für Mike Joseph, war so mein Eindruck.
Und es gab beispielsweise Fragen an die Galerien der Stadt, an die Galerien
der Stadt, könnt ihr nicht auch irgendwas zum Thema machen?
Und da habe ich einen Hinweis bekommen, dass Andreas Mühe, ein Fotograf,
will ich nicht sagen Fotokünstler, mehr so, der sich sehr viel auch so,
also jedenfalls bei dem, was ich jetzt gesehen habe zum Thema,
hat wohl vorher schon eine Schirn- oder Städelausstellung gehabt,
da weiß ich nicht genau, was die zum Thema hat, aber es war sehr historisch.
Angefangen biografisch bedingt familiär und so auch so bei 33,
45 und dann eben diese ostdeutsche teilung andreas
mühr also ostdeutscher und dirk oschmann
westdeutscher der aber in ostdeutschland in leipzig lehrt und andreas mühr hat
seine einladung angenommen von einer galerie eine ausstellung zu machen und
hat sich als gesprächspartner dirk oschmann gewünscht die haben also dann eine
stunde zusammen gesprochen und zwar so dass auch kurz jena winzerland gesprochen wurde,
als Ursprungsort der NSU und ich habe ja selber in Jena-Winzala gewohnt, von meinem 0. bis 17.
Lebensjahr oder so, habe mich deswegen auch in die Diskussion eingemischt und
ich bin jetzt umso gespannter,
wie dieses Buch beschrieben ist, denn man hört ja schon, dass jetzt 30 Jahre
später mit Dirk Oschmann jemand antritt, der die Anliegen der Ostdeutschen aufnimmt.
Das Buch wird ja zu 80 Prozent in Ostdeutschland verkauft, also in In Ostdeutschland
ist es ein Megabestseller, dafür, dass es deutschlandweit jetzt schon so gut
positioniert ist und Dirk Oschmann aber nicht den Jammerton mitbringt,
sondern mal einen anderen.
Und zwar auch nicht diesen neu arroganten AfD-Ton natürlich,
dass man jetzt so selbstbehauptungsmäßig da irgendwie völlig neben der Spur
argumentiert, sondern es bringt einen neuen Ton mit.
Und ich hab dann in der Veranstaltung, in der ich war, und das ist der Teaser
für den Salon, auch so gedacht, hm, nachdem ich mich jetzt in meinen eigenen
Podcasts immer so wahnsinnig lustig gemacht habe über die Ostdeutschen und ihre
völlig verqueren Anliegen.
Vielleicht ist das ja für mich jetzt auch mal wieder ein Thema,
so irgendwie so als, klar, ich war sieben, als die Mauer fiel.
Ich kenne eigentlich nicht wirklich eine DDR und so.
Aber vielleicht ist jetzt wirklich, Dirk Oschmann hat da noch Anmerkungen dazu
gemacht, so eine besondere Zeit, sich das noch mal anzuschauen.
Es sind ja durchaus viele Umbrüche gerade, die man so hat,
also Abflauen oder beziehungsweise Umkehr, dieser Wanderungs-Migrationswelle innerdeutsch,
dann diese Neuorientierung durch unser Verhältnis zu Amerika und Russland,
das ja gerade ganz neu sortiert wird oder auch werden soll, wie auch immer.
Wir sprechen ja gleich über Patriotismus, da spielt natürlich der Osten auch nochmal eine Rolle.
Und dann eben, und das ist ja besonders für Frankfurt interessant,
klar, man kann jetzt zurückblicken auf 1848, das erste frei gewählte Parlamentarismus,
der allerdings, was jetzt kollektive Bindung, folgenlos bleibt.
Gleichzeitig jetzt, aber 175 Jahre später, wollen wir ja eigentlich so einen
Aufbruch nach Europa wagen. Wenn wir mal feststellen, diese Probleme,
die wir jetzt auf Top 1 bis 17 nennen, die sind alle nur global,
aber mindestens europäisch lösbar, aber deutsch jedenfalls nicht.
Und dass jetzt plötzlich eine deutsch-deutsche Debatte wieder aufkommt durch
so ein Buch, das wirklich aus heiterem Himmel kam.
Von einem Literaturwissenschaftler.
Das noch dazu, genau. Also es ist, ja, da können wir sehr gespannt sein.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie wir dieses Buch dann lesen.
Und wo wir gerade vom Salon sprechen, kann man jetzt den Salon,
wie gehabt, buchen über Steady, was wir präferieren,
über Apple, man kann auch über den Spotify-Link dann direkt oder den Button
direkt zu Steady kommen,
man hat noch Patreon, aber es gibt jetzt in diesem Monat etwas Besonderes,
das musst du erklären, man kann jetzt auch ein Schnupper-Abo machen,
das heißt man kann einen Monat gratis testen.
Einmal im Jahr meldet sich ja Apple und Steady bei uns.
Das machen die wohl bei allen möglichen Podcasts. Wir sind zum Beispiel bei
Apple der erste Podcast überhaupt gewesen, der die Paywall-Funktion in Apple
Podcast nutzt, ohne von Apple aus darauf hingewiesen worden zu sein.
Die gehen natürlich zu den Redaktionen und stellen das so vor. Als Vertriebsmodell.
Wir sind die ersten, die das aus eigenen freien Stücken verwendet haben.
Also kamen die dann auf uns zu und jetzt haben sie wieder mit uns gesprochen
und auch mit Steady kam so die Idee auf, wir könnten ja einen Monat mal diese
üblichen hier 30 Tage lang testen. Natürlich immer mit diesem Kniff.
Du buchst, hinterlegst deine Zahlungsbereitschaft und wenn du das Angebot,
also wenn es dir gefällt, bleibst du dabei und dann wird ab dem zweiten Monat gezahlt.
Oder aber man nimmt sich vor, okay, die nächsten 30 Tage sind mein Salon Monat.
Jeden Tag höre ich eine Folge aus dem Archiv und am 29. Tag kündige ich alles.
Das geht natürlich auch. Wir laden zu allem ein, würde ich ganz frei sagen.
Aber es wird ab jetzt für die, also für den Monat Juni bis zum Ende des Monats
ist es möglich Testmonat bei Apple und bei Steady einzugehen.
Und das ist eben genau, wie man das aus allen anderen Angeboten auch kennt,
es ist einfach ein Testenmonat. Dann kann man sich entscheiden,
ob man bleibt oder nicht.
Wer nicht testen will, sondern gleich dabei sein möchte, kann natürlich auch
normal buchen, kann auch das JA direkt buchen, ganz wie es beliebt.
Und es gibt ja in diesem Monat zusätzlich ja nicht nur den Salon,
sondern auch noch den Live-Salon in Frankfurt.
Treffen wir uns ja wieder in der case und bereiten dann noch ein buntes potpourri
vor wir schauen mal was ich habe so ein paar themen liegen lassen in diesem
monat zum beispiel die omr das omr festival. Oh ja das war sehr schön.
Da fand ja doch einiges statt ich weiß nicht wie viel du da schon gesehen hast.
Ich habe auch schon mich sehr amüsiert aber das geht noch mal gut vor publikum.
Lust, Stress, Zeug. Denn um nur eine Sache anzumerken, die haben ja wirklich
eine wahnsinnig riesengroße Bühne.
Also die mussten ja so viele Leute, 7000 Leute vor ihrer Mainstage springen,
dass sie zum einen auf der Bühne sich fragten, was macht man eigentlich?
Ich finde, das Bühnendesign war besonders gut gelungen. Also so ein Hamburger
Messe, man kennt ja vielleicht den CCC, diese Chaos Communication Veranstaltungen,
die fand ja auch jahrelang in Leipzig in einem Messesaal statt.
Aber da war die große Bühne mit 4000 Leute Publikum und hinten noch aufstehende Tribüne und so.
Das war schon groß. Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, hey, 7000 Leute vor einer
Bühne, wie macht man das eigentlich?
Naja, man hat noch ein DJ-Pult oben drauf und eine Bar.
Das heißt, nachdem die Keynote gehalten wurde, kommt ein Moderator,
dem von der Natürlichkeit Pflaume, wer sonst, auf die Bühne,
holt dann den Keynote-Spiegel ab, geht mit ihnen 20 Meter rüber.
Da ist eine Bar. Der Keynote-Spiegel kriegt erstmal ein Bier angeboten.
Währenddessen werden Nachfragen an die anderen.
Der Bühnenraum muss ganz bespielt werden.
Ja, ich fand das gar nicht unclever von der Methodik her, aber inhaltlich.
Ist die Frage, was machen wir eigentlich auf der Bühne vor 7000 Leuten natürlich
viel schwieriger und ich würde vielleicht die These in den Raum stellen,
gar nicht zu beantworten. Wie kann man 7000 Leute, also vor Ort, bespielen?
Und in der Keynote, die die beiden Macher da selber halten, war deswegen auch
gefühlt, sag ich jetzt, jeder zweite Satz, und damit ihr was nach Hause nehmt.
Und damit sich die 400 Euro auch gerechtfertigt haben und so weiter und so fort.
Also sie waren die ganze Zeit unter Legitimationsdruck, den sie sich selber
gestellt haben, obwohl ich denke, wenn da 70.000 Leute kommen,
ist doch egal, was auf der Bühne stattfindet, die treffen sich da halt,
trinken irgendwie ein Bier zusammen und dann fahren sie alle wieder nach Hause,
bezahlt ja jedes Unternehmen.
Das ist dann so ein kleiner Firmenurlaub, den man da macht.
Du musst nur irgendeine Rahmung, glaube ich, schaffen. Man kann nicht einfach
sagen, wir treffen uns nur so.
Genau.
Wir treffen uns einfach zum Saufen.
Diese Rahmung, also das Festivalprogramm, was dann auch die Kostenstelle des
Arbeitgebers nachlesen kann, die musste halt inhaltlich aufgefüllt werden.
Und genau so illustre, wie man sich das dann vorstellt, dass das quasi nur Kulisse war.
Genau so verlegen standen da noch einige auf der Bühne und wussten gar nicht
genau, was soll ich denn jetzt hier eigentlich? Also in der Hinsicht,
das wird, glaube ich, ganz heiter, wenn wir da nochmal reingucken.
Denn über die kann man sich auch lustig machen. Die haben da ausreichend Geld
verdient. Alle Learnings sind gedroppt.
Ich glaube, da hat keiner was dagegen. Genau, es werden immer Learnings gedroppt.
Und die Bucketlist wird abgefahren.
Die Bucketlist wird abgearbeitet. Aber das glaube ich keiner was dagegen haben,
wenn wir da auch nochmal einen kleinen Fokus drauf werfen. Also so in die Richtung.
Außerdem neue Familienmodelle.
Die Threadwives und so liegen bei mir auch schon eine Weile rum.
Die müssen jetzt auch mal thematisiert werden. Kannst du dir vorstellen, was Thread-Vibes sind?
Nein.
Thread ist die Abkürzung für traditionell. Also es gibt eine neue Konjunktur
von ich möchte lieber traditionell leben.
Ach, das ist auch bei TikTok gibt's ja die, die...
Also Frauen, die sich so im 50er Jahre Look aufleiden und sagen,
eigentlich ist es toll, wenn der Mann arbeiten geht und ich kann zu Hause.
Das Sugar Daddy Ding, aber so, dass man es den Eltern erklären kann.
Ja und das perfide ist dann, das wird aber von TikTokerinnen dann vorgestellt,
die natürlich selbstständig sind und immens viel Geld mit ihrem TikTok Kanal verdienen.
Und jetzt aber ihren Zuschauern einsehen, du musst gar nicht finanziell unabhängig
sein, es ist viel besser, wenn der Mann das ganze Geld verdient.
Genau, die Tradwives überflügeln die Männer, für die sie sich die ganze Zeit
so hübsch machen in ihrem Einkommen, aber müssen halt diese Show weiterziehen.
Ja, es ist wirklich total verdreht.
Aber gut, es wird viel Programm bei uns geben.
Dann gehen wir jetzt zum Monat über und hören als erstes Carla Hinrichs von
der letzten Generation.
Denn wir haben alle mitbekommen, es gab Hausdurchsuchungen bei der letzten Generation.
Verdacht, der im Raum steht, handelt es sich um eine terroristische Vereinigung.
Werden Sie vielleicht in den Untergrund gehen?
Wo ist vielleicht noch Uhu und anderer Kleber versteckt? Wir hören mal, was sie sagt.
Man kann es sich kaum vorstellen. Man kennt es nur aus dem Film.
Plötzlich wacht man auf, weil gegen deine Tür gedonnert wird.
Man wacht auf, weil Polizei geschrien wird. Und plötzlich steht ein Polizist
mit schusssicherer Weste vor deinem Bett und richtet eine Waffe auf dich.
Dann durchsuchen sie alles. Dann nehmen sie alles mit, was eigentlich zu deinem Alltag gehört.
Das macht Angst. Sie machen mir Angst.
Sie versuchen mir Angst zu machen, weil wir jeden Tag allen vor Augen führen,
dass diese Regierung gerade ihre Verfassung bricht, dass diese Regierung gerade
ihre eigenen Kinder in die Klimahölle schickt. Ich habe Angst.
Der Einsatzleiter hatte selber Kinder. Ich habe ihn gefragt.
Ich habe ihm von der Katastrophe erzählt. Ich habe ihm erzählt, wovor ich Angst habe.
Ich habe Angst davor, dass dieser Staat seinen Beamtinnen in meine Wohnung stürmen
lässt mit gezogener Waffe.
Aber so viel mehr Angst habe ich davor, dass er uns in diese Katastrophe rasen
lässt, dass er seine eigenen Bürgerinnen in diese Katastrophe rasen lässt und nichts dagegen tut.
Es ist immer ein bisschen im Stile des Poetry Slam vorgetragen.
Sie liest ja auch. Ich habe jetzt gerade gedacht,
ich habe ja von Stuckhardt Barreff nichts gelesen, nichts gelesen außer
noch wach und die erste seite solo album ja die genau das beschreibt ja du liegst
im bett und dann klopft es an der tür und du weißt nicht was ist denn das könnte
die polizei sein und so und das ist ja wie wir hören pop weltliteratur geworden
sind natürlich die zeiten in der das heute in so einem tiktok video versendet
wird weil das hätte bestimmt auch noch einen guten aufmacher gegeben irgendwo
als text wahrscheinlich.
So für die Boomer zum Nachlesen.
Wir überlegen jetzt aber mal, was sie inhaltlich sagt. Sie sagt,
da sind Beamten, die kommen mit der gezogenen Waffe, gehen sie da rein.
Also die Staatsgewalt steht plötzlich am Bett.
Und sie hat gar nicht nur Angst davor, sondern auch Angst davor,
dass der Staat uns in die Katastrophe rasen lässt.
Das heißt, hier gibt es also eine Diskrepanz zwischen dem Staat,
Man könnte auch noch hinzufügen der Regierung oder den Regierungen,
das sind ja Landesregierungen und Bund, da sind ja verschiedene dran beteiligt, und seinen Bürgern.
Diese Differenz machen wir ja für gewöhnlich immer mal wieder aus und fest und
das ist auch eigentlich nichts ungewöhnliches und es ist ja sehr erstaunlich,
wie man im Zuge des Ukraine-Krieges, Also um schon mal eine Pointe vorweg zu
nehmen, wie man im Zuge des Ukraine Krieges von linksliberaler Seite plötzlich
den Staat nicht mehr kritisierte, sondern jetzt ist das alles gut.
Also wir hatten die ganze Zeit, die Bundeswehr ist rechtsradikal und was weiß
ich, das wurde von linksliberal die ganze Zeit gesagt. Plötzlich aber ist Militär
super. Jetzt wollen wir darüber nicht mehr reden.
Dann überlegt man, naja, ist eigentlich das, was in der Regierung tut,
identisch mit dem, was eine Bevölkerung will? Nee, kann ja nicht.
Wir wählen zwar, aber wir haben ja jetzt auch nicht alle die SPD gewählt mit
dem Bundeskanzler Scholz.
Da haben wir schon eine Koalition. Wie geht das eigentlich zusammen?
Aber wir haben tatsächlich eine doch sehr,
sehr interessante Verschiebung gerade im Zuge von Krieg, Aufrüstung und Militarisierung,
dass man eigentlich davon ausgeht, dass die großen Staatsinteressen.
Immer identisch sind mit den Bevölkerungsinteressen und wenn die Bevölkerung
aber dann plötzlich doch nicht für Panzerlieferungen ist, dann haben die das
nur noch nicht richtig verstanden.
Also das hatten wir ja auch beim Salon, als wir noch mal diese Wälzer-Studie vorgestellt haben.
Und hier aber zeigt sich jetzt, und es sind im übrigen dieselben Leute,
die diese Identität jetzt herstellen zwischen Staat und Bevölkerung,
Die jetzt aber wieder in ihr altes und in meinen Augen auch richtiges Muster
zurückfallen und sagen, ja Moment, was macht denn der Staat da?
Das kann ja nicht angehen, dass Leute nur, weil sie sich auf einer Straße mal
festkleben, plötzlich wie Terroristen behandelt werden.
Also da sieht man dann plötzlich wieder eine Staatskritik zurückkommen,
die vorher in dem ganzen Kriegsdiskurs überhaupt nicht da ist oder wo man dann
in komische Ecken gestellt wird.
Ich nutze das jetzt als Entrebele, diese Äußerung da von Carla Hinrichs,
um auf eine andere Debatte zu kommen, nämlich die Patriotismus-Debatte.
Mehr Patriotismus wagen will die CDU.
Aber sagen die auch, mehr Patriotismus wagen?
So sagen sie es nicht, ich sage sehr ganz genau, wie sie es sagen.
Die Beratung des Antrages der Fraktion der CDU und CSU mit dem Titel Verfassung
und Patriotismus als verbindendes Band stärken Tag des Grundgesetzes am 23.
Mai als Gedenktag aufwerten Patriotismus als verbindendes Band stärken Das ist
angesagt und darüber hat man im Bundestag debattiert.
Wir hören jetzt erstmal von der CDU, was die denn da vorhaben.
Wir wollen deshalb den Tag des Grundgesetzes als Gedenktag mit einer Großveranstaltung
aller deutschen Verfassungsorgane aufwerten.
Wir wollen mit einem Bundesprogramm Patriotismus dazu beitragen,
dass die Berliner Republik ihre gebührende Form der Repräsentation unseres Staates findet.
Und wie dringend das notwendig ist, das zeigte auch kürzlich erst der Besuch
von König dem dritten hier in Berlin.
What?
Ja.
Wie ist das? Also das ist eine These. Wie lautet das Argument dazu?
Das Argument dazu lautet, sie erwähnt dann noch, es gab da ja einen Artikel
in der Berliner Zeitung,
der minutiös aufgeführt hat, wie schlecht die Deutschen, und damit sind jetzt
gemeint, also die deutsche Regierung Steinmeier und Co, sowie auch die Bundeswehr
sich nach außen repräsentieren.
Da waren mitunter lustige Formulierungen, dass die Stiefel der Bundeswehr aussehen
wie umgedrehte Knobelbecher und so weiter.
Und das war aber eine reine Stilkritik.
Da war also die Frage, wieso kann der Bundespräsident nicht mal einen vernünftigen Mantel tragen?
König Charles kann es doch auch. Das ging also um etwas ganz anderes.
Und das war einfach die Frage, warum muss der Deutsche immer so in seiner Funktionsjacken-Mäßigkeit
auftreten, während die Briten mehr Stil haben.
Hier, das wird aber jetzt verknüpft damit, dass man sagt, wir brauchen mal mehr
Patriotismus und mehr Verfassungstreue, damit man wieder nach außen strahlt.
Hat sie, also sie hat Bezug auf diesen Besuch von Prinz Charles in Deutschland genommen,
oder König Charles, aber wenn man sich die Krönung anschaut,
also was dem König übergezogen wurde,
der goldene Mantel, der Gürtel, das Dings hier und so, und dann musst du ja
die ganzen Armreifen, Pi, Pa, Pu, und dann kommt Prinz William als Thronfolger
in diesem blauen Mantel mit der Scherpe, mit der Schleppe, mit dem ganzen Charme,
das sah alles ziemlich albern aus.
Und als der König dann in seine goldene Kutsche stieg, um zuerst mal zu den
Truppen zu fahren und die haben dann ihre 50 Zentimeter hohen Fellhüte da in
die Luft gestreckt, um Hurra zu rufen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob dieses Argument sehr weit trägt, das an der Mode aufzuhängen.
Wir haben ja auch den Kölner Karneval dafür, man braucht das nicht unbedingt.
Ich würde aber auch sagen, dass man schon erkennen kann, wie Prinz oder König
Charles sich in einem Anzug oder eine Mantel bewegt und wenn ich dann Herrn
Steinmeier sehe, das ist ausbaufähig.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, als CDU-Abgeordneter würde ich mich da ein bisschen zurückhalten.
Wir können gerne mal über Modesünden bei der Union sprechen.
Das wäre ein ganz eigenes Thema.
Wir hier in Frankfurt mit Mike Joseph, der immer einen Anzug und zum Teil sich
auch in zwei Reiher traut, können gar nicht klagen.
Prima. Ich gratuliere. Steinmeier war ja da zu 175 Jahren, da hat man gesehen,
wer hier die Hosen anhat.
Aber du siehst, es geht hier dann doch um was anderes, also mehr Patriotismus.
Hören Sie mal weiter, Andrea Lindholz.
Wollen wir Deutsche, wollen wir im 21. Jahrhundert uns selbst überhaupt noch als Nation verstehen?
An einer Antwort hierzu hat sich bereits 2010 der damalige Vorsitzende der Landtagsfraktion
der Grünen in Schleswig-Holstein versucht.
Wir erinnern uns, es war Robert Habeck, der in seinem Buch Patriotismus ein
linkes Plädoyer behauptete,
und zwar allen Ernstes, dass die Deutschlandfahnen der Fußball-WM 2006 nicht
etwa signalisiert haben, dass wir ein Volk sind, sondern dass wir Fans sind.
Er bekannte darin offen, dass er mit Deutschland eigentlich nichts anzufangen
wisse und er wisse es auch bis heute nicht.
Sein progressives Weltbild gipfelte in der Aussage, es sei möglich,
eine Art von Patriotismus zu entwickeln, der letztendlich Deutschland gar nicht brauche.
Es wird hier transparent, es handelt sich um einen Kulturkampf gegen die Grünen,
der jetzt von Seiten der Union angezettelt wird.
Da kämpft sie auch gegen Windmühlen, also ausgedachte Gegner,
denn ich war ja, und ich habe es noch vor Augen, Robert Habeck war ja mit Alain
Linaire-Baerbock hier in Frankfurt auf dem Römerberg und da war ich ja auch
und habe mir das mal angehört,
mir die Show angesehen und ja, da ging es viel um dieses Thema,
aber genau mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen würde ich sagen, denn Robert Habeck hat
zum einen das Thema Freiheit für sich reklamiert und dann noch mal ausdrücklich
betont, Wir müssen uns auch die deutsche Flacke zurückerobern.
Also sie quasi wieder zur Geltung bringen. Und zwar nicht unter der Maxime,
eigentlich brauchen wir sie nicht mehr. Sondern wir wollen damit wieder was
darstellen, was die neuen Rechtsradikale nicht damit darstellen.
Ich hab mir die Passage rausgesucht aus dem Buch, die sie wohl meint.
Da heißt es, man braucht es, um eine sinnstiftende politische Erzählung zu schaffen,
dass Veränderungen gut sind und es sich lohnt, für sie zu streiten.
Man braucht eine Erzählung, die auf Veränderung setzt, auf Gerechtigkeit und Internationalität.
Gut, Erzählung ist natürlich das, alle reden heute von Narrativen.
Dieses Engagement nenne ich einen linken Patriotismus. Ich schreibe das im vollen
Bewusstsein, dass ich Widerspruch provozieren werde.
Patriotismus, Vaterlandsliebe also, fand ich stets zum Kotzen.
Ich wusste, mit Deutschland nichts anzufangen und weiß es bis heute nicht.
Dann geht sie weiter und sagt, er glaubt an einen Patriotismus jenseits von Deutschland.
Ich verstehe absolut, was er da meint. Dass es nicht darum geht,
dass man Deutschland los wird. Dass das antipatriotisch ist.
Man kann den Grünen nicht mangelnden Patriotismus vorwerfen.
Eher im Gegenteil. Da sehe ich eher das Problem drin, wenn sie sagt,
dass Habeck meint, man könne auch patriotisch sein.
Man könne auch patriotisch sein ohne Deutschland. Ich habe den Verdacht,
dass die Leute, die nicht konservativ und rechts sind, Ciao.
Nicht patriotisch sein können aus geschichtlichen Gründen und das auch ein bisschen
schmuddelig finden, das Deutschlandfälschchen sich ans Auto zu heften und so weiter.
Aber sie haben mitunter, das ist also meine Unterstellung jetzt hier,
doch diesen großen Wunsch, irgendwie schon patriotisch zu sein.
Aber ist halt doof gerade so mit dem 20. Jahrhundert, was Deutschland da angerichtet hat.
Und deswegen gibt es eine Tendenz bei, ich sage mal, Linksliberalen,
die patriotische Gefühle haben wollen, ihren Patriotismus zu übertragen wo anders hin.
Gerne auf andere Länder. Ich würde sagen, dass man schon sehr deutlich jetzt
gerade merken kann, dass der Patriotismus der Ukrainer etwas ist,
was ein gutes Sinnangebot ist.
Dann kann man patriotisch sein, kann diesen Patriotismus toll finden,
kann selbst auch ein kleiner Patriot sein, ohne dass man das auf Deutschland beziehen muss.
Man hat das immer wieder in linken Kreisen gehabt. Das wird auch auf andere Länder übertragen.
Es gibt da genügend Beispiele, dass man immer wieder ein Volk sucht,
den man seinen Patriotismus, wo man seinen Patriotismus überstülpen kann und
ich würde sagen, das findet jetzt gerade so ein bisschen mit der Ukraine statt
und deswegen auch dieses besondere Engagement da.
Ich erinnere mich gerade an Rolf-Dieter
Krause, der ja sehr lange Brüssel-Korrespondent in der ARD war,
so eng mit Merkel, dass er dann ihr auch,
ich melde mich noch mal bei Ihnen bei der letzten Pressekonferenz inklusive
dann Abschiedsparty und so,
Und der saß kürzlich in der Phoenix-Runde und hat zum Krieg mitgesprochen und meinte dann,
nee, wir können die Ukraine gar nicht in die EU aufnehmen, weil dort zu viel
glühender Patriotismus einer eigentlich europäischen, etwas übergeordneten Idee im Wege steht.
Wurde ihm natürlich vehement widersprochen, aber im Lichte deiner Ausführungen
heißt das ja jetzt, Ja klar, und es ist nicht nur der überbordende ukrainische
Nationalismus, sondern auch...
Unser Anhängsel, also allein unser deutscher, ukrainischer Patriotismus steht
eigentlich dieser europäischen Idee im Wege.
Denn anders ist es ja auch nicht zu erklären, dass es diese große Identitätsdebatte gibt.
Zwar hier, dass wir die ganze Zeit sagen, wie plural wir sind,
wir die ganze Zeit von denen sprechen, die nicht repräsentiert werden in unserer Gesellschaft.
Man aber, wenn über die Ukraine gesprochen wird, man immer glaubt,
das ist die Ukraine und damit ist alles gesagt. Aber wir kommen gleich dazu.
Wir hören nämlich da jetzt mal den ganz klaren Kontrast gleich.
Wir hören noch einmal Lindholz.
Die CDU, CSU-Bundestagsfraktion ist daher der Auffassung, dass Grundgesetz und
Patriotismus in der Zeitenwende starke Potenziale zum Wohl von Staat und Gesellschaft entfalten können.
Wir wollen, dass der Reichstag als parlamentarisches
Zentrum patriotische Selbstvergewisserung gestärkt werden.
Hierher gehören Porträts bedeutender Parlamentarier und Bilder der deutschen
Nationalgeschichte hin, die auch zeigen, auf welchen Traditionen unsere heutige Demokratie beruht.
Also wollen sich so ein bisschen schmücken.
Kurze Erlebnis-Impressionsanekdote. Also wie gesagt, Frankfurt feiert 175 Jahre
Paulskirche und öffnet dafür auch das Rathaus.
Tag der offenen Tür. Ich nehme meine Kinder so mit Und wir gehen da hin und
ich sag dann so, komm, da können wir uns mal Meiks Büro angucken und so überhaupt.
Und wir kommen in den Kaisersaal und ich denke mir so, der ist ja eigentlich
nicht für die Öffentlichkeit da. Also gehe ich mir mal die Kaiser angucken, die da oben.
Komme ich in den Saal, ist jeder Kaiser zugehangen mit einem Porträt einer wichtigen
Frau aus der letzten hundertjährigen Politikgeschichte, wo ich auch dachte,
ist ganz cool, das zu machen.
Aber irgendwann hätte ich dann doch gern mal die Kaiser gesehen.
Ich kann ja nicht einfach hier reinkommen in den Kaisersaal und mir den Kaiser
mal anschauen, sondern das ist die Gelegenheit gewesen und sie wurde mir verwehrt.
Zum Glück hat die CDU-Bundestagsfraktion davon keinen Wind bekommen,
sonst hätte die einen Kulturschampf gemacht.
Du weißt ja, die CDU dreht ja völlig durch, also man findet ja nur noch nur noch kuriose Sachen da.
Es gab ja beispielsweise irgendeine Politikerin,
die in einer Kantine vegetarisch gegessen hat und musste sich dann gleich,
ich glaube das war im Saarland, und musste sich dann gleich erklären der CDU-Politikerin,
dass sie sonst sehr, sehr gerne Fleisch isst.
Also man muss nochmal betonen, ich esse mindestens fünf Kilo Schwein die Woche,
sonst bin ich auch kein richtiger Deutscher im Prinzip.
Und die AfD hat sich auch dazu geäußert und ist eigentlich ganz einverstanden.
Ganz kurz, Christian Wirth.
Ein Tag des Grundgesetzes ist ein guter Anfang. Ich wünsche mir noch mehr. Vielen Dank. Glück auf.
Glück auf.
Wir hören uns jetzt gar nicht die ganzen Äußerungen von SPD und Co an,
die das natürlich kritisieren, denn es ist so furchtbar langweilig.
Denn jetzt, sie sind schon über das Stöckchen gesprungen, das die CDU hingehalten hat.
Man könnte ja jetzt einfach so voll dagegen sein, aber nein,
alle, fast alle Abgeordneten kommen erstmal hin und sagen, Das Grundgesetz ist
für uns etwas, worauf wir ganz besonders stolz sein können.
Und wir gerade mit unserer Geschichte. Also das ist dieses, was wir immer wieder
auch in Talkshows erleben. Man muss erst nochmal sagen, der völkerrechtswidrige,
genozidale russische Angriffskrieg Putins und so weiter.
Und so muss man jetzt auch noch mal sich ganz klar bekennen,
wo ich denke, ja, du bist Abgeordneter im Bundestag, vermutlich findest du das
Grundgesetz relativ gut so an sich.
Hier mal ein Beispiel, Lukas Benner von den Grünen.
Wie glücklich können wir uns schätzen, dieses Grundgesetz zu haben,
diese unglaubliche Erfolgsgeschichte.
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und die Wahrung von Grundrechten sind aber keine Selbstverständlichkeit.
Das wird bei einem Blick in die Welt deutlich. In die Ukraine,
wo Russland seinen grausamen Vernichtungskrieg fortsetzt.
Nach Iran, wo das Regime erst vor wenigen Tagen wieder weitere Demonstranten hingerichtet hat.
In die USA, wo im Bundesstaat Florida unter Gouverneur Ron DeSantis Schulunterricht
über Homosexualität verboten und somit essentielle Freiheiten drastisch eingeschränkt wurden.
Und ich finde es unerträglich, mit welcher Gleichgültigkeit unsere Gesellschaft
inzwischen hingenommen hat, dass jedes Jahr tausende Menschen im Mittelmeer tritt.
Das Grundgesetz wurde in den letzten 74 Jahren immer wieder an neue Realitäten
angepasst. Der Artikel 87a, das Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr,
ist der jüngste Ausdruck davon.
Hat sich einfach entschieden, irgendwas mal zu erzählen.
Also über diese Minute könnte man natürlich stundenlang reden.
Ich will nur eine Sache aufgreifen.
Unsere Gesellschaft hat hingenommen, wie viele Menschen im Mittelmeer sterben.
Also unsere Gesellschaft nimmt ja ziemlich viel hin, weil wir haben eine Arbeitsteilung.
In Berlin werden Gesetze gemacht, überall anders wird Essen,
Kleidung, Technik, was auch immer hergestellt.
So die Menschen, die Gesellschaft, die also nicht daran beteiligt sind,
direkt darüber zu entscheiden, wie viel Geld kriegt jetzt Frontex,
wie viel Honorare gibt es für Pushbacks und so weiter und so fort.
Die würden ja alles mitmachen, genauso unbesehen und unhinterfragt.
Ob man nun die Menschen im Mittelmeer auffängt oder halt sich ihrem Schicksal überlässt.
Deswegen ist es so ein bisschen perfide, wenn jemand, der in der Regierungsfraktion
mit darüber entscheidet, was da passiert, plötzlich an die Gesellschaft abwälzt,
dass die das ja einfach so geschehen lassen.
Ich meine, das ist seine Verantwortung. Er muss diese Anträge schreiben.
Wir haben ihn eigentlich gewählt, um, wenn er das nicht gut findet, dagegen vorzugehen.
Das ist ein Bundestagsmandat, also das zeichnet es aus im Vergleich zu den 84
Millionen, die keins haben.
In der Sicht ist das besonders gut.
So eine Feierstunde zum Thema Grundgesetz zu machen und dann genau so einen
Satz dazu sagen, das ist wirklich Hanebüchen.
Es wäre ein bisschen, als würden wir unserem Publikum sagen,
ihr seid es, die jetzt das Thema Patriotismus aufgegriffen habt.
Nee, wir zwei sind es, die das gemacht haben.
Genau, wir machen es für euch.
Das ist eine arbeitsteilige Gesellschaft, sehr eigenartig,
vor allem das Thema Migration ist ja ein vollkommen verfahrenes,
wir werden das gleich an einem Detail nochmal sehen, ja später an einem Detail nochmal sehen,
aber wir haben jetzt die Migrationsdebatte, kommt ja im Juni dann in Europa,
die Verschärfung, die da vorgenommen wird und die schon vorgenommen wurden, sind ja katastrophal.
Also das ist ja tatsächlich so, dass man sagen würde, das hätte sich jetzt die
CDU vor zehn Jahren nicht erträumen lassen, was jetzt von so einer linksliberalen
Regierung wohl durchgesetzt wird.
Während man ja selten so Hinterbänkler hört, kommt mir gerade der Gedanke,
eigentlich müssten wir auch so eine Kategorie einführen, einen Namen,
den man sich nicht merken muss.
Meistens, also klar, der Bundestag ist so groß wie nie, das größte Parlament
der Welt nach diesen kommunistischen Apparaten, dass man dann sagt,
okay, 700 Menschen haben jetzt die Chance, uns zu zeigen, was sie können.
Man hört die dann so und hofft ja eigentlich, zum Glück ist der im Bundestag,
zum Glück haben wir den ausgewählt, zum Glück hat der die Ochsen-Tour gestartet.
Die Quelle hatten wir ja schon mal hier im Podcast.
Genau, und jetzt hört man aber immer solche Leute, wo man denkt,
Lukas Benner von den Grünen. Einen Namen, den man sich nicht merken muss.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob wir uns den nächsten Namen merken müssen,
den kennen wir schon. Janine Wissler hat sich den Antrag ein bisschen genauer angesehen.
Was sie fordern, ist ein Bundesprogramm Patriotismus, die stärkere Sichtbarkeit
nationaler Symbole, das regelmäßige Singen der Nationalhymne und mehr öffentliche
Gelöbnisse der Bundeswehr.
Abstruse Forderungen und Deutsch-Tümelei, die man sonst in AfD-Anträgen liest.
Auf zweieinhalb Seiten, meine Damen und Herren, kommen die Begriffe Patriotismus,
Nation und National 32 mal vor.
Nation als Begriff ist ganz erstaunlich, denn das war etwas,
was in den 90er Jahren ja hoch umstritten war.
Soll man überhaupt mit diesem Begriff wieder arbeiten? Also es ist immer noch
umstritten, aber es war damals eine große Debatte.
Da gab es ja dann solche Renegaten, vorsichtig gesagt, wie Martin Walser oder
Boto Strauß, eins links, nun plötzlich die Nationen wieder als ein positives Wort ansahen.
Dann gab es diesen Sammelband, die selbstbewusste Nation und die CDU machte
also in dieser Richtung weiter.
Wissler spricht jetzt mal über die eigentliche Spaltung der Gesellschaft.
Sie fordern mehr Patriotismus, um der Spaltung der Gesellschaft entgegenzuwirken.
Meine Damen und Herren, angesichts von steigenden Lebensmittelpreisen,
von steigenden Mieten wissen Menschen nicht mehr, wie sie ihre Rechnungen bezahlen sollen.
Das spaltet die Gesellschaft, dass wenige reicher und viele armer werden.
Aber die Antwort der Union ist, lasst uns die Klassenunterschiede ausblenden
und uns und patriotisch vereinen, alle gemeinsam hinter Schwarz und Weiß.
Abgrenzung zu allen, die nicht dazugehören können oder wollen.
Tatsächlich hat das funktioniert, jetzt schon ziemlich gut. Wir haben im Zuge
des Krieges und der ganzen Auffrüstungsdebatte überhaupt nicht als Hauptthema,
wie schlecht es den Menschen geht.
Wir haben die größten Reallohnverluste seit 2008, das ist ja immens.
Wenn man durch die Stadt geht, sieht man auch im Straßenbild,
wie die Armut zugenommen hat.
Wenn man mit Menschen aus dem bekannten Freundeskreis spricht,
wenn man mit Studenten spricht, dann sieht man, wie prekär die Lage ist.
Und trotzdem zeichnet sich ja nicht irgendwo am Horizont so etwas wie Demonstrationen,
ich will gar nicht Revolution sagen, so was wie Demonstrationen ab.
Das war ja 2008 völlig anders bei Occupy Wall Street. Da war ja schon auch generell was in Bewegung.
Aber dieses Thema Armut ist nur so, wir nehmen es mal zur Kenntnis,
Es gibt eine Meldung dazu.
Ich hatte zum Beispiel auch gar nicht gewusst, wie sehr sich Studenten verschulden
durch diese Studienkredite, also dass die acht Prozent Zinsen zahlen müssen.
Das war mir überhaupt nicht klar.
Das hatte jetzt mal Lukas Scholle bei Twitter ein bisschen verbreitet.
Ich bin völlig entsetzt darüber. Und klar, wenn man nur über Panzer diskutiert
und jetzt auch noch das Deutschlandferienzchen wieder raushalten will,
dann geht das natürlich.
Ja, man kann es ja mal durchspielen. Angenommen, dieser Antrag hat irgendwie Erfolg.
Man hat dann also das, was Wissler gerade vorgelesen hat, mehr Gelöbnisse,
mehr Hymne singen, wie auch immer.
Die Kinder kommen dann morgens in die Schule und singen erstmal die Hymne.
Okay, das sind irgendwie zweieinhalb Minuten des Tages.
Und dann geht man einmal im halben Jahr auf den Marktplatz und guckt ein Gelöbnis
zu, weil es da irgendwie Bratwurst gibt, ist dann auch nochmal sozusagen ein
halber Tag von 150, der dafür aufgewendet ist.
Die Realität ist aber, egal ob man da nochmal eine Minute und da nochmal einen
halben Tag für Deutschland rausholt? Diese Kinder gucken 5 Stunden am Tag TikTok.
Wenn man jetzt an der Realität dieser Kinder irgendwas ändern möchte,
müsste man da heran argumentieren und diesen quasi populistischen linken Whataboutism
von Whistler finde ich genau richtig.
Denn ja, natürlich kann man jetzt nochmal das Deutschlandlied so ein bisschen
singen, aber die Leute bezahlen das ganze Jahr über jeden Tag 10 Prozent mehr
und kriegen 30 Prozent weniger dafür.
Also es greift so richtig ein in ihre Lebensrealität.
Und ich habe auch im Fernsehpodcast, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es hier auch schon mal gemacht habe,
ich bin jetzt immer sehr dafür, ich werbe sehr dafür, dass man,
wenn irgendwer irgendeine Quatschdiskussion aufführt, wie zum Beispiel,
ich saß jetzt auch wieder auf dem Sportplatz, die Kinder haben Handball gespielt,
ich sitze auf so einer Bank, weil es gibt ja nur wenige Banker,
also sitzt man mit irgendwelchen Fremden auf der Bank und dann plötzlich erzählen
die so von der Heizung und der ganze, also als hätte man die Bildzeitung dort
auswendig gelernt, wird einem einfach das der Floskel-Scheiß so vorgetragen.
Also ich saß natürlich nur peripher dabei und so. Und ich denke mir dann immer,
ja, na klar, können wir uns jetzt darüber aufregen, dass irgendein hessischer
CDU-Abgeordneter gesagt hat, diese Kita, also dieses Tilman-Kuban-Ding,
wo er Wert drauf legte, dass das ganz wichtig ist, diese Kita bastelt einmal
im Jahr keine Vatertagsgeschenke mehr.
Nur es gilt eben auch, für alle
700 Kitas in Frankfurt alleine ist die Wasserversorgung nicht gesichert.
Können wir das erstmal diskutieren? Ja. Und dann kommt die Frage,
wie für die Kitas ist die Wasserversorgung?
Ja, für die ganze Stadt ist die Wasserversorgung nicht gesichert.
Achso, echt, wusste ich gar nicht, ja.
Also ich finde, dieser Whataboutism ist jetzt absolut angebracht.
Wenn man bei irgendwelchen familiären Feierlichkeiten ist, klar,
Pfingsten und so ist jetzt alles erstmal rum, aber wenn man irgendwo ist und
es wird Quatsch erzählt, Sagt man einfach.
Ja, aber ein Problem ist doch auch, dass unsere Wasserversorgung nicht gesichert ist. Oder?
Und dann wartet man einfach mal, was so wird aus dem Gespräch.
Aber da bin ich sehr dafür.
Es ist schade, dass es hier Wissler macht, dass sie Wagenknecht so aus der Partei
gedrängt haben, weil diesen Redetext hätte man natürlich jetzt gerne von Wagenknecht
gehört und nicht von Wissler.
Aber vielleicht gut, wenn noch ein paar Stimmen jetzt bei der Linken dieser
Art sind. Und die einer solchen Stimme entgegenhalten, den muss man nicht mehr
vorstellen. Philipp Amthor hier.
Tag des Grundgesetzes als nationaler Gedenktag, eine Rede zur Lage der Nation
und ein Bundesprogramm Patriotismus.
Denn wir finden, nicht nur für ein Verfassungsjubiläum, sondern ganzjährig braucht
es ein Bekenntnis zu Schwarz-Rot-Gold.
Und ich sage das gerade, weil hier Ostdeutschland angesprochen wurde.
Die Wiedervereinigung, die schwarz-rot-goldenen Fahnen, dieser schwarz-rot-goldene
Glücksmoment der Freiheitsmut der Ostdeutschen.
Das ist eines der größten patriotischen Glücksmomente, den wir in unserer Geschichte
erlebt haben. Darauf sind wir auch stolz, liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Also ...
Ja, Philipp Amthor war das natürlich ein besonderes Anliegen.
Man kann sich's denken, der war viel auf Sendung jetzt mit diesem Thema.
Genau. Er ist ein ... Also, wenn man immer so an Patriotismus zusammenhält, die Idee und so weiter.
Wenn einer neben Patriotismus partikulare Interessen nach vorne gestellt hat,
dann doch wohl Philipp Amthor. Und ich will nur darauf hinweisen,
wir sind jetzt im Mai auch in diesem.
Andrea Tandler, Tochter des ehemaligen CSU-Ministers Gerold Tandler, also seine Partei.
Es ist zwar jetzt nicht die Mecklenburg-Vorpommerische CSU, sondern die CDU,
aber aus dieser christlich-sozialen und demokratischen Union wurde jetzt die
Nachricht bekannt, Andrea Tandler hat nicht nur sich an Masken bereichert,
sondern währenddessen auch noch,
23,5 Millionen Euro Steuern hinterzogen.
Das ist schon ein Skandal für sich. Und dann höre ich im Deutschlandfunk,
wie mir noch dazu gesagt wird, außerdem hat sie noch 9.000,
Elfe Corona Soforthilfe beantragt, die aber inzwischen zurückgezahlt.
Wie kann man denn Millionen und Millionen, so viele Millionen verdienen,
illegalerweise, dass man, dass allein die Steuerschuld 23 Millionen Euro übertrifft.
Ja, das muss ja ein grundlegender Betrag, der hier durchdreht, wirklich immens sein.
Wie kann man sich denn da an seinen Schreibtisch setzen und sagen,
9.000 Euro Corona-Soforthilfe beantrage ich jetzt auch noch.
Das ist doch krank. Und solche Leute erzählen uns hier was.
Also die haben solche Leute in ihren Reigen oder sind wie Philipp Amthor, gehören selber dazu.
Die Partei, in der die Väter in der Wirtschaft zu Hause ist,
deswegen fand ich das so besonders eigenartig, die sich immer wieder völlig
von ihrer eigenen Parteigeschichte loslösen können und als Akteure der Weißen Weste auftreten.
Beziehungsweise, vielleicht muss man es anders sehen. Ich habe mich das jetzt
sehr gefragt, ich will jetzt gar nicht, dass wir groß da über diese Greichen
Affäre sprechen, aber...
Die Greichen Affäre, also dass auch die Grünen noch zusammenhalterisch Hochzeiten
begehen, also Trauzeugenschaften aussprechen, das ist ja der ganze Skandal.
Ja, ich finde es ganz erstaunlich, dass diese Trauzeugenschaft als so eine besondere
Nähe empfunden wird. Also ich war zum Beispiel bei jemandem Trauzeuge,
da habe ich überhaupt gar keinen Kontakt mehr zu.
Während ich mit anderen Leuten sehr, sehr viel enger bin, wo aber wahrscheinlich
kaum einer weiß, dass wir so eng sind. Die wüssten das, ließ sich gar nicht nachvollziehen.
Die Trauzeugenschaft von Griechenland ist 23 Jahre her. Die fand wahrscheinlich
noch irgendwie oder knapp im letzten Jahr tausend statt.
Ich meine, dass der Habeck da von seinem Bruder sich einen Preis überreichen
lässt, da fragt man sich dann schon, geht's denn noch? Also kann man dann nicht
sagen, okay, ist ein bisschen albern? Also wir können uns jetzt auch nicht… Was für einen Preis?
Davon habe ich noch gar nicht gehört.
Irgend so einen Umweltpreis haben die sich da gegenseitig… Also ich kann dir
auch gerne beim Leipz Salon… War der notiert?
Ja, wollen wir uns das Preis nicht verleihen im Salon?
Nein, wir können uns gerne gegenseitig Preise verleihen, dass wir wirklich die allergrößten sind.
Also ich will diese Grünen gar nicht da in Schutz nehmen. Ich glaube,
der Unterschied in der Rezeption ist folgender.
Die Grünen sind eine Partei, die einen hohen moralischen Anspruch an andere
und an sich selbst legen.
Dann fallen sie bei den kleinsten Dingen sofort unters Rad.
Während die CDU überhaupt nicht diese moralischen Ansprüche hat.
Und man geradezu erwartet, dass da mal mindestens 23 Millionen Euro Steuern hinterzogen wird.
Darunter macht man es ja gar nicht. Und dass das für viele Leute eher der Ausweis
von Professionalität sind. Die wissen, wie das Business geht,
die lassen sich da nichts vormachen.
Und dass deshalb die CDU aus solchen Skandalen, und seien sie noch so groß,
und der Maskenskandal müsste eigentlich so ein Skandal sein,
dass die für die nächsten 20 Jahre keinen Fuß mehr auf den Boden setzen können.
Dass das nicht bei den Menschen so ankommt, sondern eher noch vielleicht diese
Denkweise ist, die wissen ja schon, wie es geht.
Denn was CDU und FDP auszeichnet, ist ja gerade nicht der Patriotismus,
sondern das laufende Arbeiten gegen die Interessen der Bevölkerung und gegen Staatsinteressen.
Weil der Staat ja laufend als Raubtier, das Steuern haben will,
vorgestellt wird, der Staat muss verschlankt werden, der Staat ist zu übermächtig.
Also eigentlich sind das ja antipatriotische Politiken, die wir dort erleben.
Aber das wird geradezu identifikatorisch von vielen Menschen aufgenommen und
deswegen haben die auch kein Problem mit solchen Skandalen.
Wir hören jetzt von Wissler, was sie zu den Ostdeutschen sagt.
Bemerkenswert bekloppt sind aber die Ausführungen zu Ostdeutschland in Ihrem Antrag.
Schwachstelle der Wiedervereinigung sei, dass Ostdeutsche einen fehlenden Bezug
zur eigenen Nation hätten und deshalb fordern Sie jetzt einen besonderen Einsatz
für patriotische Fragen in Ostdeutschland.
Da können Sie der AfD die Plakate auch gleich selber aufhängen, meine Damen und Herren.
Das Problem in Ostdeutschland ist doch nicht, dass dort so wenig Nationalfahnen
wehen oder dass an Nationalstolz fehlt, an einigen Orten sogar eher das Gegenteil.
Das Problem ist, dass die Löhne und Renten auch nach 30 Jahren niedriger sind
als in Westdeutschland.
Das Problem ist, dass die Treuhand ausgeplündert hat und dass Lebensleistungen
nicht anerkannt wurden.
Das Problem der Wiedervereinigung ist doch nicht, dass da zu wenig Fähnchen
geschwungen wurden und gesungen wurde.
Und wenn Sie die Identifikation mit dem deutschen Staat bei Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
stärken wollen, dann geben Sie
doch endlich mal Ihren Widerstand gegen erleichterte Einbürgerungen auf.
Das merken wir uns jetzt mal mit den erleichterten Einbürgerungen.
Da kommen wir gleich noch mal zu. Wir hören jetzt Linda Teuteberg von der FDP.
Und diese Republik des Grundgesetzes, die wird nicht allein von den gerichtlich
durchsetzbaren Regeln getragen.
Sie lebt auch von einer politischen Kultur, die rechtlich nicht erzwungen werden
kann, sondern die wir mit Leben füllen müssen und die im Alltag stattfinden
muss. Das meinte auch Böckenförder mit seinem berühmten Diktum.
Gemeint sind da alle Symbole und Praktiken, mit denen sich auch ein Land und
eine Gesellschaft ihrer Werte versichert.
Darüber lohnt die Debatte, die, glaube ich, müssen wir im Ausschuss führen und
deshalb werden wir einer Überweisung Ihres Antrages zustimmen.
Findet es also gar nicht so schlecht. Jetzt frage ich dich, die politische Kultur.
Fällt dir da die FDP, wenn du an den Monat zurückdenkst, als erstes ein,
was die Pflege der politischen Kultur anbelangt?
Unbedingt. Also es ging ja beim EFU los.
Das demokratische, politische, parlamentarische Verfahren, auf das sie so stolz
sind, ist schon abgeschlossen gewesen. Plötzlich kam ein Veto und alle so, geht das überhaupt?
Und da hat die FDP eigentlich schon vorgemacht, wir nehmen es zur Not mit ganz Europa auf.
Blamieren Deutschland auf offener Bühne. Und dann hat Habeck irgendwie gedacht,
naja, wenn ich jetzt eine Absprache mit denen treffe, die werden uns ja nicht hängen lassen, oder?
Und die FDP so, naja, also wir lassen ganz Europa hängen, da schaffen wir das
in Deutschland erst recht. Also haben sie das bei dem Heizungsding genauso gemacht.
Ich finde dann immer interessant, dass...
Nur eine parteiinterne sache ist weil der frank schäffler und,
noch so ein paar andere,
leute die auf einem FDP-Parteitag für das ganze Land entscheidet.
Wir torpedieren das jetzt oder stellen einen Fragekatalog von 101 Fragen.
Auch da ist interessant die mediale Rezeption wieder. Die von den Linksliberalen
über alle Maßen verehrte Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann.
Die für jeden Panzer in die Luft springt, taucht jetzt auch in dieser Debatte
auf. auch in dieser Debatte auf und unterstützt ja vollkommen diesen irren FDP-Kurs,
der die Klimatransformation verunmöglicht geradezu.
Aber das wird jetzt nicht mal entsprechend rezipiert, sondern ja,
dann sitzt die wieder bei Mickey Meisens Herz, dann wird gelacht und ha ha ha.
Sie hat ihre tausend Medienauftritte im Jahr, hast du uns ja vorgetragen.
Also sie war jetzt auch im Fernsehen. Ich habe das mit Mick ganz ausführlich
besprochen im Fernseh-Podcast.
Da Da kann man sich wirklich nur drüber lustig machen und man muss sich wirklich
darüber beschweren, dass die Grünen meinem Angebot nicht nachkommen,
dass ich ihr Populismusbeauftragter werde.
Denn zu sehen, wie die FDP alles kurz und klein schlägt und Robert Habeck sich
dann erstens seine Partei diszipliniert im Sinn von nur ich spreche für sie.
Alle anderen werden an die Kette gelegt. Man sieht ja nur irgendwo Jürgen Trittin,
der mal irgendwo draufschlägt.
Sondern dass dann Robert Habeck meint, er hätte sich jetzt wirklich mal durchgerungen
zu einem echten Medien-Stunt, in dem er öffentlich verlautbaren lässt.
Also das ist jetzt aber ein Wortbruch.
Da denkt man sich wirklich, Alter.
Jetzt geh doch mal los. Das ist wirklich kaum noch zu ertragen.
Noch einmal Teutoberg, denn wir haben ja schon Karla Hinrichs gehört.
Es muss gerungen werden und immer wieder um die zeitgemäße Deutung des Grundgesetzes gerungen werden.
Und das sei übrigens auch all denjenigen gesagt, sie meinen,
mit dem Verweis auf eine Bestimmung des Grundgesetzes sei ihre Meinung schon
die allein richtige. Sie könnten Ihre Meinung mit Gewalt durchsetzen.
Artikel 20a des Grundgesetzes gehört zum Grundgesetz. Er ist aber mit anderen
Anliegen und Grundrechten abzuwägen.
Das gilt auch für die letzte Generation, die meint, unser Grundgesetz beschädigen zu können.
Die letzte Generation ist es, die das Grundgesetz beschädigt.
Darauf weist die FDP noch mal hin.
Immerhin hat die FDP nicht Interesse, die FDP nicht Interesse,
den Steinmeier-Plan umzusetzen. Der wurde noch mal ausgebreitet in der FAZ.
Steinmeier hatte einen Gastbeitrag und sagte, dieses Pflichtjahr geht ihm nicht aus dem Kopf.
Aber auch für Alte habe ich mitgekriegt.
Er hat festgestellt, dass nicht so viele Junge dafür sind. Da müsste man Überzeugungsarbeit leisten.
Immerhin wird dies die FDP verhindern. verhindern.
In einem einzigen Punkt kann ich Ihnen aber gleich eine Absage erteilen.
Für eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht sind wir nicht zu haben.
Unser Grundgesetz gibt uns den Auftrag, ohne eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt zu organisieren.
Und da sollte man auch nicht schnell mit so Allgemeinplätzen kommen wie Freiheit ist nicht grenzenlos.
Die Mütter und Väter des Grundgesetzes haben diese Wertentscheidung zugunsten
der freien Persönlichkeitsentfaltung und Lebensgestaltung gerade im Angesicht
von materieller Not, von Wiederaufbau und der direkten Kriegserfahrung getroffen.
Sie haben die Notwendigkeit einer Wehrpflicht zur Landesverteidigung als einzige
Möglichkeit einer Dienstpflicht vorgesehen.
Und das sollte uns zu denken geben, dass nicht heute auf Kosten der jungen Generationen
als billige Profilierungsmöglichkeiten.
Ich kann nur hoffen, dass man nicht diese Dringlichkeit plötzlich sieht und
sagt, wir brauchen jetzt die Wehrpflicht, weil die Chinesen ja kurz vor Berlin stehen.
Also nachdem die Debatten ja laufen, wie sie laufen und wir ja auch schon vor
einem Jahr auf Kommentatoren hinwiesen,
die meinten, naja, wenn wir jetzt mit leichten Waffen anfangen,
dann sind als nächstes die schweren dran, dann die fahrenden,
dann die leichtfahrenden, dann die schwerfahrenden, dann die Flugzeuge.
Und dann ist der Einberufungsbescheid für uns da. Und wir sind jetzt schon bei
den Flugzeugen angekommen. Da haben wir wirklich ein bisschen Angst und Bange.
Ja, in der Tat. Es ist ja erstaunlich, vor allem jeder, der dieses Argument
brachte, wenn jetzt das eine kommt, dann kommt schon sehr bald das andere.
Da waren ja dann, wir wollen diese Namen dieser Leute nicht nennen,
da waren sie ja dann alle bei Twitter und in ihren Podcasts.
Was ist denn das für ein Argument? Das stimmt doch alles gar nicht.
Wir sind jetzt wirklich bei den Flugzeugen angekommen. Wir hören Abgeordnete
aus FDP und CDU, die sagen, wir können doch auch mal auf russischen Boden jetzt mal rauf.
Das hat doch nichts mit Eskalation zu tun. Weil man natürlich immer sagen kann,
Putin war ja der, der eskaliert hat. Also können wir jetzt auch mal dahin noch mit dem Militär.
Sehr, sehr viele Söldner aus Deutschland, aus Großbritannien,
Amerika, die dort auch in diesem Krieg mitkämpfen.
Wir bilden hier ohne Ende aus.
Ich halte das mittlerweile alles für möglich.
Ich finde auch, man sollte jetzt eigentlich, wenn man eine linke Position noch
vertritt, dann sollte man ganz klar dieser mal ausschließen.
Denn ich sag mal so, den jungen Grünen traue ich zu, dass die dann sagen,
wir hatten zwar schlimme Bauchschmerzen, aber wir haben dem Antrag dennoch zugestimmt.
Die Otto-Brenner-Stiftung ist es, glaube ich, die jetzt gerade eine Analyse
gemacht hat, wie Funk so aufklärt, an welchen Themen.
Und ich finde, es ist jetzt an der Zeit, dass Funk mal so ein,
sie sind ja so stolz auf ihre neuen Reportageformate, dass sie mal die Frage
klären für uns, wie geht eigentlich Flucht?
Also nicht Flucht aus Opferperspektive, sondern doch im Sinne von wir flüchten selber.
Wie bereite ich mich auf eine Flucht vor? Wo gehe ich zuerst hin?
Gehe ich zu Fuß? Buche ich mir noch ein Ticket für den Zug? In der Hoffnung, dass er fährt.
Also das könnte man jetzt mal durchdiskutieren. So für, sagen wir mal Sommer
2024, wenn dann auch Amerika,
Also vollends ausfällt, weil dann irgendwie sich herausstellt,
es ist nur noch die Wahl zwischen Desentis oder Trump oder sowas.
Wie geht eigentlich Flucht und wohin flüchten wir Deutsche eigentlich?
Ja, wir dürfen dann wahrscheinlich nicht flüchten, weil man ja möglicherweise
dann das Ausreiseverbot hat.
Ja, das gehört ja dazu.
Also wie kann man das umgehen?
Also das gehört zu meiner Fragestellung dazu, wie flüchte ich auch unter der
Bedingung, dass mir das der Staat nicht erlaubt.
Denn wir wundern uns jetzt seit einem Jahr, dass die Linksliberalen,
die sonst sagen no borders, no nations, just people, überhaupt kein Problem
damit haben, dass ukrainische Männer zwischen 18 und 60 nicht ausreisen dürfen.
Ja vor allem, es gibt ja nicht nur gerade keine Diskussion darüber,
Flugzeuge exportieren oder nicht, sondern wird einfach gemacht.
Deutschland dann so, ja wir können ja nicht, wir haben ja keine F-16.
Also Gratulation zu diesem Move.
Aber was, also worum wird eigentlich gekämpft? Bachmut. Okay,
Bachmut wurde jetzt verteidigt. Kann man das wirklich sagen?
Wurde Bachmut jetzt verteidigt?
Also vielleicht die Fotos damals zu sehen. Ja, es sei nicht mehr strategisch
wichtig, aber symbolisch.
Also es sterben dann Zehntausende für ein Symbol.
Symbolisch, ja. Es ist alles total verdreht. Also naja. Funk.
Ich sehe hier einen Auftrag für Funk.
Naja, bei Funk, die sind ja nun ganz auf dem Kriegskurs.
Umso interessanter, wie Sie diese Fragestellung, die ich gerade aufgeworfen habe, beantworten.
Ja, ja. Wahrscheinlich abschlägig. Das gibt es nicht. Flucht. Flucht.
Ja, da soll sie das aber auch so deutlich sagen.
Ja, ja. Also 2015 jedenfalls Syrienkrieg waren wir uns noch alle einig.
Es ist ein Menschenrecht vor Krieg zu fliehen.
Inzwischen haben wir da rechte Positionen akzeptiert. Nein, man muss kämpfen. Es ist halt Krieg.
Oder wir können auch gleich den Satz von Amthor übernehmen.
Wir wollen stolz sein auf unser Land.
Jawohl. Und jetzt gehen wir noch an den ganz rechten Rand. Wir gehen jetzt zu
Matthias Helferich. Der ist zu rechts für die AfD und ist deshalb jetzt fraktionslos im Bundestag.
Nee, der wurde von der AfD ausgeschlossen oder was?
Irgendwas, ich habe es nicht genau nachgelesen, er ist nur noch so angedockt,
aber sonst ziemlich frei flottierend und äußert sich auch dazu,
findet es an sich gar nicht schlecht, was die CDU vorschlägt, aber.
Grundsätzlich erfreut es mich, liebe Union, dass Sie sich vorsichtig an den
Patriotismus heranwagen.
Auch ich bin der festen Überzeugung, Herr Amthor, dass man die Vaterlandsliebe
nicht den Rändern überlassen darf.
Auffällig ist jedoch, dass sich an keiner Stelle in Ihrem Antrag das Wort Volk
findet. Sie sprechen immerzu von Gemeinschaft, Gesellschaft und Menschen.
Doch was ist eigentlich eine Verfassung?
Sie ist der Ordnungsrahmen, den sich ein Volk gibt. Und dieses Volk erwächst,
wenn es nicht staatlich verfasst ist, mit den Worten des Staatsrechts,
das Deppenheuer, ich zitiere, aus einer geschichtlich gewachsenen substanziellen
Gemeinsamkeit einer Gruppe von Menschen.
Sie findet ihren Grund in der subjektiv unverfügbaren Vergangenheit.
Aus gemeinsamer Geschichte, Schicksalssprache, Kultur erwächst so dann solidarische Verbundenheit.
Ja, aber dann bin ich auch dafür, das aufzugreifen, ernst zu nehmen und auszuschlachten.
Denn die deutsche Geschichte, klar kriegt man nochmal 400 Jahre rein argumentiert
oder so, aber eine Menschheitsgeschichte, ist das nun wirklich ein Vogelschiss?
Da kriegen wir das doch anders argumentiert. Also da ist, glaube ich,
das kommt einer beispielsweise europäischen oder gleich globalen Argumentation,
ist das sehr zuträglich, diesen Weg einzuschlagen.
Er möchte jetzt den Begriff Volk rehabilitieren. Das ist etwas,
was in Deutschland eigentlich nicht geht.
Es sprechen die Regierenden deshalb von Bevölkerung oder von den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern.
Oder Merkel sagte immer die Menschen. Aber das Volk ist nicht mehr die Kategorie,
in der wir sprechen, weil wir an eine plurale Gesellschaft denken wollen und
nicht an so eine Homogenität.
In Deutschland ist das so, aber wenn jetzt deutsche Regierende über andere sprechen,
dann gibt es natürlich schon das Volk.
Das ukrainische Volk wird nicht weichen vor Russlands Gewalt.
Das ukrainische Volk wird widerstehen.
Damit sind wir jetzt angekommen beim Karlspreis. Er wurde nicht nur Selensky
überreicht, sondern auch dem ukrainischen Volk.
Und Scholz hat dort eine Rede gehalten.
Ich will hier kurz anmerken, Selensky wird ja, das ist ja der Vorzug,
weshalb wir ihn so krass verteidigen, wurde ja demokratisch gewählt.
Dieses Wahlergebnis ging natürlich nicht 99 zu 1 aus, sondern anders.
Und wir wissen auch, dass Selensky da als Schauspieler und so weiter,
sehr viele Leute waren damit sehr unzufrieden.
Klar gibt es dann diese Phänomene, dass man sich hinter dem Staatschef versammelt,
wenn man in einem Angriff ausgesetzt ist und so weiter und so fort.
Aber es scheint wohl auch direkt nach Kriegsbeginn keine dieserartigen großen,
also ja man kämpft natürlich für die Ukraine, für seine Heimat, was auch immer.
Aber dass das so auf Silenski gemünzt ist, scheint wirklich ne reinen...
Fremdbeschreibung, also wirklich nur eine Fremdbeschreibung von außen zu sein,
der sich auch nachträglich heute sehr wenige Ukrainer in der Selbstbeschreibung so wiederfinden.
Also wir reden natürlich gerade wenig mit Ukrainern, denn ja manche kommen her,
aber die haben dann andere Themen als mit uns über Zelenskys zu sprechen.
Aber diese Verherrlichung von Zelensky, die ist zunehmend jetzt auch nochmal
ein Thema für sich, denn die Frage ist ja, wie kommt man eigentlich aus so einer Situation wieder raus?
Also ist jetzt Selenskyj einfach der Kriegsherr und dann auch Aufbauer und Präsident
für die Ewigkeit oder wie ist das genau angelegt,
kriegt man irgendwann wieder die Kurve und sagt, nee, Selenskyj darf dann,
also zur Demokratie gehört, dass er auch mal abgeweht wird.
Ohne dass wir dann den Ukrainern das irgendwie verübeln oder so.
Also ich sehe da auch schon so ein paar...
Ja, wenn die jetzt eine konservative Partei dann wählen, dann sagen die,
ach so, so hat man es aber eigentlich nicht vorgestellt, der Ukraine.
Das muss man jetzt so langsam auch mal vorbereiten, das gehört ja auch schon
so. Aber das ist in Deutschland auch noch ganz, ganz, ganz fern.
Also wenn der Ausnahmezustand ist, dann gibt es jetzt das Volk.
Und damit sind wir eigentlich in einem Carl-Schmidt-Denken angelangt,
was die Linken dann eher sonst loslassen wollen.
Also ich habe den Eindruck, wenn der Staat kritisiert wird, wenn die letzte
Generation kritisiert wird, wenn die letzte Generation den Staat kritisiert
Und sich dann ganz viele von links bis Mitte mit der letzten Generation solidarisiert.
Wenn wir sagen, dieser Staat ist rassistisch konstituiert, strukturell verdrängt,
er macht immer mehr, wird er zur Festung.
Wenn wir diese ganze Staatskritik äußern, wenn wir Überwachung kritisieren und
all das, dann ist das so eine Schönwetter-Liberalität.
Aber wenn es dann doch ernst wird, wenn die Panzer rollen müssen,
dann doch bitte wieder alle sich einreihen hinter dem Staat.
Und das ist, glaube ich, auch diese ...
Große Veränderungen, die wir diskusiv erleben zwischen einer älteren Generation.
Ich sage mal so die Jahrgänge Reinhard May und Alice Schwarzer und wie die alle
heißen, die eine fundamentale Staatskritik noch äußerten.
Während wir heute sagen, also zu sagen, ich finde den Staat scheiße,
wenn er die Klimabewegung da so behandelt, dann ist das völlig okay.
Da kann man sich überall auch noch mal gratis Applaus abholen,
aber wenn es so ans Eingemachte geht, dann lieber doch nicht.
Und ich will das mal anmerken.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das Lied hier schon mal erwähnt haben.
Kennst du das von Reinhard May?
Meine Söhne gebe ich nicht.
Ich kenne von Reinhard May leider nur über den Wolken.
Ja, das ist wirklich schade, denn das ist nicht sein stärkstes Lied.
Reinhard May hat schon ein paar gute Lieder geschrieben. Ich will es mal ganz
kurz zitieren, weil du jetzt eben die Flucht angesprochen hattest.
Und zwar geht dieses Lied so, ich denke, ich schreibe euch besser schon bei
Zeiten und sage euch schon endgültig ab.
Ihr braucht keine langen Listen auszubreiten, um zu sehen, dass ich auch zwei
Söhne habe. Ich liebe die beiden, das will ich euch sagen, mehr als mein Leben,
als mein Augenlicht. Und die, die werden keine Waffen tragen.
Nein, meine Söhne gebe ich nicht.
Meine Söhne gebe ich nicht. Ganz sicher nicht für euch hat ihre Mutter sie unter
Schmerzen auf die Welt gebracht.
Nicht für euch und nicht als Kanonenfutter, nicht für euch habe ich in manche
Fiebernacht verzweifelt an dem kleinen Bett gestanden und kühlt ein kleines
glühendes Gesicht, bis wir in der Erschöpfung Ruhe fanden.
Nein, meine Söhne, geb ich nicht.
Sie werden nicht in Reih und Glied marschieren, nicht durchhalten,
nicht kämpfen bis zuletzt, auf einem gottverlassenen Feld erfrieren,
während ihr euch in weiche Kissen setzt.",
Und er sagt dann auch, lieber, das ist dann die Strophe, die ich jetzt nicht
mitgebracht habe, lieber werde ich mit ihnen fliehen.
Und das finde ich ja doch erstaunlich. Ich habe ja keine Kinder,
kenne aber viele Leute mit Kindern, das.
Da überhaupt keine Sensibilität momentan dafür da ist, dass man doch niemals
seine Kinder einfach mal so losschicken würde. Und sagen, du kämpfst ja hier
für Amthors Patriotismus, zieh mal los.
Wo man zugleich alles tut, damit die Kinder wohl behütet sind.
Stichwort Helikoptereltern.
Ich hänge ja immer noch sehr dem Argument nach, auch wenn man später sagen kann,
die Corona-Politik wurde ja eigentlich Präsidentenkonferenz gemacht und so weiter
und so fort. Aber diese Corona-Politik an den Kindern vorbei.
Wurde ja von einem Wirtschaftsminister, einem Gesundheitsminister,
einem Finanzminister und einer Kanzlerin gemacht. Alle ohne Kinder.
Und das hat man da wahrscheinlich auch gesehen.
Und irgendwie habe ich immer noch so die Hoffnung in mir, dass wir ja in so
einer individualistischen Gesellschaft leben, in der die eigenen Kinder auch
gegen andere absolut bevorzugt werden.
Also die eigenen Kinder sollen nicht irgendwo eingereiht werden oder so.
Deswegen ja auch dieser ganze Schulstreit. Wir brauchen das Gymnasium.
Ich muss ja meine Kinder von den ganzen anderen hotten Totten da fernhalten.
Also dafür brauche ich ein Gymnasium.
Und ich möchte noch, bevor wir jetzt, weil du sehr viele Volksgruppen hast.
Du würdest sagen, dass man einfach die Aufrüstung alles toll findet,
aber dann nimmt man zugleich die eigenen Kinder raus aus dieser Rechnung und
sagt, mit denen muss ich dann mal gucken.
Das ist dann so wie wir das bei Lockdowns erlebt haben, wenn dann alle sagen,
wir brauchen den Lockdown, aber ich bin jetzt mal im Süden.
Also um einen Begriff aufzuwerfen, der überall schon Konjunktur hat,
außer beim Thema Krieg, aber ich glaube, wir sind in Deutschland kurz davor,
den Krieg gerne technologieoffen, technologiefrei planen, aber nicht mit Biomasse.
Also jede Maschine da irgendwie hinschicken, aber bitte nicht die Kinder.
Und zum Thema Volk. Also, tschüss.
Wie ich mein Kind erziehe, ist ja in höchstgradiger Art und Weise eine ganz
individuelle Entscheidung der Eltern.
Der Staat mischt sich ja mit Absicht nicht ein, will sich da auch gar nicht
einmischen, weil umso weniger Verantwortung auf ihm lastet, umso weniger muss
er bezahlen. Das heißt dann, ne, der beliebte Losung, Homeoffice,
Homeschooling, alles gleichzeitig, die Eltern übernehmen die Verantwortung.
Da passt es natürlich wenig rein, dann zu sagen, ja, aber jetzt brauchen wir
deine Kinder mal, sie müssten leider für uns sterben.
Also das kriegt man keinem Eltern vermittelt und in der Hinsicht habe ich da
eine gewisse Hoffnung, dass irgendwo dann auch so eine Grenze erreicht ist im Diskurs.
Aber dieser hochindividualistischen Angelegenheit, nicht nur bei der Kindererziehung,
sondern grundsätzlich, dass man auch sagt, ich möchte darüber entscheiden, was ich esse.
Ich möchte darüber entscheiden, ob jetzt, ja, ich bin irgendwo geboren,
aber meine Wahlheimat ist mir wichtiger oder ja, ich weiß, ich habe eigentlich
so ein Geschlecht, das ist sichtbar, aber das ist ja nur Biologie.
Also alles wird der individuellen Entscheidung unterworfen und trotzdem finden
wir ja in einer Gesellschaft statt.
Und wir haben Probleme, von denen es dann immer wieder heißt,
wir kriegen die nur kollektiv gelöst.
Und wir kennen ja Maja Göbel, die jetzt ihr drittes Buch zum Thema Klima und
so weiter vorgelegt hat. Und Peter Sloterdijk hat sie sich als Gesprächspartnerin
für so eine Gesprächsrunde in irgendeinem Radiosender gewünscht.
Also man kann das bei YouTube aktuell finden, das ist irgendwie von letzter Woche oder so.
Maja Göbel und Peter Sloterdijk im Gespräch.
Und da fragt Peter Sloterdijk sie, na ja, sie haben hier ein Buch,
ja, sehr oft sprechen sie von wir.
Ist das jetzt so eine Verlegenheit, weil sie wissen, irgend so ein Bloch hat
gesagt, wer Menschheit sagt, lügt oder was auch immer?
Oder wie ist denn das gemeint? Und sie führt das dann so kurz aus.
Ja, wir müssen uns ja auch gegenseitig überzeugen.
Ja, es muss alles einmal durchs Bewusstsein geleiert werden.
Und dann sagt Sloterdijk noch so eine ganz super interessante,
aber leider viel zu kurze, weil eigentlich wirklich interessante Anmerkung.
Wenn wir von mehr als ich sprechen, also von dem Wir, dann kommt das eigentlich
nur vor, wenn wir beispielsweise bei Großveranstaltungen so Panikelemente irgendwie einbauen.
Dass in dem Moment, wo sich aufgrund physikalischer Gesetzmäßigkeiten das Individuum
nicht mehr retten kann, wenn alle plötzlich so zu Schwarm-Dummheitsmäßig lostreten.
Nur, das sind eigentlich nur noch Momente, in denen das Bewusstsein,
das Geist, das Individuum, die Intuition, alles ausgeschaltet ist,
sondern nur noch instinkthaft mitgerannt wird.
Hauptsache man kommt da irgendwie lebend raus, man klettert über alle anderen
drüber, großes Töten, großes Sterben und so weiter und so fort.
Und daran muss ich gerade denken, wenn hier immer das Volk, das Volk,
das Volk, es ist wirklich der absolute Verlegenheitsbegriff.
Wenn wir vom Volk so sprechen, dann meinen wir wirklich einfach nur noch die,
sozial-physikalisch gefasste Biomasse.
Ja, die dann mal nach Bachmuth gesteuert wird oder sonst wo hin.
Genau, die absolut in Bedrängnis, also die wirklich nur hervorkommt,
wenn man sie richtig in Bedrängnis bringt. Also wenn man einfach individuell
flüchtet und dann fahren alle auf die Autobahn und stehen im Stau.
Also dann spielt irgendwie diese Art von Gemeinschaft eine Rolle.
Ansonsten nicht. Ansonsten betonen wir eigentlich das Individuum,
die Entscheidungshoheit und so weiter und so fort. Und das würde ich auch mal unterstellen.
Das ist ja auch das Verrückte an den Neoliberalen, die jeden Eingriff des Staates,
Vermögenssteuer, Tempolimit oder sonst irgendetwas als eine unglaubliche Freiheitseinschränkung
wahrnehmen, zugleich aber nicht kritisieren, dass junge Männer verpflichtet werden zu kämpfen.
Das ist dann für sie kein Problem, denn da gelten plötzlich höhere Interessen.
Da ist der Staat dann gut. Im Ausnahmezustand darf der Staat souverän sein, wie er möchte.
Ja, also es ist einfach nur absurd, albern geradezu, mit welcher Leichtigkeit
hier von einem Volksgefüge, von einem Volk gesprochen wird, weil es wirklich
jeder Erfahrung, jedem Wunsch,
jeder aufklärerischen Arbeit, die wir egal aus welcher Richtung,
sei es die sexuelle Aufklärung, die Bildungsaufklärung, die Einkommensaufklärung.
Wir machen TikTok auf und sehen die ganze Zeit nur Videos. Also wenn du diese
Habits übernimmst, dann wirst du auch Millionär und so weiter,
weil Millionär heißt ja dann auch nur, dann bist du besser als alle anderen,
weil du gehörst ja nicht zu denen.
Also überall findet es statt und jetzt reden die einfach vom Volk.
Also es ist wirklich, wenn man es nur eine Sekunde länger durchdenkt,
als die Rede einfach so an sich vorbeilaufen zu lassen, weil es Sonntag und
Feierstunde ist, ist es einfach absurd.
Die Ukrainer werden auch Menschen sein wie wir. Selbst so ein minimal staatlicher
Eingriff wie eine Impfung hat bei einem Drittel der Bevölkerung für Widerstand gesorgt.
Da kann man sich mal vorstellen, was das bedeutet, wenn man verpflichtet werden
sollte, nicht mehr auszureisen.
Oder wenn man da abkommandiert wird zum Kampfe.
Das kann ja nur so sein, dass das nicht eine homogene Gruppe ist,
Es ist keine homogene Gruppe, die einfach nur Ja sagt. Es gibt in den letzten
Monaten Verschärfungen für Deserteure bei den Strafen.
Man müsste keine Strafen für Deserteure einführen oder verschärfen,
wenn es nicht Deserteure gäbe.
Deserteure gibt es nur deshalb, weil da offenbar Leute nicht mehr einverstanden
sind und nicht mehr mittun wollen.
Und für diese Deserteure würde es ja sich eigentlich von links gehören,
sich für diese einzusetzen.
Aber all das findet ja nicht statt.
Und jetzt kann man immer sagen, ja, aber viele Ukrainer wollen kämpfen.
Und das streiten wir auch gar nicht ab. Und wir wollen ja auch nicht ein Selbstverteidigungsrecht
oder so was in Frage stellen. Nur muss es aus einer Freiheit heraus geschehen.
Und ich kann wirklich inzwischen auch diesen Embedded Journalism nicht mehr ertragen.
Wir in der FAZ war auch noch mal so eine ganze Seite von Leuten,
die in der ukrainischen Armee kämpfen, die in Bachmuth gekämpft haben und.
Es müsste ja auch mal einen Artikel geben über Leute, die sagen,
es war scheiße, ich hätte irgendwie versuchen müssen zu fliehen.
Ich bin jetzt für mein Leben geschädigt. Und stattdessen lesen wir,
und ich polemisiere jetzt bewusst, lesen tatsächlich nur so Artikel von Dimitri.
Wir treffen ihn im Krankenhaus, er hat beide Arme und beide Beine verloren,
aber er sehnt sich schon jetzt wieder zurück an die Front. Und das kann irgendwie nicht sein.
Ja, die dann ein Hohenbild aufkrücken, Hauptsache sie können zurück an die Front
und die Frau steht daneben und sagt nein, nein, nein und dann wird aber sein
Patriotismus nochmal größer gefeiert.
Ja, das mag für ihn, das mag dann, also diese Fälle wird es auch geben,
ich will nicht unterstellen, dass es gelogen ist, nur ich sehe nur solche Geschichten
und da wundere ich mich dann schon.
Wir wissen aber, glaube ich, also wir können alle antizipieren,
selbst wenn man jetzt uns zuhört und denkt, naja, aber und und so weiter,
wir müssen doch da verteidigen.
Wir wissen, glaube ich, wir können alle antizipieren, wie der Ukrainekrieg,
sagen wir mal von 2020 bis 2070,
äh 2030 bis 2070 in der europäischen Geschichte fortgeschrieben wird.
Wie die Bücher aussehen, wie die Filme aussehen, dass man sich in 50 Jahren
so ein, wie jetzt bei Netflix, im Westen nichts Neues und so weiter anschauen
wird und dann die große Warnung.
So bitte nicht nochmal. Aber jetzt gerade nicht. Und es ist wirklich erstaunlich,
wie man alle Gesetze, von denen man dachte, ja die gelten doch,
oder? Also in im Krieg stirbt die Wahrheit immer zuerst.
Das heißt, wenn man vom Krieg hört, ist die Wahrheit um den Krieg schon tot.
Und trotzdem hören wir seit einem Jahr von dem Krieg und nehmen alles für voll,
was irgendwie irgendwo diskutiert wird. Also das finde ich auch wirklich ein
bisschen beängstigend.
Wir hören noch mal Scholz.
Denn das ukrainische Volk und du, lieber Volodymyr, leisten gemeinsam seit dem
24. Februar 2022 Unermessliches.
Es ist exakt, wie du sagst. Das ukrainische Volk und Selenskyj werden in eins
gedacht, deshalb ja auch zusammen ausgezeichnet.
Und jetzt macht er eine Differenzierung.
Russen und Ukrainer sind eben nicht ein Volk, wie es Präsident Putin in seiner
imperialistischen und kolonialistischen Verblendung behauptet.
Die ukrainische Nation hat ihre eigene lange Geschichte, ihre in sich unglaublich
vielfältige eigene Kultur, ihre eigenen Traditionen, ihre eigene Identität.
Schon seit dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion Poch, die unabhängige Ukraine auf
ihre Freiheit über den eigenen Weg selbst zu entscheiden.
Und die Ukraine hat ihre Entscheidung getroffen für Europa.
Die Ukraine ist ein sehr vielfältiges Land. Man müsste also,
wenn schon von den eigenen Traditionen, den eigenen Identitäten sprechen.
Es ist ja richtig, dass sie nicht eine Identität sind, Russen und Ukrainer,
wie Putin sich das vorstellt.
Aber man kann nicht dann sagen, die sind hier unsere, diese eine Identität,
die wir jetzt mal gerade hier aus Aachen herausgefasst haben. das Absurde.
Er bezieht sich jetzt nochmal auf diese Serie, in der Selensky die Hauptrolle
spielte, Diener des Volkes.
Sluha Narodu, Diener des Volkes. Mit diesem Anspruch sind Sie als Präsident
der Ukraine angetreten.
Genau das bist du heute.
Wenn es darum geht, stellvertretend für das Volk den Karlspreis entgegenzunehmen.
Der Freiheitswille und die Widerstandskraft in dunkler Zeit spenden Hoffnung
und Inspiration weit über die Ukraine hinaus.
An der Spitze des gesamten ukrainischen Volkes verteidigst du die Werte, für die Europa steht.
Ja, schon das Bild von an der Spitze ist natürlich... Würde Scholz von sich
sagen, er steht an der Spitze von Deutschland?
Da würde man... der könnte morgen zurücktreten.
Ja, das ist doch lächerlich, alle, wir hören es nachher auch,
machen sich lustig darüber, fordern es im Grunde ein, jetzt sag doch wenigstens
mal einen Satz zu irgendeinem Thema und dann an der Stelle, du stehst an der Spitze des Feuers.
Scholz, der sich wochenlang versteckt. Nun, von der Leyen kann natürlich noch eins draufsetzen.
Ich habe mit Präsident Zelensky in diesen frühen, düsteren Tagen und Wochen
oft am Telefon gesprochen.
Ich kannte bereits seinen Mut und seine Entschlossenheit.
Aber als ich an diesem Tag in Kiew in seine Augen blickte, war ich zutiefst
berührt von dieser unerschütterlichen Standfestigkeit, die er zeigte.
Also, man kann es natürlich alles übertreiben, so wie die das macht und es ist
alles, da sitzt ja Publikum und so weiter, dem will man auch was bieten.
Die ist ja angeklatscht bekommen, hast
du gesagt. Es wird immer so einer vorgeklatscht und dann fangen alle an.
Aber es gibt doch diesen Spruch, man wächst mit seinen Aufgaben.
Das ist ja Grundlage der Definition von Heldentum.
Man ist eigentlich kein Held. Es steckt auch nicht in einem drin,
aber dann wird man gefordert. Das wird dann in Demokratien immer übertrieben,
indem Helmut Kohl sagt, naja, wenn ihr mich ruft, werde ich euer Tribun.
So ungefähr. Also man erfindet sich das so an.
Aber diese Verklärung des Hellen, dass es ihn eigentlich schon gibt.
Und dann, und was heißt das dann eigentlich? Danke für die Gelegenheit,
dass wir jetzt zeigen konnten, er ist ein echter Held.
Ohne den Krieg wäre das gar nicht gelungen. Also es war nicht alles schlecht
am Krieg, er hat immerhin Helden hervorgebracht. Was für eine Logik steckt denn
da dahinter so semantisch, ne?
Das ist wirklich super schräg und ich denke, es ist wirklich super wichtig,
dass wir uns das nicht nur anhören, sondern uns auch darüber lustig machen.
Ich finde das auch gut. Weil das sind solche Sachen, gerne jetzt nochmal thematisieren.
Es ist jetzt Krieg und so weiter.
Und deswegen empfehle ich auch nochmal dieses Sloterdijk Gespräch.
Er macht auch so Anmerkungen zum Thema Krieg.
Krieg, also dass wir Krieg blöd finden, ist eigentlich neu.
Vor hundert Jahren hat man Krieg nicht so blöd gefunden. Da ist man halt,
da war halt Party. Man zieht jetzt in den Krieg und die Mütter haben ja noch
ein paar andere Söhne und so weiter. Also es war einfach so eine andere Gemengelage.
Und jetzt nutzen wir aber diesen alten Krieg, um uns hundert Jahre später zu
erklären. Ja, eigentlich finden wir Krieg blöd, weil guckt mal,
vor hundert Jahren der Krieg war besonders blöd. Aber der jetzige Krieg,
der ist nicht ganz so blöd. Also der hat so Gründe. Das ist,
das muss man dann so und so machen.
Zeigt sich ja bei dem ganzen TikTok-Hype, wie dort Soldaten sich präsentieren
oder wie dort ja im Prinzip jetzt so Kriegs-Influencer entstanden sind,
die aus Amerika kommen, Söldner, die dann plötzlich eine TikTok-Karriere noch
nebenher machen und das auch als große Party verkaufen.
Und gut wäre ja eigentlich, wenn, sagen wir mal, in zehn Jahren droht wieder
so ein Quatsch, dass dann von Anfang an alle sagen, nee, das ist zu doof.
Also das ist uns leider zu doof. Wir sehen, Herr Putin, was Sie da wollen.
Wir können jetzt aber leider nicht in dieses Spiel einsteigen,
wir schicken nur leichte Waffen, damit wir dich nicht provozieren oder so,
also dieser ganze Blödsinn, sondern nee, wir machen hier keinen Krieg.
Und dann muss man da eine andere Strategie finden, weil das ist wirklich,
ich habe es schon mal thematisiert, das ist ja immer noch so,
nach Monaten, wir führen den Krieg so, dass völkerrechtlich wir auf der sicheren Seite stehen.
Also wir hätten so ganz viele wirklich schwere Waffen, militärischer und nicht
militärischer Art, man muss ja auch nicht in 17 Sanktionspaketen hoch sanktionieren,
man kann ja auch von Anfang an mal gleich ordentlich zuschauen.
Und die Botschaft, die wir den Ukrainern geben ist, wir wollen leider nicht
eskalieren, deswegen kämpfen wir erstmal nur mit deinem Bizeps und nicht mit
der schweren Waffe, die muss noch bei uns in der Garage bleiben.
Aber wenn du jetzt stirbst und nach dir noch 17 andere, dann sind wir an der Eskalationsstufe,
Das wäre so, aber ihr müsst erst mal geopfert werden und das ist doch Quatsch.
Wir haben ja das schon mal thematisiert, damals dieser Kampf da im Himalaya,
wo sie mit Hacke und Beile aufeinander zugegangen sind.
Ich hörte jetzt den Funkkreis Podcast, das ist ein Bundeswehr Podcast,
ich habe da auch noch Clips dabei, aber nicht von dieser Folge,
auf die ich jetzt anspiele, und zwar über die Mulis, das sind ja so Tiere,
Mischung aus Pferd und Esel.
Und die Bundeswehr hat ja Mulis, hat die, um zum Beispiel dann auch in Afghanistan
oder so dort langere Transportwege zu machen.
Und erstaunlich war, dass ich da an einer Stelle hörte, dass wohl ganz viele
Armeen weltweit wieder mehr auf Mulis und überhaupt auf solche Arten des Transports setzen,
Weil man sich offenbar auf Kriege einstellt, wo so was wieder vonnöten ist.
Denn eigentlich klingt das nach einem Karl-May-Roman, dass man da mit Mulis
loszieht, wo man die besten Drohnen der Welt hat.
Aber in der Logik, die du gerade beschrieben hast, dass man sagt,
na ja, wir können nicht in dem Sinne eskalieren mit den Atombomben im Rücken, schwierig.
Aber wir können es über Mensch und Tier austragen lassen.
Und dann muss man plötzlich wieder archaische Kriege führen und genau diese werden ja geführt.
Wir haben das ja sowohl von der russischen wie von der ukrainischen Seite gehört,
dass die mit schlechter oder keine Ausrüstung am Ende aufeinander losgehen müssen.
Ganz so, wie das ja auch im Westen nichts Neues zu sehen war,
dass die nachher mit dem Klappspaten dann als Waffe gearbeitet haben.
Ja und interessant ist das selbst so.
Figuren wie Kissinger jetzt nochmal sagen, schon anfangen mit dem Tenor,
die Russen sind nicht alleine schuld an der Eskalation des Krieges.
Und das finde ich eigentlich das interessanteste Ding überhaupt,
muss man sich natürlich nochmal genau anhören, wie er das meint und wie er das
einbettet, aber, dass man den Krieg, also dass man nicht einfach sagt,
ja am 22. Februar oder 24.
Februar 2022 begann der Krieg, sondern dass man einbettet in,
Nee, das war nur der Moment, wo irgendeiner im Gefüge dachte,
es ist für mich jetzt lukrativer, alles in Schutt und Asche zu legen,
als, ja, und dass diese Kalkulation schief geht.
Also das ist sozusagen der Fail unserer Moderne.
Da muss einfach eine andere Vorarbeit sein. Und dass man dann ein Jahr läuft
der Krieg, plötzlich feststellt, ah ja, globaler Süden, Solidarität,
da haben wir ja ganz schön viele Defizite.
Das sind diese großen Probleme, die man thematisieren müsste. Also es ist sozusagen,
wir haben auf der einen Seite diese Selensky und das Volk ab Feierstunde in
Aachen und dann in Hiroshima diese Feststellung,
dass die G7 sich treffen und merken, wir kriegen den globalen Süden nicht nochmal eingefangen.
Und das ist aber eigentlich die Debatte, die man zum Karlspreis bringen müsste.
Also das würde dann auch diesem Preis gerecht, diese Thematisierung.
Stattdessen hier so eine Feierstunde für Selensky und das Volk.
Also da sieht man, wir sind wirklich krass falsch abgebogen in unserer Debatte zum Thema.
Und mich wundert auch, dass die Sprachsensiblen gar nicht aufhorchen,
wenn da gewisse Äußerungen getan werden.
Wir haben lauter Insta-Kracheln, die darauf hinweisen, dass man nicht mehr übergewichtig,
sondern mehrgewichtig sagen soll. Aber wenn von der Leyen solche Äußerungen
tätig, dann passiert nichts. Wir hören uns das genau mal an.
Kurt Pfeiffer nimmt uns Europäerinnen und Europäer in die Pflicht um,
ich zitiere, die höchsten irdischen Güter zu verteidigen,
Freiheit, Menschlichkeit und Frieden und die Zukunft der Kinder und Enkel zu sichern, Zitat Ende.
Der Preisträger und die Menschen seines Landes, die wir heute mit ihm würdigen,
sind dieser Pflicht besser nachgekommen, als wir es alle jemals könnten.
Sie kämpfen buchstäblich für Freiheit, Menschlichkeit und Frieden.
Sie sichern mit Ihrem Blut und Ihrem Leben die Zukunft Ihrer Kinder,
aber auch die unserer Kinder.
Ja, aber das ist doch dumm.
Sind wir schon in der Kategorie des Bluts angekommen?
Ja, das ist doch dumm, dass Sie das müssen.
Blutzoll, das ist jetzt das, was... Und es funktioniert ja auch,
wenn man es jetzt mal mit Kant betrachtet, moralisch gar nicht richtig.
Also wenn man etwas aus Pflicht tut, dann muss das ja nicht mehr besonders geehrt
werden. Das ist die Pflicht, die man zu tun hat. Man muss sich nicht was umhängen lassen in Aachen.
Das funktioniert so nicht. Dass hier das Blut aufgerufen wird und sagt,
das ist der Weg, der zu gehen ist.
Mich schockiert das von allen Überraschungen. Mich hat die Pandemie kalt erwischt,
dass ich dachte, hätte ich nicht gedacht. Man konnte es sich doch vorstellen.
Hätte mir jemand vor zehn Jahren gesagt, es könnte eine Pandemie kommen.
Eineinhalb Jahre mit Masken und so unterwegs, dann hätte ich gesagt,
ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Wenn mir jemand gesagt hätte, dass wir eine solche
Kriegslüsternheit noch einmal zurückbekommen, dann hätte ich gesagt,
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das hat mich überrascht.
Wir hören noch zum Schluss nicht Aachen, sondern Washington.
Zelensky hat sich mit Lindsay Graham getroffen, ein Republikaner,
wie er im Buche steht und vorab hat dann, oder kurz danach hat dann Graham erst
mal der Pressekonferenz folgendes von sich gegeben.
I'd like to do more to help prosecute Russian war crimes.
The best way to protect Taiwan and world order is for Putin to lose.
And if you don't get that, I think you're missing a lot.
Er will also Putin als Verlierer dastehen haben. Also nicht nur der Krieg soll
gewonnen werden, sondern Putin soll als Verlierer dastehen und soll dann am
besten nach Den Haag ausgeliefert werden.
Wir hören noch mal weiter rein.
Auch der Bezug zur Taiwan ist sehr wichtig.
Ukraine, because if we fail here, there goes Taiwan.
Wie das aussehen soll, wissen wir ja alle nicht. Was soll da passieren?
Bevor wir jetzt diesen letzten Clip hören, den ich auch schon kenne und viel
auch hoffentlich, weil er wahrscheinlich die Runde gemacht hat und wenn nicht,
hört noch mal genau zu und so weiter.
Wir müssen uns jetzt noch mal genau überlegen, ich habe es ja eben schon mal
kurz angedeutet, Da kann es ja nochmal ein bisschen größer das Argument ziehen.
Warum hat bislang China Taiwan nicht angegriffen?
Aus Taiwan kommen so und so viele Chips für die Welt, die werden überall gebraucht.
Angefangen bei der Waschmaschine, beim Fernseher und dann hochleistungsmäßig
Handy, Computer, Wertechnik, der ganze Kram, Autos.
Also man braucht für alles diese Chips.
Und China möchte sich gern weiterhin aus der Armut befreien.
Mit 400 Millionen Menschen oder so hat man es schon geschafft.
400 Millionen sind noch offen.
Und die Wege sind, naja, so viele Möglichkeiten hat die kommunistische Partei
dort nicht. Man hat ja gesehen, das große Ziel der Volksbefriedung,
es hat so ein bisschen funktioniert mit dieser Corona-App.
Man hat einfach die Mobilität beschränkt und den Leuten Möglichkeiten gegeben
und hier und da waren rot und grüne Schranken und sehr viel direkte Verhaltenskontrolle.
Nur das ist natürlich sehr ressourcenzehrend, das hält man nicht lange durch.
Und wenn die Erzählung nicht gut funktioniert, dann schafft man es die Leute
auch nicht zu befrieden. Also hat man von jetzt auf gleich einfach diesen großen
politischen Umschwung gemacht.
Okay, ihr dürft jetzt alle wieder vor die Tür, was die kommunistische Partei
unter Zugzwang gesetzt hat. Wenn die Corona-App als Disziplinierungsmaßnahme
ausfällt, muss es wieder das Aufstiegsversprechen sein. Das ist das Wichtigste überhaupt.
Taiwan wird erst dann von China
angegriffen. wenn das Aufstiegsversprechen Chinas ernsthaft bedroht ist.
Beispielsweise, indem selbst in Friedenszeiten so viel Sanktionen und Kram durch
Amerika entschieden abläuft, dass immer weniger Chips nach China importiert
werden. Was ja jetzt gerade so ist. Die werden ja wirklich aus dem Markt rausgenommen.
Die zentralen Maschinen von ASLM kommen alle aus den Niederlanden usw. Und irgendwann...
Guckt man sich diese Zahlen da an und die Chinesen machen das nun wirklich streng nach Excel-Tabelle.
Irgendwann ist es lukrativer, einfach Taiwan zu übernehmen, zehn Jahre,
was auch immer für ein Fallout da in Kauf zu nehmen und sagen,
aber wenigstens haben wir dann Kontrolle über diese Schifffabriken oder wie auch immer.
So, und dieser Punkt, also das ist die Kalkulation.
Und irgendwann kommt also der Punkt, wo man sagt, es ist lukrativer für uns,
einen Krieg zu führen. Ja. So, und erst dann wird er geführt.
Danach kommt natürlich die Erzählung, ja jetzt dreht Xi total durch oder so.
Er hat sich wohl isoliert mit seiner Gang, die er 2023 installiert hat für die Ewigkeit.
Dann haben die sich reinradikalisiert und so weiter und so fort.
Aber die sitzen einfach da, gucken sich ihre demografische, ökonomische Kalkulation
an und sehen, wie die Warenströme so sind. Es wäre lukrativer,
Taiwan einfach platt zu machen, weil wir sind ja eh schon aus dem Spiel.
Dann nehmen wir wenigstens den Rest der Welt auch noch aus dem Spiel,
damit die nicht, wenn wir schon keine Chips haben, Das ist die Kalkulation.
Und unter dieser Maßgabe können wir jetzt diesen Lindsay-Gray-Clip hören.
Dieser Clip, an den man nicht genau weiß, ist der geschnitten.
Es gibt nur ein Fernsehbild dazu. Da sehen wir die erste Hälfte des Satzes und
sehen dann eine zweite Hälfte.
Ob es wirklich die zweite Hälfte ist, man kann es nicht so genau sagen.
Ich würde aber sagen, es ist nicht kriegsentscheidend, um auch mal militaristisch
hier zu sein, sondern die Aussage ist an sich schon erstaunlich.
Free or die. Free or die. Now you are free. Yes. And we will be.
And the Russians are dying.
It's the best money we've ever spent.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, der ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie geschnitten.
Da war wahrscheinlich vorher ein anderes als dieser Free or die Dings davor.
Free or die, das fragte er Zelensky. Zelensky sagt, now we are free.
Und dann sagt er wohl und die Russen sterben.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und dann kommt vielleicht ein Schnitt und er sagt diesen Satz,
das war das beste Investment ever.
Und jetzt egal, ob sich das genau auf den Tod der Russen bezieht,
man sieht hier ganz klar, er sieht es als ein großes, tolles Investment an,
diesen Krieg zu unterstützen von amerikanischer Seite.
Damit dürften diese ganzen Debatten von, ja der Westen hat überhaupt gar kein
Interesse da drin und ist da einfach nur als Freund und Helfer zur Seite,
sich nun wirklich jetzt mal in Luft auflösen.
Ja, also wenn man es jetzt ohne, also ganz nach,
wie soll man sagen, also wenn man Lindsay Graham jetzt in ganz schlechtes Licht stellt,
hat er hier gesagt, der Kongress hat 40 Milliarden bewilligt für die militärische Unterstützung,
was natürlich nur bedeutet, das Geld geht symbolisch einmal in die Ukraine,
die bestellen Waffen in Amerika, das Geld bleibt aber direkt in Amerika,
der Kongress bezahlt das direkt an die Waffenhersteller und dann fährt einfach
ein Schiff los und liefert Waffen ab, also 40 Milliarden für die eigene Waffenindustrie und 66.000,
tote russische Soldaten. Best money ever spent.
Also da gibt es eine sehr hohe Plausibilität, dass das genau so abgelaufen ist,
ungefähr in seinem Kopf.
Und das finde ich schon ganz schön gefährlich, denn am Ende ist es immer der Kapitalismus.
Und wenn Krieg mehr Return on Investment verspricht als eine Friedenssituation,
dann ist es doch wirklich sehr heikel.
Und es sind Menschen, die da sterben. Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Der Klimadiskurs, wir kennen ihn und erleiden ihn.
Oh ja.
Ja, ist ja in Deutschland, wir haben ihn ja angesprochen, Greichen, E-Fuels,
was auch immer, man hört jetzt in Nordrhein-Westfalen, wird wenigstens mal inhaltlich
diskutiert, ich habe es nur gestern so gehört, Henrik Wüst sieht das Land auf dem richtigen Weg.
Andere Stimmen sagen, naja, wir müssen hier Solarplatten auf rechnerisch 15.000,
Fußballfeldern verlegen und 1.500 Windräder brauchen wir. Um allein die Stahl-Industrie,
die da immer noch für Furore und Umsätze sorgt, zu retten. Herbert Dies war
jetzt bei Lanz und hat da nochmal durchgerechnet.
Die Chinesen haben uns sozusagen befreit in der Welt.
Wir brauchen eigentlich gar keine politische Entscheidung mehr,
die Solarpaneele sind so kostengünstig, dass sie das von alleine regeln.
Also da hat er so ein bisschen Hoffnung versprüht, aber naja,
wir wissen alle nicht, in welche Richtung es geht.
Das heißt, indem wir Solarpanels von China importieren, das wäre sein Vorschlag.
Genau, damals hat der Strom, ich weiß nicht genau, welche Einheit,
zwei Euro gekostet, jetzt sind es 17 Cent.
Damit ist das Signal an alle Ihnen da gegeben, klar, können jetzt noch drei
Jahre lang ein Loch buddeln,
um dann irgendwann am Kohlefluss anzukommen und das dann und so,
aber bis dahin sind wir hier bei 13 Cent und dann ist es einfacher,
dreimal die Fläche, die ihr da ausbuddelt, einfach mit Solarpanelen zuzudecken
und dann habt ihr die gleiche Ausbeute.
Und, naja, die deutsche Debatte, ich hab nur so illustrativ,
Mark Schieritz weist den Spiegel noch mal drauf hin, nachdem er ein aufregender
Thema zum Jahr aufregung um die Reform des Gebäudeenergiegesetzes kommt.
Nicht von ungefähr, denn 2024 erreichen 4 Millionen Öl- und Gasheizungen das
Alter, in dem sie ausgetauscht werden müssen. Und dann schreibt Mark Schieritz,
naja, aber das steht doch im Gesetz seit 2020.
Das kann man ja nicht der aktuellen Novelle unterstellen, dass da irgendwie
Heizungen nach 30 Jahren ausgebaut werden müssen.
Also sowas zum Beispiel. Dann haben wir Habecks Heizungshammer,
der ja eigentlich aus dem Hause Gaiwitz kommt.
Also diese große, wir gehen in deinen Keller und gucken mal nach, was da ist.
Machen eine kleine, was ist denn eigentlich verbaut Analyse,
nur das hat mit Habeck gar nichts zu tun, wird ihm trotzdem in die Schuhe geschoben.
Geil, jetzt duckt sich einfach weg.
Ja, die sagt einfach gar nichts dazu, sie hat ja auch die Hände voll zu tun,
damit 150 Wohnungen noch irgendwo zu erfinden. 150.000. 150.000.
Damit die ihre Statistiken haben.
Klappt hier wieder nicht. Genau, in der Bild schreibt dann irgendwie der CDU-Chef,
also Thürings CDU-Chef Mario Vogt, Klammer auf 46, die Bild weist ja immer drauf
hin, empört zu Bild, Zitat, Habecks Heizungswahn muss ein Stoppschild gesetzt werden.
Der Minister ignoriere die massiven Sorgen und Ängste der Bürger." Zitat von
dem CDU-Chef in Thüringen.
Jetzt will er die Energiestasi einsetzen, um wie in einem Schnüffelstaat den
Menschen in den Heizungskeller zu gucken.
Also, das, wie gesagt, ist Skywitz-Gesetz. Also, es ist wirklich Hanebüchen.
Und Olaf Scholz war ja nicht nur in Straßburg und in Aachen,
sondern auch im Bundestag.
Und seine Redebeiträge zum Thema Klima, Klimadiskussion, Heizung und so weiter,
werden im Deutschlandfunk.
Was hier auch völlig irre ist, wenn ich hier gerade darüber nachdenke,
es ist doch so, dass sowieso die Heizungen jährlich kontrolliert werden.
Also man kann ja ohnehin nicht als Hausbesitzer oder Mieter sagen,
geht Ihnen überhaupt nichts an, hier kommt keiner in den Keller,
hier guckt keiner in irgendeinen Schacht. Das ist ja nicht gegeben.
Ich kaufe zwar Gas für 1000 Euro im Jahr, aber ich sage Ihnen nicht, was ich damit mache.
Es ist irgendwie absurd. Also der Deutschlandfunk Politik Podcast,
da reden die ja so ein bisschen allgemeiner über die Sachlage.
Da wird mal kurz über Scholz auftreten zum Thema.
Allgemein und so weiter. Was ist das größte Thema in Deutschland?
Naja, die Heizung, das Klima. Findet von Olaf Scholz Seiten auch ein Klimadiskurs statt?
Es hat eine absolut blutleere Rede gehalten. Also es war kaum zu ertragen.
Völlig emotionslos, okay, das ist nicht überraschend. Aber wo ich auch das Gefühl
hatte, er hat quasi nichts gelernt aus dem, was man ihm vorgeworfen hat.
Und das Wort Heizung kam in dieser Rede nicht einmal vor. Das Wort Gebäudeenergiegesetz
kam nicht einmal vor. Aber er hat Wärmeplanung gesagt. Immerhin,
ja, er hat zwar nicht kommunale Wärmeplanung, aber Wärmeplanung gesagt.
Aber da war rein gar nichts, dass er überhaupt mitkriegt.
Da war überhaupt nicht zu sehen, dass er von diesem Thema überhaupt irgendwas mitkriegt.
Den er als Kanzler mit seiner Machtfülle dort irgendwie rausfindet.
Robert Habeck ist als Kommunikator ausgefallen.
Das war ja irgendwie das, was man in diesem Krisenjahr hatte.
Irgendwie Olaf Scholz sagt halt irgendwie nüscht, der macht nix.
Habeck erklärt, funktioniert jetzt halt im Moment auch einfach nicht mehr.
Und Christian Lindner ist da halt irgendwie auch keine große Hilfe.
Ja, Lindner ist auch keine große Hilfe. Also es findet genau nichts dazu statt.
Das wäre auch mal ein Thema auf so insgesamt.
Du wirst Kanzler in Deutschland, um dann genau nichts zu machen außer halt Bürotermine,
die aber möglichst niemand mitbekommen soll.
Das kennen wir ja schon von der Vorgängerin.
Ja, weil die hatte wenigstens den Nimbus, dass ihr halt ewig lang mit irgendwelchen
Leuten verhandelt und am Ende kommt
was bei rum. Ja, ja. Das ist ja nur in diesem Fall wirklich nicht so.
Die hat nur nicht kommuniziert mit Journalismus und Bevölkerung,
aber tatsächlich hat man bei Scholz gar nicht mehr so den Eindruck, dass da...
Er hält sich eben auch aus der Entscheidung aus, nicht aus der Kommunikation.
Wir beide sind ja nicht Leute, die betreut werden wollen vom Bundeskanzler.
Wir sind ja nicht die, die immer danach rufen, wo ist denn der Kanzler,
dass der uns jeden Morgen einen kleinen Gruß noch sendet.
Das wollen wir ja nicht. Es geht ja nur darum, dass wir den Kanzler als Entscheider
eigentlich gar nicht erleben.
Ja, also diese Diskussionen finden entweder gar nicht statt,
weil schon keine Entscheidungen stattfinden. Die FDP kann einfach sagen,
nö, findet in unserem Parlamentarismus nicht statt auf der Tagesordnung, also ist das dann so.
Und zur Debatte allgemein ist wahrscheinlich hier Rolf van Dijk ganz instruktiv,
Sozialpsychologe an der Goethe-Uni Frankfurt, der hat dem Redaktionsnetzwerk
Deutschland im Interview gegeben.
Gibt es einen Weg, die Wut aufzulösen, weil unter dieser ganzen misslichen Lage
leiden ja vor allem Autofahrer, weil andere Menschen sich auf der Straße festkleben
und sagen, jetzt muss aber mal entschieden werden.
Und eine dieser beliebigen Antworten endet dann, indem der Sozialpsychologe
sagt, macht doch viel direkter Druck und bringt vielleicht 2000 Politikerinnen
gegen euch auf, aber lasst 80 Mio.
Deutsche in Ruhe. Bringt sie im besten Fall auf eure Seite, damit dieser Druck multipliziert wird.
Also diese Sicht auf 80 Millionen Deutsche werden gerade von Klieberklebern auf der Straße.
Selbst in Berlin sind 99,99999% der Leute überhaupt nicht davon betroffen.
Also man muss wirklich lange suchen, bis man mal jemanden sieht,
der einem sagen kann, ja, ich stand mal in einem Stau, der von Klimakleberei blockiert wurde.
Also hier werden einfach 80 Millionen Deutsche in Beschlag genommen,
was ja überhaupt gar nicht stimmt.
Ja, lass mich nur mal eine Anmerkung dazu machen. Wir sind ja nicht im Verdacht,
dass wir gegen die Klimakleber sind.
Ich habe mich jetzt angemeldet, hier in der Nordwestgruppe, glaube ich,
bei Signal. Ich wollte mal gucken, ob die da irgendwas Interessantes diskutieren.
Wenn ich zur Oper fahre, dann versperrst du mir hier den Weg oder wie?
Nee, es ist aber nichts los in dieser Gruppe. Nichts los im Chat ist die Losung.
Okay.
Also es ist wirklich.
Ja, lass mich nur eine Anmerkung machen. Also ich finde, dass das Argument nicht
ganz falsch ist, dass man die Politiker gegen sich aufbringen muss und nicht die Bevölkerung.
Ja, es werden nicht 80 Millionen Menschen in Geiselhaft, wie es hieß,
genommen von den Klimakläbern.
Das sind vor allem Aktionen, die in Berlin oder in Hamburg stattfinden.
Ich bin, obwohl ich viel unterwegs bin, nie in so was reingekommen.
In Hamburg gab es das schon. Das Problem ist nur Folgendes. Die deutschen Autofahrer
sind wahnsinnig genervt davon, dass es nicht richtig auf der Straße weitergeht.
Ich war in Münster, hab dort in einer Performance mitgewirkt am Theater.
Bin freitags gefahren durch die Stadt.
Freitags gefahren durch nrw statt zwei stunden 20
habe ich vier stunden gebraucht und das ist alles
nur noch baustelle baustelle vollstau
baustelle und dann höre ich zugleich im podcast da wird noch mal argumentiert
warum das tempo limit so wichtig ist und man denkt ja könnte ich nur einmal
130 fahren wäre so glücklich und das ist das große problem und wenn du dann
in diesen situationen in wenn du Nachrichten hörst,
die Klimakleber haben irgendwo wieder eine Straße blockiert,
dann ist die Reaktion das auch noch.
Und der Vorteil aber bei den Klimaklebern ist, hier habe ich wenigstens mal
Gesichter, die sind also schuld.
Wenn ich in NRW in Baustellen stehe, weiß ich nicht, wer dafür gesorgt hat.
Dann kann ich dann sagen, der Wüst oder die Landesregierung davor oder sind
es Beamte, die die Anträge nicht durchbekommen, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es ist auf jeden Fall richtig viel, funktioniert da nicht.
Deswegen ist auch diese Anti-Auto-Haltung für die großen Städte sicherlich richtig.
Und da kann man auch viel mehr machen, dass da nicht überall Autos durchfahren müssen. Nur die...
Gesamtheit des Landes sieht nun anders aus und da fährt auch kein Zug und da
fährt dann nichts. Also ist nichts anderes möglich, als mit dem Auto zu fahren
und da geht es auch nicht voran.
Deswegen müsste man eigentlich Aktionen machen, bei denen die,
die wirklich entscheiden. Wir hatten das ja eben gehabt bei diesem Grünen,
dessen Namen wir vergessen sollten. Ich habe ihn auch jetzt schon vergessen.
Der sagte im Bundestag, wir schauen teilnahmslos zu, was mit den Flüchtlingen passiert.
Nein, wir sind ja teilnahmslos gegenüber vielen Klimapolitiken,
weil wir nichts machen können. Aber es gibt ja Leute, die gewählt wurden,
Stichwort Arbeitsteilung, die sich darum kümmern können.
Protestaktionen unter Druck gesetzt werden. Ich glaube auch,
dass man einen strategischen Kampf nur so ...
Man kann den Kampf nur gewinnen, wenn man strategischer ist,
als das jetzt stattfindet.
Ich habe da jetzt überhaupt kein Problem, wenn ich da irgendwo reingeraten würde.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich nicht dann, wie Ulf Posch hat wild geworden,
auf der Straße rumspringen und dann gehen Videos von mir viral.
Da werde ich dann auch mich selbst beherrschen.
Empfehlung den Aktivisten sagen, versucht mal die Leute zu treffen,
die entscheiden können.
Und versucht darüber eine Solidarität in der allgemeinen Bevölkerung herzustellen.
Ich glaube, dass das machbar ist.
Ich würde dem so ein bisschen widersprechen. Denn ich sehe einfach den Auftrag
nicht, dass die Leute, die das machen,
Man jetzt sagt, naja, wir haben doch die Grünen in der Regierung und die Protestler,
sollen die das mal mit dem Klima machen?
Im Sinne von, dass die ihre Wut jetzt irgendwie so kanalisieren,
dass es aber möglichst klug, möglichst instruktiv, möglichst in die richtige Richtung oder sowas.
Nein, nicht instruktiv.
Im Prinzip müssen die eine Aktion machen, dass die Grünen-Politiker sagen,
ach du Scheiße, dann kommen die ja morgen wieder.
Ja genau.
Weil ich kann ja, wenn die jetzt in Münster sich auf der Straße festmachen,
ich kann ja nichts ändern.
Also ich kann dann sagen, gut, das nächste Mal fahre ich eine halbe Stunde früher
los oder park woanders. Also was soll ich machen? Also das ist ja Quatsch.
Aber wenn ich die Entscheider unter Druck setze und die sagen,
ach scheiße, sonst haben wir das ja morgen wieder hier, das Debakel,
dann glaube ich, kann man schon etwas bewirken. Nur was passiert,
wenn ich irgendwelche Leute auf dem Arbeitsweg aufhalte?
Also das bringt jedes Mal, Julian Reichelt noch mal mehr Zuschauer,
habe ich Ich mache ein gefühltes Argument, wir haben es ja hier mit bewussten
Störungen der Abläufe zu tun.
Die haben auch ein politisches Ziel, also sie haben einen politischen Anlass.
Die Klimapolitik kommt nicht aus den Socken und wenn es jetzt,
es sind ja gar nicht so viele Jüngere, aber wenn sich jüngere Menschen auf der
Straße festkleben, haben die irgendwie noch 80 Jahre Leben vor sich,
also das ganze Jahrhundert noch.
Immer wenn jetzt heißt, bis zu Ende dieses Jahrhunderts werden es irgendwie
so und so viel Grad mehr, betrifft die das halt unmittelbarer,
wir haben es ja bei Carla Hinrichs gehört, als jetzt irgendwie irgendwem anders,
der halt nochmal zum Friedhof fährt, weil er gucken will, ob sein Grab schon bereit liegt oder so.
Und im Grunde stören jetzt einfach Menschen auf der Straße, was nun mal der
öffentlichste Raum ist, den wir haben, Abläufe.
Wir nutzen die Straße eben auch, aber anders als...
Ja, sagen wir mal der Zweck, für den sie gebaut wurden, nämlich,
dass man mit dem Auto ein bisschen schneller als über einen Feldweg da fahren
kann oder so. Jetzt kann man natürlich immer sagen, naja, das wäre aber klüger,
wenn die irgendwie die Zufahrt zum Parlament, damit die Politiker da irgendwie
morgens Schlange stehen müssen und nicht die Menschen, die zur Arbeit fahren oder so.
Sehe ich alles ein. Ich finde aber trotzdem, wir haben es ja erst mal mit einer Wut zu tun,
die sich einfach mal bahnen bricht und zwar auch so ein bisschen,
es ist halt Wut, also wenn man durch den Supermarkt geht und man steht an der...
Aber dann kann man sich nicht wundern, wenn die Wut zurückschlägt.
Und das möchte ich auch nicht. Das ist genau das, was mir ganz wichtig ist,
wenn jetzt irgendwer kommt und dann aussteigt und sagt, ne, aber du bist ja
selber schuld, du hältst ja die Abläufe auf.
Dann würde ich einfach sagen, ja, ich halte hier die Abläufe auf und der Rest
ist mir einfach egal. Wie auch so, und das ist eben die Unterstellung,
die dann gemacht wird und die ich jetzt
selber mache, aber eben ohne diese Vorverurteilung oder Verurteilung.
Wenn ein einjähriges Kind oder ein zweijähriges Kind in einem Supermarkt sich
auf den Boden legt und schreit, Um die Eltern so ein bisschen in Verlegenheit
zu bringen, ja, was mache ich jetzt, ich steuere jetzt hier auch die Abläufe und so weiter.
Finde das halt einfach statt, da bricht sich halt einfach Wutbahn.
Und klar werden dann Menschen davon belästigt und wenn man auch nur eine halbe
Sekunde darüber nachdenkt, sagt man sich, das könnte auch klüger sein.
Also das Kind könnte das auch besser machen. Nur in dem Fall würde ich sagen,
ja, hier bricht sich halt einfach Wutbahn.
Hier wird jetzt kein politischer Diskurs geführt, das ist kein Parlament,
das ist kein Klassenraum, das ist kein Seminar.
Was soll es? Es ist einfach nur Sichtbarkeit.
Aber das ist mir zu wenig. Man muss schon eine Strategie verfolgen.
Sonst braucht man keinen Protest, dann kann man das machen. Ich kann jetzt auch
brüllen durch Frankfurt, rennen und irgendwas fordern, dass nicht mehr gehustet wird.
Das beliebteste Argument dieser ganzen Bild und sonstigen Journalismus überall
ist ja auch im Parlament,
auch von der SPD und auch von Ricarda Lange zu sagen, Das, was die jetzt machen,
ist leider kontraproduktiv, die bringen ja nur noch mehr Leute gegen sich auf,
die dann noch mit Absicht mit einem
größeren Auto noch weiter entfernt zum Steak fahren, um das zu essen.
Und da würde ich sagen, ja gut, dann verbohre ich das unter Axialitarismus,
wenn der eine Gemütszustand, nämlich die blanke Wut, bei den anderen die blanke
Häme hervorbringt, zu sagen, na dann erst recht, dann zerstöre ich jetzt besonders den Planeten.
Dann würde ich sagen, nur ist das eingepreist, findet statt.
Die meisten Leute, die von den Klimakliemann betroffen sind,
werden wahrscheinlich erst einmal dafür sein, dass es eine sinnvolle Klimapolitik gibt.
Und sie würden wahrscheinlich, wie ich zum Beispiel, ich bin ja nicht von denen
betroffen gewesen bislang, würde ja unterschreiben, dass die Bundesregierung
viel zu wenig tut. Nur ist damit ja nicht geholfen, wenn ich das...
Ich meine ohnehin dann ständig in Staus führendes Leben noch mal weiter zugemauert
bekommen. Also es hat ja keinen Zweck.
Also es muss, ich will nicht konstruktiv, ich möchte nicht den Luisa Neubauer törnen.
Ich habe mal mit der Kanzlerin geredet und ihr noch mal erklärt,
wie das ist mit dem 1,5 Grad Ziel.
Diesen Unsinn brauche ich nicht. Ich würde aber festhalten wollen,
dass Aktivismus nur da sinnvoll ist,
wo er jene trifft, die am ehesten dafür sorgen können, dass dieser Aktivismus
in sinnvolle Politik überführt wird.
Denn hier kann ich ja, wenn ich jetzt hier, das ist jetzt, ich kann mich jetzt
auch hier gleich rausstellen und sagen nieder mit Frontex, aber das nutzt uns
hier in Frankfurt nix, wenn ich das gleich mal schreie.
Und deshalb glaube ich, dass wir es mit einer typischen medialen,
unsere Freunde vom Jacobin würden sagen, hyperpolitischen Erscheinung zu tun haben.
Wir diskutieren jetzt, wir tun es jetzt auch gerade wieder, über irgendwelche
komischen Aktionen, die aber in keiner Weise überführt werden können zu einer
anderen politischen Gestaltung.
Und das ist dann der Unterschied zum Beispiel zu einer Gewerkschaft oder zu
so etwas wie Genug ist genug oder den Volksentscheid Deutsche Wohnen und Co.
Enteignen, wo es tatsächlich dazu übergeht, dass man gegen die Macht kämpft.
Man kämpft nicht gegen die Macht, wenn Leute in ihrem Kleinwagen irgendwo auf
einer Straße zwei Stunden warten müssen, dann denken die, ja,
ich habe gestern schon gewartet, weil da ein Unfall war, heute warte ich noch
mal, weil sich irgendjemand festgeklebert, es macht am Ende keinen Unterschied.
Aber ich sag's nochmal, genau das, also genau das.
Ja, aber das ist ja so ganz kindisch.
Ne, das ist nicht kindisch, sondern ich sehe einfach, oder ich nehme diese Klimakleber
in Schutz, indem ich sage, ne, ihr
müsst nicht klüger sein als die dumme Klimapolitik. Klimapolitik ist dumm?
Es hat sich schon gezeigt, dass sich Boomer nicht überzeugen lassen,
es hat sich schon gezeigt, dass die partikularen Interessen auch im Parlament
überwiegen. Also macht ihr, bevor ihr gar nichts macht, wenigstens Klimaprotest
auf ganz dumme, inhaltliche, fragwürdige...
Aber die würden ja gar nicht behaupten, dass das dumm ist. Diese Zuschreibung
machst du ja jetzt gerade.
Genau, das mache ich jetzt.
Auf die können wir uns ja schon mal einigen. Ich würde aber auch hier nochmal
unterstreichen wollen, es sind ja nicht alle Boomer, es sind ja durchaus ältere
Generationen, die sehr wohl dieses Anliegen unterstützen.
Wie gesagt, ich halte diesen Kampf erst einmal für aussichtslos.
Ich halte ihn strategisch für dumm.
Und er trifft nicht die, die er eigentlich treffen sollte.
Man sollte, wenn man aktivistisch unterwegs ist, die Macht so bündeln,
seinen Aktivismus so bündeln, dass die Mächtigen diesen Gegendruck erfahren.
Die Mächtigen erfahren den Gegendruck nicht, weil sie mit dem Helikopter fliegen.
Ja, aber diese inhaltlichen Diskussionen, wie gesagt, wenn du jetzt so eine
Diskussion hast, wie es droht, tatsächlich Trump wieder Präsident zu werden
und gleichzeitig sind sich alle einig, der ist echt doof.
Hat man dann nicht ab und zu auch mal die Lust, ey, dann will ich auch einfach mal doof sein?
Okay, das kann ich so auf so einer psychologischen Ebene nachvollziehen.
Und ich finde, das steckt da irgendwie drin. Wenn Trump doof ist und trotzdem
gewählt wird, dann sind wir einfach auch mal doof.
Und das finde ich irgendwie, damit zeigt man zumindest noch,
das Thema ist da, wir wissen, es scheitert auf allen Ebenen,
wir kämpfen uns jetzt auch nicht hier ab, sondern wir machen einen Happening draus. Love Parade, ja?
Ja, aber das ist ja schon wirklich Love Parade.
Naja, aber das ist dieser Akzelektarismus, den man ja auch ein bisschen was
abgewinnen kann. Love Parade war ja damals, wir machen eine politische Demonstration
mit einem Ausspruch, wir sind unpolitisch.
Das interessiert uns nicht, aber wir sind trotzdem sichtbar.
Aber diese wollen ja politisch sein. Die Love Parade würde ja sagen,
wir tanzen auf dem Vulkan.
Das machen ja die Klimaaktivisten nicht. Die Klimaaktivisten schauen uns ja
ganz ernsthaft an und sagen, wir steuern auf die Katastrophe zu.
Und dann würde ich ja noch eher die Party akzeptieren, dann den Hedonismus,
da würde wahrscheinlich auch noch Matthias Döpfner einsteigen, aber so geht es ja nicht.
Wir können nicht sagen, wir wollen ganz aktivistisch sein und wir brauchen das,
wir müssen dringend was tun und dann aber sagen, es ist einfach nur so eine
Partyaktion. Nein, ich möchte, dass...
Es einen strategisch klugen Aktivismus gibt, der auch wehtut.
Du bist doch so hoffnungsvoll.
Also du willst einfach nur noch, dass du sagst jetzt, wir haben eine... die... die... die...
Naja, ich sehe...
Die Messe ist gesungen, wir können hier nichts mehr tun.
Wir haben jetzt Olaf Scholz zum Thema Volk beim Karlspreis gehört.
Und stellen fest, also diese Selbstbeschreibung, die da abläuft,
ist wirklich stronstoff, fragwürdig, gefährlich und so weiter. Wo soll das hinführen?
Unsere Fremdbeschreibung ist entsprechend. Jetzt sehe ich diesen Klimaaktivismus
und denke mir dann auch, warum sollte ich die jetzt überfordern mit so einem
von euch, von euch aber eine bessere Selbstbeschreibung und so weiter.
Sondern da stehe ich einfach mit meiner Fremdbeschreibung daneben und sage,
ja klar, sehr viele Leute stehen im Stau und so weiter und dürfen sich darüber
nicht aufregen, weil man weiß ja nicht und so.
Und es ist halt immer so ein bisschen fragwürdig, wohin führt es denn eigentlich?
Wir haben jetzt die Situation gehabt, dass die neue Justizsenatoren von Berlin,
das hast du bestimmt auch gesehen, in den Tagesthemen zu Gast waren.
Genau, und sie hat ja da zum Beispiel über die Klimakleber gesprochen und meinte dann,
hat dann so vorgerechnet, naja, erste Statistiken zeigen,
dass in Berlin Krankenwagen mit lebensgefährlich verletzten Menschen 26 Minuten
später am Klinikum ankommen, also da Versorgung gefährdet ist.
Das gilt wahrscheinlich aber auch, wenn Berlin Marathon ist.
Und das ist nämlich der Punkt, jetzt hat sie von Seiten der Politik die Argumentation
aufgemacht, dass Stau, Verkehrsbehinderung grundsätzlich erst mal ein Problem ist.
Am Beispiel Blockade durch Klimakleber. Aber was ist denn mit,
wenn man das als Chiffren nimmt, mit den anderen Blockaden?
So, und jetzt kann man sagen, ja gut, die Selbstbeschreibung der Klimakleber
war echt scheiße. Jetzt kann man sagen, meine Fremdbeschreibung ist auch ein
bisschen dämlich, indem ich die irgendwie vergleiche mit zwei Kindern im Supermarkt.
Aber es führte dazu, dass wir jetzt eine regierende Justizministerin haben,
die plötzlich einen Diskurs aufmacht
zum Thema, die Gründe einer Verkehrsverzögerung sind nicht mehr egal.
Und das ist ja eben beschrieben, wie die Verkehrsverzögerungen so aussehen.
Welche Diskussionen haben wir denn in einem Jahr, wenn wir das mal ein bisschen
weiterführen, wenn daran jetzt angeschlossen wird. So und da würde ich sagen,
das kann durchaus mal eine Verkehrswende einleiten, wenn nicht mehr jeder einfach
alles auf der Straße machen darf, zum Beispiel mit einem dicken SUV rumfahren.
Wenn der Anlass dafür war zu sagen, auf der Straße darf man nicht alles,
man darf sich zum Beispiel nicht da festkleben, würde ich sagen,
stimmt, auf einer Straße darf man nicht alles. Zum Beispiel,
man darf sich da nicht festkleben, was sollte man zum Beispiel noch alles nicht dürfen?
Und dann ist das für mich ein Einstieg auch in der SUV-Diskussion zum Beispiel.
Ja, und lauter solche Sachen. Deswegen, man weiß jetzt nicht genau, wohin es führt,
aber dass wir das als Phänomen und insbesondere als hochgradig kommunikativ
anschließbares Phänomen haben,
weil nämlich jeder, und ich saß auf dieser Bank bei diesem Handbeispiel in der
Sonne und plötzlich höre ich diesen Scheiß da die ganze Zeit,
selbst die reden darüber. Und da denke ich mir, ein guter Diskurs.
Aber ist das ein guter Diskurs, denn Sie reden ja dann über diese Aktionen und
Sie reden ja nicht konstruktiv darüber, wie könnte man generell den Verkehr
besser, geschmeidiger organisieren, sondern es ist ja ein Aufregen über einzelne Akteure.
Und man sieht ja auch bei YouTube, was einem angezeigt wird.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das verändern wird. Ich glaube, das sind solche
Debatten wie die um die Papierstrohhalme und so ein Kram.
Also man hat solche Scheindebatten und tatsächlich müsste man doch dahin kommen,
dass die Debatte eher ist, du hast es ja eben vorgemacht.
Die Wasserversorgung stimmt ja eigentlich gar nicht. Ich habe nicht den Eindruck,
dass von diesen Aktionen und von der Debatte um diese Aktionen,
und das ist ja nicht alleine den Klimaklebern anzukreiden, sondern generell,
dass von diesen Debatten aus irgendetwas hinführt zu den fundamentaleren Fragen.
Also ich werbe noch mal für die Atmosensorik. Es sind Zukunftsbilder.
Hier sind doch bestimmt KI-Leute und alles, die sollen mal so eine Erinnerung
machen. Ende Mai 2023, Ende Mai 2024.
Bitte mal dann so kurz vorher in die E-Mail schicken. Vielleicht kann da irgendjemand
mal eine Erinnerung machen, ob sich die Debatte so verändert hat,
wie Stefan uns das jetzt hier skizziert hat.
Also ich werbe auch für die Gespräche in der Sensorik. Der ein oder andere Jurist
ist ja jetzt schon aufgefallen, selbst Thomas Fischer musste sich äußern,
auch wenn auch publizistisch.
Auf sehr dumme Aktionen haben wir jetzt dadurch provoziert sehr dumme Reaktionen
aus der regierenden Politik gehört.
Und jetzt kommen die ersten Juristen und sagen, Momentchen mal, also bitte.
Und das, finde ich, ist der Einstieg in die eigentliche Diskussion.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wohin das führt.
Deswegen provoziert mal schön weiter. Es wird, glaube ich, noch eine oder andere
politische bescheuerte Reaktion geben, bei der man dann sagt,
also jetzt müssen wir wirklich mal ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich habe mir im Zuge dessen hier mal angeschaut, wie wird eigentlich woanders,
also beispielsweise in Italien, über Klima debattiert?
Gibt es da überhaupt Klimadiskussionen? Wir hören einen einminütigen Clip aus
der Welt, also Welt TV, Springer und so weiter.
In Rom wurde der Dreh wie Brunnen geschändet.
Damit in die Hauptstadt Rom. Bürgermeister Roberto Gelateri hat die jüngste
Klimaprotestattacke auf den Trevi-Brunnen scharf verurteilt.
Er appellierte an die Täter der letzten Generation, derartige Aktionen zu unterlassen.
Man kann protestieren, das ist legitim und sogar notwendig, aber nicht auf diese Weise, sagte er.
Am Sonntagvormittag hatten mehrere protestierende Behälter mit schwarzem Kohlestaub
im Brunnenbecken des Fontana di Trevi entleert. 300.000 Liter mussten ausgetauscht
werden. So viel zum Klimaschutz.
Was ist eigentlich mit den ganzen Münzen, die da drin sind? Mussten die auch rausgenommen werden?
Wenn ihr mehr News aus unserem Team wollt, dann müsst ihr einmal hier klicken.
Wenn ihr auf der Suche seid nach spannenden Dokus, starken Reportagen,
dann geht es hier entlang.
Die Welt hat noch einiges im Angebot. Die machen sich also ein bisschen drüber lustig.
Man hat es so im Ton gehört. So viel zum Klimaschutz, 300.000 Liter Wasser da austauschen muss.
Wir wissen ja aus Italien, da war die Lage so ... Dann noch der Trevi-Brunnen.
Da darf ja eigentlich nur Anita Eckberg drin baden.
Wenn die Fotografen dabei sind. Wir haben ja eigentlich eine Klimaanlage,
die ungefähr so aussah, jetzt auch im Mai.
Innerhalb eines Tages ging an manchen Orten der Region ein Drittel des Jahresniederschlages herunter.
In den Monaten zuvor hatte hier Trockenheit geherrscht. die Böden ausgedörrt.
Der zuständige Minister spricht von einer neuen Realität.
Nichts wird mehr sein, wie es vorher war. Was in diesen Stunden geschieht,
ist Zeugnis für künftige lange Dürreperioden und sehr kurze Perioden heftiger Niederschläge.
Wir müssen jetzt an ein Wassersystem denken, das Wasser speichert.
Wir haben unsere Autos, unser Harp und Gut, das, wofür wir 20 Jahre lang geschuftet
haben, innerhalb von 5 Minuten verloren.
Also nicht nur haben die jetzt so viel Dürre, Stress, die Böden funktionieren.
Nicht mehr, die Ansage gekriegt haben, wir haben jetzt immer stehende Wetterlagen,
also drei Wochen lang Hitze, Dürre sowieso das ganze Jahr über,
aber wenn es dann regnet, regnet es gleich richtig, also so wie es halt immer ist.
Und dann denkt man ja, na, da werden die Italiener ja wohl ordentlich diskutieren.
Ich habe mir GPT genommen, das kann ja jetzt webbrowsen und habe gesagt,
hier, wo wird denn übers Klima diskutiert?
Dann sitzt man vor diesem GPT wirklich wie vor so einer alten Steampunk-Maschine
und dann sieht man so, Braust jetzt so rum im Internet, öffnet einen Link,
öffnet den nächsten Link.
Öffne den nächsten Link, failed, Error und so weiter.
Also es hat überhaupt gar nicht funktioniert. Ich war ganz überrascht,
dass GPT sehr gut aus dem eigenen Modellinhalt, der Datenbestand uns irgendwie was sagen kann.
Aber dieses Browsing und so weiter ist alles noch sehr behäbig.
Mal gucken, das wird bestimmt schnell besser.
Deshalb hab ich dann umgeswitcht und hab mir ein DeepL-Account gemacht.
Weil die ja das tolle Browser-Plugin haben, gibt's auch von Google und so weiter.
Aber die haben ja tollere Übersetzungen, wie es heißt.
Surft man die internationalen Zeitungsseiten an und kriegt die einfach auf deutsch
angezeigt, also da wird einfach das gleiche Format, ist ja nicht so schwer Format
und Inhalt ist ja streng getrennt und dann hast du einfach die ganzen Zeitung
vor dir und kannst sie so als deutsche Zeitung lesen.
Also bin ich mal durchgegangen, war so in den Zeitungen gelesen.
Das wusste ich ja gar nicht, mit dem einfachen Diepel Abo.
Genau, das DeepL-Abo braucht aber dann ein Pro-Account, das kostet irgendwie
so 15 Euro im Monat oder so, wo du dann auch ganze Dokumente hinschicken kannst
und da hast du dann leider nur für Chrome und Edge, das habe ich mit Chrome
unterladen musste, ich mache sonst alles mit Firefox.
So, und da habe ich mal gelesen, also in Italien angefangen,
la Repubblica, es war wirklich nichts zu finden, außer zu diesem blöden Teich, Teichbrunnen da in Rom.
Neun Aktivisten sind also reingesprungen und haben dann, wie es hier heißt,
zahlreiche Dosen von dieser Asche ausgeschüttet.
Sie haben aber nur zwei auskippen können.
Und der Bürgermeister, der dann herangeeilt ist, hat natürlich die Ultima Generatione
Aktivisten verurteilt.
Und meinte, das wird jedoch einen erheblichen Eingriff bedeuten.
Denn auch wenn nach ersten Schätzungen keine bleibenden Schäden,
also kennen wir so von den deutschen Grundgesetzsthälen da, erwartet ist,
so muss doch jetzt einige Zeit und Mühe und Wasser aufgewendet werden,
weil 300.000 Liter müssen ersetzt werden.
Nun gut, lassen wir Italien hinter uns, gucken wir nach Frankreich.
In Frankreich, ich wurde nur getriggert, weil im Deutschlandfunk diese neue
Diskussion in Frankreich über die 4-Grad-Erwärmung bis zum Ende des Jahrhunderts
jetzt öffentlich diskutiert wird.
Dafür ökologische Transformation. Christoph Béchut hält dieses Szenario für
realistisch und sagt, alles andere sei Zitat Verleugnung.
Sein Ministerium startet deshalb ab heute eine Art Bürgerbefragung zur Klimaanpassung.
Worum es da genau geht, kann ich jetzt besprechen mit meiner Kollegin Annika
Jörres. Sie ist Fachjournalistin für Klimapolitik.
Frau Jörres, erklären Sie uns doch erstmal, wie muss man sich eigentlich diese
Befragung, Der offizielle Begriff
ist Konsultation zur Klimaanpassung vorstellen, die da heute beginnt.
Wie funktioniert das? Ja, die Befragung wird ein paar Monate andauern und da
kann tatsächlich jeder Mensch in Frankreich sich daran beteiligen und zum Beispiel
zum Rathaus gehen oder anderen öffentlichen Gebäuden und da seine Meinung kundtun
eben zu der Klimaanpassung,
die Frankreich, auf die Frankreich sich jetzt vorbereiten soll.
Das kann auch im Internet passieren, aber es gibt verschiedene Wege.
Das Ziel ist eigentlich, so ein breites Meinungsbild einzufangen von der Bevölkerung,
also sollen sich möglichst viele beteiligen.
Dafür trommelt der Klimaminister.
Und am Ende des Sommers soll dann nochmal das ausgewertet werden und eine Grundlage
sein für den nächsten Klimaanpassungsplan, den Frankreich dann verabschieden wird.
Also sie haben einen Minister für Klimawandel. Ist wahrscheinlich so,
naja, auf verlorenen Posten. Wir kennen das ja in Deutschland.
Auch ein Bundesminister kann mal sagen, für uns arbeiten 50 Sklaven und wir
bräuchten eigentlich mal Verantwortung im Lieferkettengesetz und am Ende kommt
dann trotzdem nur Müll raus.
So sehe ich das hier irgendwie auch, aber.
Hat bisschen Bürgerratscharakter.
Ja, genau. Was aber bedeutet, dadurch sind die vier Grad erst mal gesetzt.
Also die Regierung redet jetzt mit dem Volk darüber, dass es ja vier Grad,
also dass es vier Grad werden.
Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Wenn man dann so nachliest, nochmal bei David Wells
oder so, also vier Grad heißt für Frankreich keine Landwirtschaft mehr.
Es ist nicht nur so im Sinne von, die Weinberge rutschen dann so ein bisschen,
die Weinarten rutschen in den Norden oder so, sondern einfach keine Landwirtschaft
mehr, weil es eben auch gar nicht mehr regnet.
Naja, sie führen so die ein oder andere Diskussion. Ich habe mal bei Le Monde
nachgeschaut. Überschrift. Um den Verkehr zu entkarbonisieren steht das Volksauto,
in Anführungszeichen, klein und elektrisch im Mittelpunkt der Debatte.
Es gibt also auch eine vom Verkehrssektor und da spricht dann der Verkehrsminister
für, also das Ministerium für den ökologischen Übergang, also auch dieser Christoph
Boucher heißt er wahrscheinlich, der führt eine Diskussion zum neues Volksauto.
Also so wie wir eine Heizungsdiskussion führen, reden die über ihr Volksauto
und die Ansprüche sind, es sollte eben klein, klimaneutral und so weiter,
aber auch ansprechend sein.
Also nicht nur einfach, sondern es soll groß ausgerollt werden.
Ich habe nochmal nachgeschaut, dieses Ministerium hieß bislang zum Beispiel
Ministerium für Ökologie, Nachhaltige Entwicklung und Energie.
Soweit so gut. Dann kam noch mal Umwelt, Energie und Meer rein.
2017 wurde es umbenannt, Ministerium für den ökologischen und solidarischen Übergang.
Also man hat, bevor Greta aufkam,
2017 schon den solidarischen zum ökologischen Übergang dazugesellt.
Danach wurde es 2020 das Ministerium zum ökologischen Übergang und ist nun das
Ministerium für den ökologischen Übergang und den territorialen Zusammenhalt.
Aha, also in Frankreich hat man das ein bisschen höher aufgehangen und zusammen
mit der Ministerin für den Energiewandel wird jetzt diese Diskussion geführt,
also zwei Bundesminister oder Republiksminister, wie das auch immer heißt da,
führen jetzt diese Diskussion über das Auto und die Herausforderung,
es auch gegen, naja, die ganzen Lobbyinteressen, ökonomischen Margen und so
weiter irgendwie in den Markt zu bringen.
Nun gut, nächste Diskussion, die in Frankreich geführt wird und das ist mal
so Stichtag, Freitag, letzten Freitag, also 22.3. irgendwann dann.
Ökologischer Übergang, Regierung gegen die Schaffung einer Zitat,
also in Anführungszeichen grünen Vermögenssteuer.
Die Exekutive sagt, dass sie der Schaffung einer neuen Steuer für die Reichen,
die von dem Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Jean Pisani-Ferry oder wie auch immer,
befürwortet wird, die Begründung der bestehenden Steuern vorzieht.
Also man will lieber keine Vermögenssteuer jetzt zum Thema Klima,
aber zumindest sich da mal einen Text schreiben lassen.
Der wurde dann an der Seite des Ministers vorgestellt und beinhaltete zum Beispiel
die Feststellung, Frankreich hat pro Jahr einen Finanzierungsbedarf von 70 Milliarden
Euro für die Klimakrise.
Diese müssen privat und öffentlich organisiert werden.
Was bedeutet, so dann der Wirtschaftswissenschaftler an der Ministerseite auf
der Bühne, wir brauchen eine Verschuldung um weitere zehn BIP-Punkte bis 2030.
Hat er einfach mal BIP-Punkte genannt als Kategorie. Das wäre in Deutschland völlig undenkbar.
Ja, das sind ja 70 Milliarden mehr als der Haushalt für die Bundeswehr vorsieht in Deutschland.
Und Olaf Scholz hat ja eine Europa-Rede gehalten, auf die wir vielleicht noch
kommen, vielleicht auch nicht.
Jedenfalls ging es da ganz kurz um Austeritätspolitik und da hat er erst betont,
wie toll das war, dass wir alle während Corona zusammengehalten haben.
Hat aber auch schon angezeigt, dass das natürlich kein Zukunftsmodell sein kann,
wenn man immer weiter Schulden macht.
Wär mehr von ...
Christian Lindner gelernt, die Krisen sind jetzt vorbei, 2023.
Und Scholz hat da quasi Christian Lindners Botschaft ein bisschen sozialdemokratisch verpackt präsentiert.
Wir beginnen jetzt noch mit der großen, bevor die Haushaltsdiskussion losgeht,
wir müssen hier mal alle sparen.
Naja, diese 10% BIP-Verschuldung wird dann ergänzt, außerordentliche Steuer
auf das Finanzvermögen der 10% der wohlhabendsten Steuerzahler.
Ich habe diese BIP-Prozente mal für Deutschland durchgerechnet.
Frankreich hat jetzt einen Schuldenstand, der sprang während Corona auf aktuell 115 Prozent.
Corona alleine hat von 98 auf 115 Prozent, also 17 Prozent mehr Verschuldung.
Wir haben so 67.
Wir liegen aktuell bei 67 bei 2,5 Billionen Euro Verschuldung.
Das heißt, 10% BIP bei uns sind 350 Milliarden Euro.
Kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen, dass Marcel Fratscher in Berlin auf einer
Bühne neben der Umweltministerin oder Habeck steht und sagt,
ja, ich empfehle eine Verschuldung um weitere 350 Milliarden bis Ende des Jahrzehnts.
Also 350 Milliarden durch sieben Jahre sind ja dann auch wieder 50 Milliarden
Verschuldung pro Jahr zur Klimaanpassung. Also eigentlich undenkbar.
Und wenn man es mal noch anders rechnet und sagt, wir müssen erst mal noch auf
den Schuldenstand von Frankreich kommen, da haben wir noch ein paar Billionen offen.
Jetzt geht der Text aber weiter. Ist die Steuer eine Lösung?
Nein. Das in Zitat sagt Wirtschaftsminister Bruno Lammer am Dienstag bei RTL.
Der Minister, der sich erneut zum Hüter der Steuerstabilität machte,
ist der Ansicht, dass der Bericht den Weg einer neuen Steuer,
Zitat, als Option, nicht als Notwendigkeit darstellt.
Also er erkennt zumindest an, dass es gerechnet wurde, aber will die Folgen nicht haben.
Er betonte, dass die potenzielle Zielgruppe bereits 75 Prozent der Einkommenssteuer zahlt.
Beliebtes Argument auch in Deutschland. Er betonte, dass seine Politik darauf
ausgerichtet sei, die Steuern zu senken und die Steuerlast in einem Land mit
der höchsten Steuerlast aller Industrieländer zu senken.
Also wir wissen, in Frankreich wird diskutiert wie in Deutschland.
Wenn Macron Außenpolitik macht, ist das was anderes, als wenn er Innenpolitik
macht. Da werden die Gürtel enger geschnallt.
Le Monde ist ganz interessant, die haben nämlich eine Planete,
also eine Subseite Planet, da kann man so ein paar Überschriften lesen.
Serious Games, sehr seriöse Werkzeuge zur Unterstützung des ökologischen Wandels.
Also Gamification der Klimawandelpolitik.
Außerdem gibt es einen Plastikwetterbericht für Paris.
Da wird dann zum Beispiel gemeldet, heute wieder 40 Kilogramm Mikroplastikregen
auf Paris, was ich mich uninteressant finde, so 40 Kilogramm auf Paris,
jede Stadt, jeden Tag verteilt ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht.
Und die dritte Überschrift hier ist, in Deutschland kriminalisieren die Behörden
die radikale Umweltbewegung, letzte Generation.
Also das hat sich auch nach dahin vorgeschlagen.
Naja, Spanien, gucken wir mal noch ein bisschen nach Spanien,
da liest man natürlich, wie heißt die Zeitung? Ich weiß gar nicht welche,
die größte habe ich da, El Pais.
Trotz der jüngsten Regenfälle sinkt der Wasservorrat in Spanien weiter.
Die Stauseelen liegen 21 Prozent unter dem Durchschnitt der letzten zehn Jahre.
Also 20 Prozent in zehn Jahren Minus, das heißt noch mal zehn Jahre und die
haben dann nur noch halb so viel Wasser und die müssen jetzt schon alles Wasser
für Barcelona aus dem Meer nehmen und entsalzen, was unfassbare Energie kostet.
Es muss ja alles abgekocht und einmal durchgedünstet werden. Es ist unglaublich.
Brüssel warnt, dass das spanische Stromnetz nicht ausreicht,
um alle Projekte im Bereich der erneuerbaren Energien aufzunehmen.
Also die deutsche Diskussion.
Ja, Söder möchte irgendwie bayerische Atomkraftwerke, aber er hat keine Stromnetze
dafür und im Norden, wo man ordentliche Stromnetze hat, sind die Netzentgelte
so hoch, dass der billige Strom nicht kunstengünstig bei den Nutzern ankommt.
Also dieser ganze Blödsinn. Und hier noch eine, es ist nicht nur Donana oder
Doniana, das ist das größte Feucht- und Sumpfgebiet Europas,
das langsam austrocknet.
Volksvertreter und Liberale torpedieren die europäische grüne Agenda aus Angst vor Wählerverlusten.
In einem Wahljahr in Ländern wie Spanien und Polen und vor den Europawahlen.
Und im Jahr 2024 erklärt die EVP einem wichtigen Gesetz zum Schutz der biologischen Vielfalt den Kampf.
Die Liberalen, Macron und De Croo, fordern eine Zitat Pause bei der Umweltgesetzgebung.
Unglaublich. Also das ist so der europäische, es ist überall genauso schlimm wie bei uns.
Oder es wird gar nicht über Klima diskutiert. Ja.
Und ich will nur ein Ding anfügen zum Thema.
Ein Tweet von Adam Tooze, ich war wirklich sehr überrascht. Ich habe mich ja
auch immer sehr dafür ausgesprochen, dass die Luftfahrt bleibt.
Ja. Weil wir diese Art von globaler Völkerverständigung, also dass Begegnungen
wichtig sind, haben wir durch Corona gelernt.
Und man sollte lieber alles andere opfern, aber das muss dann sein.
Und klar, wenn man es ersetzt kriegen, ist gut, und dann hat er in dem Tools
einen Tweet geschrieben,
laut einer Berechnung, die er hier verlinkt, braucht man eine Investition von
300 Milliarden, also das ist wirklich verschwindend gering eigentlich für die globale Luftfahrt.
Und dann könnte man die ganzen Treibstoffe ersetzen durch klimaneutrale,
ja, was man dann halt so entweder durch Wasserstoffgewinnung,
durch Energie aus Wind und so weiter, oder eben durch hier diese ganze EFU-Diskussion,
die braucht man fürs Flugzeug und so weiter.
Und wenn man das dann noch klug mit der Steuer macht, jetzt sind ja die Kerosine
alle steuerbefreit und so weiter,
wenn man die besteuert, aber dann die neuen Treibstoffe nicht besteuern würde,
hätte man allein über Markt- und Kostenregelung eine, also die haben das durchgerechnet,
es wäre zwei Prozent billiger.
Was? Es wäre nur zwei Prozent teurer.
Hört das ja auch nicht viel.
Nee, zwei Prozent billiger. Es wäre zwei Prozent billiger,
2035 zu fliegen, wenn man mit den Finanzmitteln, er fragt dann,
Adam Tewes fragt dann, wir haben doch die pricing tools, macht er so die Feststellung
und fragt, wo ist eigentlich das Drama?
Also wenn die FDP mal bei dem E-Fuel-Scheiß nicht so, ja, müssen wir auch noch
für den Porsche und so weiter,
weil wenn man da sagt, ja, alles gute Diskussion,
also egal, wo wir es herbekommen und in welcher Form wir es zur Verfügung stellen,
aber diese Kapazitätsstelle für die Luftfahrt zur Verfügung und alle anderen
fahren bitte mit Batterie und so weiter und so fort,
dies hat es ja auch noch mal durchgerechnet, eine 3 Megawatt-Turbine könnte
1600 Energieautos bewegen, die den Strom in Batterie mitnehmen oder irgendwie 15 Verbrenner.
Also das wäre die Kalkulation, wie viel Energie verloren geht,
wenn man E-Fuels herstellt.
Aber für die Luftfahrt gibt es ja das Szenario,
dass man das ganze Jet-Fuel-Zeug mit klimaneutralem Wasserstoff um zwei Prozent
billiger macht als mit einer anständigen,
nämlich Bepreisung, also steuerlichen Bepreisung von Kerosin heute,
als wenn man diese Entwicklung einfach weiterzieht.
Also wenn man selbst rechnerisch Luftfahrt demnächst klimaneutral bekommt,
ohne dass es nennenswert Kosten verursacht, da fragt man sich wirklich,
was hält die denn alle zurück?
Außer irgend so ein komischer Ideologie-Kampf und so weiter um Bratwurstverbrenner und so weiter.
Ja, das wird auf den Kulturkampf hinauslaufen am Ende und es wird nichts geschehen. Oder zu spät.
Also es ist wirklich sehr schräg.
Die Wagner-Leute sind jetzt in Donbass.
Bachmut, Soleda, Jakovlivka, Makijivka, diese Richtung. Und da halten wir die Stellung.
Denn wenn wir die Wagner-Leute in der Region Bachmut aufhalten können,
dann haben unsere Soldaten in der Region Kherson die Möglichkeit,
die Russen zu vertreiben." Einige Straßen seien in Bachmut zurückerobert worden,
erzählt Alexander weiter.
Die ukrainische Armee führe wirksame Gegenangriffe aus.
So beschrieb auch der Befehlshaber der Bodentruppen Oleksandr Sierski die Lage auf Telegram.
An bestimmten Frontabschnitten habe sich die russische Seite bis zu zwei Kilometer
weit zurückziehen müssen.
Laut Sierski starten die ukrainischen Einheiten rund um Bakhmut Gegenangriffe.
An einigen Orten seien Wagner-Söldner inzwischen durch weniger gute Soldaten
der russischen Armee ersetzt worden.
Es war glaube ich 12. Mai etwa dieser Beitrag.
Inzwischen hat sich die Lage ja da dann verändert, etwas mehr zugunsten der
Russen, wenngleich man auch da immer nur noch von ein, zwei Kilometer nach vorne und zurück spricht.
Es ist ein Fleischwolf, wie es geschildert wird. Diese Wagner-Gruppe geht besonders
brutal vor. Man muss sich das auch vergegenwärtigen.
Die besteht zum Teil zu 50 Prozent aus Insassen, aus Gefängnisinsassen,
die mit dem Versprechen, wenn sie sechs oder acht Monate dienen bei der Gruppe Wagner,
dann in die Freiheit entlassen werden.
Das heißt, wir haben es damit zum Teil Schwerverbrechern zu tun,
die Mördervergewaltiger sind. und die dann jetzt bald wieder,
wenn sie das überleben, auf die Bevölkerung losgelassen werden.
Wir können aber auch hier nochmal diese These bestätigt sehen,
dass wir es auch in Russland mit einer post-terrorischen Gesellschaft zu tun
haben, dass es also auch für die Russen schwer ist, Leute zu rekrutieren,
die das freiwillig wollen. Also muss man zu solchen.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das noch schildern will, weil es ist ja eine
Privatisierung eigentlich des Krieges durch die Gruppe Wagner und zugleich haben
wir es aber mit einem zwischenstaatlichen Krieg zu tun.
Es ging ja sogar soweit, dass bei den Russen,
also auf russischer Seite jetzt Afghanen mitkämpfen,
die mit dem Westen zusammen versucht haben Afghanistan aufzubauen,
dann vom Westen im Stich gelassen wurden, jetzt vor den Taliban fliehen,
dann nach Russland fliehen, hoffen da auf Staatsbürgerschaft und Sicherheit
und können sich diese erwerben, indem sie kämpfen.
Was wir hier also sehen, man versuchte alle Mittel in Bewegung zu setzen,
um irgendwie an Leute zu kommen, die bereit sind oder keine andere Wahl haben,
als sich diesen Gefechten auszusetzen.
Wir haben aber auch Situationen gehabt, in der im Irak, während das amerikanische
Mandat lief, mehr als die Hälfte der Amerikaner dort Contractors waren,
also über Blackwater und so weiter.
Stimmt.
Die werden natürlich nicht aus Gefängnissen rekrutiert und so,
aber das ist auch alles sehr zwieschneidig.
Und dass man jetzt diese Wagner da immer so hervorhebt und das auch als neue
Qualität und Dimension von Kriegsführung, da würde ich sagen, nee.
Also das kennen wir von Amerika schon seit langem.
Von Erhard Eppler, dem SPD-Kranken, gab es schon vor 20 Jahren ein Buch,
das hieß vom Gewaltmonopol zum Gewaltmarkt.
Und da beschreibt er solche Entwicklungen bereits. Wir hören jetzt nochmal von
der Tagesschau diesen Bericht über Mahmoud.
Wer in eine Offensive angreift, hat immer mehr Opfer als die Verteidiger einer
Linie. Die Ukraine ist kein so großes Land, kein einziger Tod eines Soldaten
ist jetzt vergebens. Aber wenn es möglich ist, das zu vermeiden,
werden die Kommandeure das tun.
Kein einziger Tod eines Soldaten ist vergebens. Dies war die Überschrift dieses Tagesschau-Beitrags.
Und das ist das Furchtbare, was wir jetzt überall erleben.
Und ich werde mich auch dem verweigern, mich daran zu gewöhnen,
dass wir diese martialische Sprache jetzt in Überschriften laufend finden.
Und dass hier auch ja eine Aussage dann sehr, sehr auf einen Halbsatz reduziert
wird. Und man packt das in die Überschrift, weil das dann besonders gut geht.
Und die mutigen Helden und so weiter.
Und zugleich ist das einfach ein sinnloses, sich gegenseitiges Töten.
Aber tatsächlich ist diese Frage, wer macht's? Also wer zieht in den Krieg?
Eine, die auch die Bundeswehr umtreibt.
So hat die Bundeswehr nun seit Mai dieses Jahres eine neue Marketing-Kampagne
am Start. mit der Marketingagentur CastNow.
Da werden also eigene Formate entwickelt für YouTube, eigene Kampagnen.
Zum Beispiel auch mach was wirklich zählt, was zählt.de ist dann eine Seite.
Die Bundeswehr-Poster können wir an Bushaltestellen sehen.
Ein Bekannter aus Köln schickte mir da etwas,
wo nicht mehr sicher war, ist das jetzt die Werbung für die Bundeswehr oder
für die Survival Show, wie heißt das, diese Influencer in the wild oder irgendwas,
diese Youtube Show. Also, be strong!
Heißt das kostenlose Jugendmagazin der Bundeswehr, dann gibt es ja auch immer
gleich so Leserbriefe von jungen Leuten, die sich begeistert zeigen.
Die Bundeswehr will auf ungefähr 20.000 Frauen und Männer anwachsen bis 2030, also um 20.000,
Männer und Frauen anwachsen bis 2030 und das ist gar nicht so leicht zu bewerkstelligen.
Wir hören jetzt mal in so ein Format herein. Das ist jetzt Lara im Einsatz.
Wir beide können es auch sehen. Wir können das ein bisschen beschreiben.
Das ist ein YouTube-Format.
Ich bin Lara. Jetzt bin ich für drei Monate in Jordanien und Irak.
Ganz grundsätzlich ist die Sicherheitslage hier ja ganz gut.
Trotzdem darf man sich unterschätzen. Es gibt Gründe, weshalb wir hier sind.
Wir müssen das Gebäude beeilen. Vormittags ist hier definitiv Stress.
Aber dann wird's nicht langweilig.
Wir tun hier natürlich alles, um unsere Sicherheit aufrechtzuerhalten.
Ruhsfeld auch nicht vergessen, was ist die Kehrseite der Medaille?
Warum sind wir überhaupt hier? Schon ein heftiges Gefühl. Ich weiß auch zu schätzen,
dass ich jetzt hier die Möglichkeit habe, mal wenigstens für den Tag reinzuschnuppern.
Action, Musik, Dramatik. Wir sind fast in einem Michael-Bay-Film. Es wird aber ruhiger.
Das Ganze, es wird dann so ein bisschen erzählt, was sie da eigentlich machen.
Hier wird ein Rettungsflug aus dem Sudan geschildert.
Wir haben letztendlich 116 Personen gerettet.
Darunter war unser jüngster Passagier, zwei Tage alt. Da muss man davon ausgehen,
dass das kleine Baby dann auf der Flucht geboren wurde.
Und wenn man die Leute rausfliegt und dann in den Laderaum geht und dann ein
Lächeln erhält von den Kindern und von den Erwachsenen, das ist dann für uns schon genug.
Und da freuen wir uns, dass wir dann dort helfen können und die Leute dann retten können.
Also, man ja, man hat Menschen aus dem Sudan gerettet. Man hat nämlich alle,
die legitime Ausreisegründe hätten, zum Beispiel sind Deutsche,
hat man rausgeholt, dass sehr viele Deutsche da waren, um dort für Sicherheit
und Hilfe zu sorgen. dass man also...
Auch die sudanesen jetzt im stich gelassen hat durch diese aktion wird ja gar
nicht thematisiert aber das fand ich eigentlich als der deutschlandfunk darüber
sprach sehr instruktiv dass man diese sichtweise auch noch mal aufmacht.
Wir haben auch so eine Diskursverschiebung, wie über die Bundeswehr gesprochen wird im Sinne von,
naja, wie kriegen wir denn jetzt das grüne Publikum für die Bundeswehr auf Dauer gesichert,
denn das ist ja immer so die Frage, die Grünen haben sich ja sehr zur Bundeswehr
gewendet, aber wird das auch auf Dauer bleiben und dann gab es ja schon solche
komischen Artikel, die Bundeswehr muss woke und wehrhaft sein.
Und in der Tat ist das jetzt auch in der Kampagne wiederzufinden.
Zum Beispiel sieht man da eine Soldatin in einem Panzer, wie sie da rausschaut.
Und da steht dann, ich kämpfe für mein Land und gegen Vorurteile.
Und darunter steht dann, egal wie du bist, hier bist du richtig.
Oder man versucht es mit familiären Werten. Ich bin für meine Einheit da und für meine Familie.
Man möchte nämlich auch die Teilzeit mehr ermöglichen, wenngleich man sagen
muss Teilzeitkriege wird es ja dann nicht geben.
Also das ist ja immer so eine Sache, jetzt gerade als Arbeitgeber geht es,
aber dann wird es eher schwierig und Kurt Kister hat das für die Süddeutsche
aufgeschrieben, hat sich diese Kampagne mal angesehen und sagt,
Die aktuelle Stärke-Kampagne der Bundeswehr ist seit Jahrzehnten die erste, bei der in
einer nur leicht verschwurbelten Art auf den eigentlichen Grund der Existenz
der Armee hingewiesen wird.
Stärke zeigen, Grenzen setzen, bereit sein für eine raue Welt.
Die Armee stellt sich nicht mehr als Karrieremöglichkeit, Entwicklungshilfe,
Organisation oder bewaffnete Volkshochschule dar. Sie tritt zumindest auf den
Plakaten auf, als sie ...
Als sei sie eine Armee. Das hat viel zu tun damit, wie sehr der russische Überfall
auf die Ukraine auch in Deutschland zu einem Sinneswandel geführt hat,
der allerdings mutmaßlich nicht sehr tiefgreifend ist.
Die grundsätzliche Skepsis gegenüber dem Militär in großen Teilen jener sich
selbst als Zivilgesellschaft verstehenden Bevölkerungsschicht bleibt bestehen.
Nun richtet sich so eine Rekrutierungsaktion aber weniger an die paar urbanen
Nachdenklichkeits-Twitterati als vielmehr an jene vielen,
unter denen dann hoffentlich immerhin einige bereit sind, für ungefähr 1900
Euro netto als Stabsgefreiter in einem sehr engen Panzer zu sitzen und das zum Beruf zu machen.
Auch wenn Putins Angriffskrieg etliche Milieus die Notwendigkeit der Bereithaltung
einer nicht zu billigen, nicht zu kleinen Armee verdeutlicht hat,
bleibt dennoch eine alte Weisheit wahr.
In aller Regel sind nicht die Wohlhabenderen, Gebildeteren und Leitartikler
beim Militär, sondern die anderen, allemal bei den Mannschafts- und Unteroffiziersdienstgraden.
Schon unter Königin Viktoria hieß es, poor men fight the rich man's war.
Und das werden wir ja, das haben wir ja alle schon gesehen und können uns das
ja genauso vorstellen. A.
Und Kister ist ja auch nicht Irmgard, er war ja lange Chefredakteur bei der
Süddeutschen und so weiter. Und jetzt wahrscheinlich nochmal aus,
ich weiß gar nicht, dem Altersruhestand hier geschrieben. Das war ihm wichtig.
Jedenfalls hat man diese Bundeswehr-Exclusives so auch Semper Talis, also immer bereit.
Hier werden wir uns auch mal den Trailer anhören. Wir sind exzellente Kämpfer.
Wir sind die 1. Repräsentanten der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Wenn Staatsgast kommt, sind die Jungs später die Ersten, die gesehen werden.
Arme schlafen ein, Güte schlafen ein. Abbrechen oder so ist nicht.
Wäre das was für dich, Stefan Wachbataillon?
Ist natürlich blöd, wenn man hier mit Erwartungen vollgepumpt wird und dann kommt man da hin und...
Nicht schön, glaub ich.
Auch kann man dann zum Beispiel an Choreografien teilnehmen.
Die Achtmannshow und dann natürlich noch Crème de la Crème, Viermannshow.
Morgen findet die Zertifizierung statt, kommt der Kommandeur morgen für die
Abnahme vorbei und segnet das Ganze ab und das ist dann auch die Choreografie,
die wir dann bei dem Prager Drillfest vorstellen werden.
Die Choreo für die Viermannsshow, genau auch für die Achtmannshow,
habe ich mit meinen Soldaten, die in der Viermannshow zusammen abgesprochen
und die Choreo hat sich dann so mit den Mannschaftssoldaten zusammengestellt.
Das sind die Besten der Besten der Besten. Da kommen Soldaten rein,
die mit dem Karabiner umgehen können, als würden die ganz normal Luft atmen. A.
Ja so ist das alles aufgemacht. B. Als würden die ganz normal Luft atmen.
A.
Relativ hohe Klickzahlen 400,
500, 600.000. Finde ich für einen Bundeswehrkanal nicht ganz schlecht.
Wird wahrscheinlich ordentlich beworben auch, damit diese Klickzahlen erreicht werden.
Aber wenn man sich ansieht, dass die Soldaten auch immer präsenter auf TikTok
werden, das hat ja auch mit dem Ukraine-Krieg zugenommen, ist das schon etwas,
was funktionieren kann in der Ansprache? Wir hören mal noch weiter.
Das wichtigste Bestandselement im Wachbataillon, den Karabiner K98.
Wenn jetzt ein Staatsgast kommt, dann wird dem quasi gezeigt mit dem Präsentiergriff,
dass die Waffe entladen ist und dass wir in friedlicher Absicht ihn begrüßen.
Also ich freue mich am meisten drauf, wenn wir den Karabiner kämpfen.
Darauf freue ich mich eigentlich schon seit ich bei der Bundeswehr bin,
dass ich den mal endlich in der Hand habe.
Aber werden jetzt hier junge Männer in die Irre geführt oder ist das einfach ein Gang mit der Zeit?
Ich glaube die werben jetzt halt so um ihre Person.
Das ist die Ansprache, wir sind ja auch Funk-Videos mit der Musik untermalt, so spricht man jetzt.
Ich meine, wir haben ja jetzt von der Bundeswehr gehört, dass sie sich um Geld
erst mal keine Sorgen machen muss. Das sind ja alles nur Orga-Fragen noch,
aber an Geld mangelt es nicht.
Und um also das Ziel, die Truppe um 20.000 Männer und Frauen zu verstärken und
am Ende werden es dann so 13.000.
Die Kraftanstrengung, der finanzielle Einsatz und dieser Halligalli waren immens.
Ich würde sagen, okay, findet statt. Früher habe ich das immer noch so mit Besorgnis,
wenn ich irgendwie so Gamification-mäßig an der Bushaltestelle oder in Nähe von Schulen.
Aber mittlerweile denke ich mir, junge Menschen, die auf den Arbeitsmarkt kommen,
werden ausreichend informiert und da sorgen sehr viele Kräfte dafür,
dass sie wirklich ihre Optionen jetzt kennenlernen, weil jeder um sie wirbt
und dann soll die Bundeswehr einfach alles, was sie hier mobilisieren kann,
irgendwie mit in den Ring werfen.
Geht, dass man so, also ich glaube es gibt die die Kampagne richtet sich an zwei Gruppen.
Die eine Gruppe ist die tatsächlich, die man erreichen kann,
die bereit ist, diesen Beruf zu wählen.
Und dann gibt es selbstredend ganz viele, die nicht dazu bereit sind,
aber jetzt plötzlich das Gutfinden, dass wir mehr fürs Militär ausgeben,
dass wir so eine Präsenz von Soldaten in der Öffentlichkeit haben.
Es fing ja schon an mit diesen kostenlosen Bahnfahrten für Soldaten,
aber nur, wenn sie die Uniform anhaben, was ja nicht sein müsste.
Also sie könnten sich auch ausweisen als Soldaten, aber nein,
sie müssen die Uniform tragen.
Und da geht es schon, wenn man es jetzt mal so auf lange Sicht betrachtet,
darum generell zu sagen, wir müssen auch mal wieder bereit sein.
Und jetzt braucht man so eine Armee von 200.000 Leuten, das ist so angestrebt.
Jetzt sind es gerade 183.000.
Und man weiß aber nie, ob man nicht auch mal dann irgendwann Leute einziehen
muss für andere Aufgaben nochmal.
Es nimmt ja auch durch den demografischen Wandel zu. Also wenn man sich das
ansieht, wie sehr wir schrumpfen, die jüngeren Leute, also die wieviel 18 bis
25 jährige man hat und haben wird, dann wird es ja nicht einfacher zu rekrutieren.
Und vielleicht hast du das mitbekommen, diesem Monat gab es ja einen Vorschlag,
nee Ende April gab es einen Vorschlag der FDP, wie man denn mehr Rekruten bekommt.
Ich zitiere aus dem Handelsblatt, die FDP fordert eine neue Personaloffensive für die Bundeswehr.
Unter anderem sollen auch Ausländer der Truppe beitreten können.
In Deutschland haben wir ein großes Potenzial junger Menschen ohne deutschen Pass,
die gern deutsche Staatsbürger werden würden und dafür auch etwas leisten möchten,
sagte der verteidigungspolitische Sprecher der FDP-Bundestagsfraktion Alexander
Müller dem Handelsblatt.
Und jetzt, man höre und staune, die CDU.
Und CSU findet das auch eine ganz gute Idee.
Also es soll dann so sein, dass man einen fünfjährigen Dienst ableistet und
dann bekommt eine Staatsbürgerschaft.
Wir machen das jetzt, also jedes Land macht jetzt sowas. Die einen dürfen aus
dem Gefängnis raus, die anderen bekommen eine Staatsbürgerschaft.
Irgendwie müssen wir das mit der postterrorischen Gesellschaft ja bewältigen
können. Bei der Unionsfraktion stoßen die Vorschläge auf Zustimmung.
Und zwar wird hier zitiert der verteidigungspolitische Sprecher Florian Hahn von der CSU.
Dass er das für eine gute Idee hält.
Das kann aber nur wirken, sagt er, wenn die FDP dafür sorgt,
dass die Ampel nicht wie geplant das Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht ohnehin lockert.
Denn klar, sonst gäbe es ja nicht mehr die Anreize, dann übers Militär an eine
Staatsbürgerschaft zu kommen.
Da sind wir jetzt angegangen. Wir haben ja schon häufiger festgestellt,
wenn es ums Militär geht, ist alles denkbar.
Dann können Schuldenbremsen keine Rolle mehr spielen.
Dann sind auch Staatsbürgerschaften plötzlich viel einfacher zugänglich.
Nur sonst geht gar nichts.
Aber es ist erstaunlich, dass dann trotzdem immer so wenig funktioniert,
wenn man dieses Beschaffungsamt und die Bürokratie hört und so.
Ja, gut, das ist dann auch mal.
Ich denke hier gerade, die CDU
mag es ja immer nicht, wenn die Staatsbürgerschaft verramscht wird. Ja.
Aber verramschen ist ja nur ein anderes Wort für, es gibt eine Gegenleistung,
also es wird dem ökonomischen Prinzipien, also dem Handel, so zu sagen verramscht,
der Preis ist zu billig, aber es gibt einen Preis, so ne? Ja.
Und das ist ja eigentlich die...
Würde ich sagen, paradigmatische Definitionen davon, etwas zu verramschen,
es nämlich zur Ware zu machen und zu sagen, fünf Jahre Lebenszeit gegen die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft.
Also wenn das nicht Verramschung ist, dann weiß ich nicht, was Verramschung ist.
Aber gut, wenn die konservativen Kräfte sich einig sind, dass das ein guter Weg ist.
Beim Militär ist alles ein bisschen anders. Wir springen jetzt mal zu dem Podcast Funkkreis. A.
Ist das von Funk? B.
Nein, das ist aber ein Podcast von der Bundeswehr und der informiert über verschiedene
Dinge. Da habe ich das auch mit den Muli's her, was ich eben erwähnt habe.
Und wir hören jetzt mal junge Leute, die bei der Bundeswehr sind.
Also wir gehen zu Funkkreis.
Neben Panzerschütze Wynn treffen wir aber auch die Frau Panzerschütze Semina.
Sie wollte Teil einer größeren Sache sein. Deswegen wollte ich erstmal was Besonderes
machen, sag ich jetzt einfach mal. Ich wollte unbedingt was im öffentlichen
Dienst machen und mit Menschen zusammenarbeiten.
In etwas arbeiten, was wichtig ist, was man auch später sagen kann,
ja, ich hab für was Wichtiges gearbeitet und man stolz drauf sein kann.
Ich hab das schon mal in einem anderen Podcast angemerkt, aber wenn nur einmal
der Bildungsminister so vor seinen Lehrern stünde, wie hier immer.
Ich gehöre dazu, man kümmert sich um mich, ich will was Wichtiges tun.
Die Politik flankiert das mit entsprechender Semantik. Es gibt Feierstunden,
es gibt Gelöbnis und so weiter.
Das finde ich immer, ist ja auch so eine Infantilisierung.
Also die Bundeswehrsoldaten werden nicht nur von der Politik aus,
wie also um die müssen wir uns kümmern als Politiker. Die können es nicht selber.
Das sind wie Drittklässler und die nehmen das dann selber in ihrer Sprache so auf.
Und komm da irgendwie hin, ich muss
mich jetzt erstmal, ich bin nicht mehr erwachsen, ich bin jetzt Soldatin.
Und dann übernehmen die einfach dieses Bild von, zum Glück kann ich hier mal
wieder beisteuern, uns wird geholfen, wir sind hier eingebettet,
dankenswerterweise. A.
Es ist ja auch traurig, dass wir so wenig Gesellschaft erfahren im positiven Sinne.
Du hast eben das wir kritisiert, aber wir würden ja schon sagen,
dass es tatsächlich eine gesellschaftliche Solidarität geben könnte,
die anders ausgeprägt ist.
Beispielsweise mal schaut, wie in den 80er Jahren in Großbritannien vor dem
großen Bruch den Zetscher verursacht hat, die Gewerkschaften,
Gemeinschaften hergestellt haben.
Das Vereinsleben, das ist ja alles nicht mehr da und dann ist klar,
dass das Team ist immer wieder etwas, was in diesen YouTube Videos,
wo wir jetzt eben nur kurz Ausschnitte gehört haben, immer wieder herausgestellt wird.
Ja, wo ist sonst das Team zu erleben? Und Infantilisierung stimmt auch in anderer Weise.
Immer mehr 17-Jährige sind jetzt bei der Bundeswehr.
Da gibt es auch eine Zahl, Bayerischer Rundfunk hat darüber berichtet, schon im März.
Minderjährige bei der Bundeswehr, weil die Mehrzahl der Staaten mittlerweile
das Rekrutierungsalter auf über 18 Jahre festlegt, in Deutschland aber auch
17-Jährige aufgenommen werden, läuft die Diskussion seit Jahren.
Aktuelle Zahlen von 2022 heizen die Debatte an. Bayern sticht im Bundesländervergleich
dabei besonders heraus. In den vergangenen fünf Jahren wurden im Freistaat jeweils
die meisten 17-Jährigen im Soldatenstatus eingestellt.
Das geht aus einer Antwort der Bundesregierung
auf eine kleine Anfrage der Linksfraktion im Bundestag hervor.
Die Unterschiede sind teilweise beträchtlich. So waren es in Bayern im vergangenen
Jahr insgesamt 460 Minderjährige.
Niedersachsen folgte mit 286 17-Jährigen. Und steht da irgendwie, wie das geht?
Also minderjährig kriegen die dann, müssen die das sich von ihren Eltern beglaubigen
lassen auf ihr Einverständnis oder?
Ja, kann ja nur so sein.
Im Arbeitsvertrag?
Kann ja nur so sein.
A. Sie dürfen nicht wählen, aber sie dürfen schon dienen. Das ist doch herrlich. B.
Mann, Mann, Mann.
Wie hat der Ukraine-Krieg oder hat er überhaupt eine Rolle gespielt jetzt für
diese jungen Bewerber? A.
Der Ukraine-Krieg hat die Entscheidung der beiden aber nicht beeinflusst.
B. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, war es für mich klar, dass jetzt auf europäischem
Boden Krieg ist, aber es war für mich nicht explizit ein Grund,
mich verpflichten zu lassen.
Obwohl ich jetzt natürlich im Klaren sein muss, dass man jetzt als Soldat möglicherweise
im Ernstfall dann auch dort einspringen müsste.
Aber trotzdem war es bei mir nicht so, dass ich dann gesagt habe,
Ukraine-Krieg, ich bin jetzt sofort bei der Bundeswehr.
Ich sehe das genau wie mein Kamerad, also es war jetzt auch nicht wirklich der
ausschlaggebende Punkt hier hinzugehen, sondern halt, weil man es machen möchte
und klar man hat es im Hinterkopf.
Man weiß auch, was auf einen zukommen würde, wenn es im Ernstfall dazu kommen könnte.
Aber insbeziehend dieser Grund, deswegen jetzt hier hinzugehen, nicht.
Aber weiß man das wirklich, was auf einen zukommt? Also ist das eine Dimension,
die man sich bewusst machen kann?
Wenn ja, dann sollte man nochmal ganz genau fragen, ob es das dann wert ist.
Also ich möchte jetzt hier nicht, dass das so verstanden wird,
dass ich hier gegen Soldaten rede.
Ich würde nur sagen, wenn er in meinem Bekanntenkreis, also ich kenne auch im
entfernteren Bekanntenkreis zwei Soldaten,
aber wenn in meinem bekannten Freundeskreis jemand zum Militär gehen würde,
dann würde ich versuchen, mit allen guten Argumenten, die mir zur Verfügung
stehen, davon abzuraten.
Also ich bin ein bisschen verwundert, wie die beiden darüber reden und dass
sie ihm da einfach beipflichtet, denn der Ukraine Krieg kann doch gar kein Anlass sein.
Die deutschen Soldaten haben im Ukraine Krieg nichts verloren.
Ansonsten wäre es ja ein deutscher Krieg. Also das ist ja diese völkerrechtliche
rote Linie, dass wir zwar die Ukrainer darin unterstützen können diesen Krieg
zu führen mit Material, aber auf gar keinen Fall mit Menschen.
Keine europäischen NATO-Soldaten, also keine NATO-Soldaten, keine anderen Soldaten
außer die Ukrainer dürfen da kämpfen.
Wenn man dieses Containment dieses Krieges sozusagen ernst nimmt,
wenn man es nicht ernst nimmt, redet man dann so wie die darüber.
Das ist so, ja ich stelle mich da schon drauf ein, also das überrascht mich ein bisschen.
Wir hören jetzt einen Oberstabsfeldwebel.
Den Soldaten ist bewusst, dass wir seit dem 24.02.letzten,
Jahres Krieg in Europa haben. Durch das junge Alter der Soldaten ist ihnen,
glaube ich, noch nicht bewusst in den ersten Monaten, was so ein Krieg für Auswirkungen
auf Soldaten haben kann.
Durch meine Ausbilder, und da spreche ich über die lebensälteren,
also meine Company-Truppführer und auch meine Zugführer, die in Zügen in dem
Szenario LVBV ausgebildet wurden,
kann das vermittelt werden, aber die allgemeine Grundausbildung schafft ja genau
den Abholpunkt der Einzelschütze mit dem Gewehr in der äußersten Konsequenz.
Und aus meiner persönlichen Bewertung, das sind auch meine eigenen Erfahrungen,
die ich im Einsatz gemacht habe, wenn der erste Schuss bricht,
ob in Afghanistan oder wo auch immer, verfällt man in das gleiche Muster,
wir hier den Soldaten vermitteln.
Selbst- und Kameradenhilfe, Überblick
behalten, das Chaos beherrschen und gegebenenfalls zurückzuschießen.
Na gut, das ist natürlich die Kameradschaftssoziologie. Man stirbt nicht für
sein Vaterland, sondern nur für seinen Kameraden und so.
Das kommt immer wieder bei diesem Podcast. Ich habe so ein paar Folgen noch
gehört, auch von einem Mali-Einsatz, Bombenentschärfung.
Es ist immer das Team. Und erst einmal kann man ja festhalten,
es gibt offenbar eine Sehnsucht, nicht als Einzelner nur durch die Welt zu gehen.
Dieser Hyperindividualismus birgt ja Probleme.
Und deshalb könnte man aber doch eher mal darüber nachdenken,
wie könnte man denn sonst ein solidarisches Miteinander organisieren?
Also zum Beispiel mit Vereinen. Ich werde immer mal wieder gefragt,
jetzt so bei Vorträgen, wenn es um Ungleichheit oder generell um Politisches
geht, was denn zu tun ist oder was wäre denn jetzt eine dinke Strategie?
Und dann habe ich früher immer so sehr holistische Antworten gegeben,
inklusive globaler Wandel und was weiß ich. Und jetzt sage ich vielleicht einfach
mal Sportverein Kunden.
Ich bin jetzt nicht da der Ansprechpartner für, aber das hat andere Gründe.
Aber ich glaube, dass das gerade so als eine politisch sinnvolle Tat,
das ist was eigentlich ganz nahe liegt, aber vielen gar nicht in den Sinn kommt.
Ich würde das leicht upgraden. Man muss keinen neuen Verein gründen,
aber sich einem anschließen.
Oder einem anschließen, ja.
Und dann auch den kleinen Schritt wagen, einen Vereinsvorstandsposten zu übernehmen.
Bin ja zum Beispiel auch zweiter Vorsitzender eines Schwimmvereins.
Was bedeutet, man hat dann so ein paar Aufgaben. Ich lege es mir auch schon
mal zurecht, wenn dann der Bundestag beschlossen hat, ja, diese Soldaten müssen
jetzt in den Krieg. Und dann, okay, dann dauert es noch drei Monate,
bis wir neue Soldaten brauchen.
Sage ich nicht, kann ich. Bin zweiter Vorsitzender eines Stadtteilvereins.
Ich kann leider nicht in den Krieg gehen. Ich hoffe, das zählt dann auch.
Wir werden schauen.
Aber das bringt einen auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen. Also das ist auf jeden
Fall sehr gemeinschaftsstiftend, würde ich sagen. Das empfehle ich auch sehr.
Nochmal Funkkreis.
Auch bei Panzerschütze Serminia gab es Unterstützung. Also bei meinen Eltern
war es so, meine Mutter war sehr davon überzeugt, dass ich das unbedingt machen
soll, weil sie immer schon gesagt hat, so was ist genau dein Ding.
Sie hat auch gesagt, im Ernstfall, jetzt auch wegen der Ukraine,
weißt du was auf dich zukommt und ich weiß ja, dass du das halt trotzdem schaffst
und auch immer weiter gesagt, das wird gut.
Also ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen, die reden da so leichtfertig über diesen Ukraine-Krieg.
Die dürfen im Ukraine-Krieg nicht eingesetzt werden. Es sei denn es ist dritter
Weltkrieg. Ja. Also die sind nun wirklich besonders davor geschützt.
Aber offenbar ist das jetzt schon so, dass ich meine, dass die Bundeswehr nimmt das ja ab.
Das ist ja nicht irgendein Journalist, der denen mal das Mikro unter die Nase gehalten hat.
Das ist ein offizieller Bundeswehr-Podcast, wo jetzt einfach schon mal so gesagt
wird, naja, und die Ukraine, aber die Eltern haben auch gesagt, du schaffst das schon.
Was ist denn das für eine Aussage, ja? In der Ukraine, das sind hunderttausende,
sind da jetzt gestorben, metzeln sich da nieder und da kann man ja nicht einfach
sagen, du schaffst das schon. ist ja nicht eine Frage von bisschen Cleverness.
Wer übersteht das Dschungelcamp?
Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt so eine Nachrichtenlage hätte wie bei dem einen
Typen aus der Schweiz, das ist schon kritisch, weil die dürfen ja wirklich nicht da mitkämpfen.
Aber dann heißt es schon, ja, da gibt es so ein paar Schweizer,
okay und so. So ein paar deutsche Söldner, ja, ist irgendwie aufgebrochen und wollte da mitkämpfen.
Wenn irgendwann die Nachrichtenlage kommt, ein Bundeswehrsoldat hat sich auf
den Weg gemacht. Also dann ist schon, das lesen dann auch die Russen.
In der Hinsicht vielleicht...
War ja jetzt bei Lanz ein, nicht ein Bundeswehr, Also ein ehemaliger,
der ja dann als Söldner dann dort und dafür jetzt laufend genau das Bundeswehr ist aber so auch irre.
Aber sobald die Nachrichtenlage ist ein aktiver Bundeswehrsoldat ist dort in der Ukraine.
Vielleicht ist die Bundeswehr sogar ein besonderer Safe Space,
weil du bist so lange sicher davor dort mitkämpfen zu müssen bis wirklich die
Hütte brennt und wir einen Weltkrieg haben. Also die NATO direkt in diesen Krieg eingreift.
Ja.
Und davon sind wir ja...
Auch wenn wir vorhin davor gewarnt haben, hoffentlich weit entfernt und es wird niemals dazu kommen.
Aber die darüber reden, finde ich echt ein bisschen spooky. Also die haben ja
gar keine politische Dimension von dem, was sie da tun.
Und dass das dann auch so von der Bundeswehr veröffentlicht wird.
Da wird es ja sieben Stellen geben, die das noch abnehmen. Da geht ja nichts
einfach mal so raus bei der Bundeswehr.
Was wollen die uns eigentlich vermitteln da? Ja, sehr eigenartig.
Wir hören uns jetzt einen Clip an, den ich erstmal nicht ankündige.
Advertisement ist wie ein Fahrzeug und seine Kleidung. Arbeiten wir an Jobs,
die wir nicht mögen, damit wir Scheiße kaufen können, die wir nicht brauchen.
Wir sind die mittleren Kinder der Geschichte, Mann. Kein Ziel, kein Ort.
Wir haben keinen großen Krieg. Keine große Depression.
Unser großer Krieg ist ein spiritueller Krieg. How great the pressure!
Das war Brad Pitt in Fight Club und er hält dort in diesem Fight Club diese
Ansprache. Wir haben keinen großen Krieg.
Die große Depression ist unser Leben. Ich sehe Männer, wie sie Tische abwaschen,
wie sie im Service arbeiten und er sieht da die Männer versauern.
Und dann wissen wir, was geschieht. Dann werden diese Fight Clubs gegründet.
Dann wird sich wieder auf die Fresse gehauen und dann wird wieder Sinn gestiftet.
Der Film ist aber dann klüger als die Ansprache von Brad Pitt hier,
denn er hinterfragt ja das dann auch noch mal.
Jedenfalls glaube ich, dass dieser Film und gerade diese Ansprache,
die ja auch längst überall viral laufend geht, bei allen Business-Coachs und weiß ich nicht wem,
dass das schon etwas ist, was hier zum Ausdruck kommt,
was möglicherweise jetzt auch für vielen Anreiz sein kann, dann doch zum Militär
zu gehen, weil man etwas haben will, was zählt, wie es in dem Bundeswehr-Slogan
heißt. Etwas, was Sinn ergibt.
Die sagen meistens ja dann Sinn macht.
Oder was dann auch, ja, dem Leben eine Tragik wiedergibt, weil man ja sonst
nur Konsument ist. Und zunächst einmal zeigt sich das ja schon so darin,
dass wir so eine Lust am Survival haben.
Und interessant ist, dass sich jetzt mehr und mehr Survival- und Bundeswehr-Militär-Rekrutierung
so vermischt. Da gibt es beispielsweise dann Soldaten, die inzwischen als Influencer agieren.
Der Otto Walletproof ist da
ein Beispiel, sehr hohe Reichweiten und da hören wir auch mal kurz rein.
Herzlich willkommen zu diesem Video. Ihr habt euch ja alle ein bisschen mehr
Outdoor-Content gewünscht oder Survival-Content.
Und den möchte ich euch bringen, heute mit dem Video, 5 Lebensmittel,
die ich aus der Natur oder Dinge, die ich essen kann, gewinnen kann,
wenn ich einfach so unterwegs bin und nichts zu essen dabei habe.
Nichts, wo ich irgendwie sagen muss, da kann ich jetzt wochenlang überleben,
aber etwas, was mir einfach über einen Tag hilft. Auf geht's zu diesem Video.
Ja, wir sehen dann hier diesen Panzer und sehen sehr viel militärisches Gerät.
Was suchen wir? Wir suchen nach Birken. Birken kennen alle von euch,
aber vor allem nur auf Grund dessen, dass man damit gut Feuer machen kann,
weil da ätherische Öle drin sind, gerade in der Birkenrinde.
Aber Birke hat auch eine ganz ganz tolle Wachstumsschicht, sprich zwischen dem
wirklich harten Holz und außen der Rinde ist eine dicke, dicke Schicht,
die ich quasi essen kann. Die kann ich mir wie Mehl mahlen, da könnte ich mit
denen schon mit Eiern und tatsächlich sogar ein Brot mitbauen, bauen, backen.
Schmeckt dann alles nach Erdbeere. Deswegen ist das Erdbeeraroma immer aus Birke gewonnen.
Wirklich? Hier ist ja ganz witzig, dass die sagen wir mal die Bundeswehr,
die ja diese Art von so Milieu irgendwie aufgreift. Ja, wir haben es ja bei den Preppern.
Es ist immer despektierlich, wenn nicht alle unter Prepper, das sind auch Naturfreunde
und so. Aber schon diese Frage, die er sich ja stellt, was kann ich mir eigentlich essen.
Zielt ja eigentlich darauf ab zu sagen, was kann ich hier essen,
wenn mich sonst niemand versorgt? Wenn ich als hochindividualistisch der letzte
Überlebende, I'm Legend und so weiter im Wald bin.
Wenn die dann angeworben werden, nach zehn Jahren bei YouTube sich individualisieren
und im Wald ganz alleine die Nächte durchschlagen und dann heißt es plötzlich,
na du isst mal genau das hier aus dieser Tüte.
Dann sind sie nämlich in diesem sozialen Gefühl gebunden, es wäre plötzlich
drin und diese ganze Prepper-Ideologie war sozusagen nichts wert.
Nur weil alle grün angezogen sind. Also hier treffen sich wirklich zwei ganz
unterschiedliche Spektren.
Aber auch die Bundeswehr hat eine eigene Serie jetzt, Survival bei YouTube und
da klingt es nicht viel anders.
Soldatinnen und Soldaten auf dem sogenannten Siri-Training beim Kommando Schnelle
Einsatzkräfte Sanitätsdienst Ostfriesland.
Hier erlernen sie Techniken, die ihnen in Notsituationen auf sich allein gestellt helfen können.
Wie mache ich Feuer? Wie baue ich mir ein Versteck?
Wie gewinne ich Wasser, wenn die Vorräte zu Neige gehen?
Highlight für die Teilnehmer dabei, eigene Fische fangen und zubereiten.
Letztendlich lerne ich hier, da kriege ich die Skills beigebracht,
wenn ich im Rahmen einer Operation versprengt werde und von meinen Kräften getrennt
bin, um mich letztendlich durchschlagen zu können und letztendlich auch zu überleben.
Vorbereitungen für den Ernstfall überall und wir hören jetzt noch mal Otto Ballett-Proof,
der im Interview ist mit jemandem von der Bundeswehr. Also es geht jetzt nicht
um die Bundeswehr direkt, es geht um Plakus.
Das ist so ein Unternehmen, das diese Einstellungstests-Vorbereitungen macht.
Und da wird man jetzt ein bisschen aufgeklärt, wenn man denn zur Bundeswehr
will, was verdient man dort?
Dann haben wir den zweiten Punkt, das Thema Gehalt.
Also steigst du im Endeffekt, wenn du in die Ausbildung gehst,
über ein Studium gehst, steigst du mit über 2000 Euro ein.
Das findest du nirgendwo in der Privatwirtschaft. Also du hast eine Ausbildung,
da hast du vielleicht 700, 800 Euro, ... ... mit denen du einsteigst in der Privatwirtschaft.
Im Studium musst du dir wahrscheinlich selbst irgendwie finanzieren,
... ... musst dir wahrscheinlich noch einen Nebenjob suchen.
So und da bietet im Endeffekt die Bundeswehr schon irgendwo eine Stabilität,
... ... also eine gewisse Selbstständigkeit, in die man einsteigt,
... ... wo man schon von Grund auf viel selbstständiger ist,
... ... was den finanziellen Aspekt angeht.
Ja, selbstständig finanziell, aber sehr eingeschränkt in der individuellen Freiheit,
du hast es eben beschrieben. Worum geht es noch?
Ja, und dann hast du natürlich noch den fünften Punkt, das Thema Anerkennung.
War vor einigen Jahren vielleicht noch nicht so, aber jetzt durch die ganzen
Krisenherde auf der Welt spielt das ganze Thema nochmal in der Gesellschaft eine ganz andere Rolle.
Rolle und ist für mich jetzt beispielsweise, wäre jetzt auch ein großer Punkt,
um zu sagen, okay, ich gehe zur Bundeswehr, das wird im Endeffekt auch von der
Gesellschaft auch anerkannt, dieser Beruf. Man tut auch der Gesellschaft was Gutes.
Das merken wir uns. Thema Anerkennung. Die Bundeswehr muss sich ja nicht mehr verstecken.
Man ist stolz, dass wir Soldaten hat. Also das ist dieser Diskurs.
Und das ist etwas, was wir in anderen Ländern auch sehen werden. Kommen wir gleich zu.
Jetzt noch ganz kurz. Es gibt also bei TikTok auch sehr viele Soldaten oder
generell Videos, die sich mit Militär beschäftigen, die ja auch diese ganzen
Strategien zum Ukraine-Krieg aufdröseln.
Und so gibt es auch Soldatenwissen. Das ist ein recht erfolgreicher Kanal.
Da heißt es dann zum Beispiel Tag 8-39 Du lernst deine Ausrüstung besser kennen
und wie man ein Zwei-Mann-Zelt baut und sich richtig im Gelände bewegt.
Die Sandausbildung wird auch ein Thema sein für Selbst- und Kameradenhilfe.
Tag 40-57 Jetzt wird's ernst. Du lernst deine Waffe besser kennen und den sicheren Umgang damit.
Erst der Schießsimulator, dann der Scharfeschuss. Tag 58-70 Jetzt geht's endlich
ins Biwak, wo du lernst Stellungen zu bauen und diese auch zu verteidigen.
Mit Streifendienst, Alarmposten und Feuerwache. Tag 71-80 Die Wachausbildung.
Du lernst alles über deine Befugnisse als Wach- und Sicherungssoldat.
Dazu gehört zum Beispiel die Überprüfung von Fahrzeugen und Personen.
Ganz wichtig, in welcher Situation darfst und musst du hocheskalieren.
Tag 87 bis 90, hier steht die Rekrutenbesichtigung im Mittelpunkt.
Das ist eine praktische Abschlussprüfung, wo nochmal getestet wird,
was du die letzten Monate gelernt hast. Nachdem das vorbei ist,
kommt das feierliche Gelöbnis. Hierzu kannst du auch Freunde und Familie einladen,
um dich zu feiern. Tag 91, du bist auf dem Weg in deine Stammeinheit,
wo du für deine spätere Verwendung ausgebildet wirst. ausgebildet wirst.
Wann und wo startest du deine Grundausbildung?
Nun, wir werden hier direkt,
angesprochen und es geht aber auch humorvoll zu.
Damit die Patronen aufgesammelt werden können. Wie wurde dir damals aufs Genommen?
Kasernenhumor auf TikTok, wir springen nach Polen.
Angesichts des russischen Überfalls
auf die Ukraine will Polen seine Verteidigungsanstrengungen verstärken.
Das Land gibt in diesem Jahr vier Prozent seiner Wirtschaftsleistung für Verteidigung
aus, doppelt so viel wie von der NATO vorgeschrieben.
Außerdem wirbt die polnische Armee gezielt um Nachwuchs. An diesem Wochenende
finden in 16 Städten Messen statt, die sich vor allem an junge Menschen richten.
Anfassen, ausprobieren. Paweł Góra ist beeindruckt.
Er ist Englischlehrer, hat drei Kinder. Die Armee interessierte ihn früher wenig.
Das hat sich seit dem Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine geändert.
Sollte es jemals zu einer Eskalation kommen, bei der der Feind an unsere Tore
klopft, würde ich an der Seite der anderen Männer unseres Landes stehen wollen
wenn nötig, verteidigen.
Das mag pathetisch klingen, aber so ist es nun mal.
Das war ein Tagesschau-Bericht. Wir hören auch noch den 2. Teil und können das
jetzt mal ein bisschen sozioökonomisch einordnen.
Innerhalb der kommenden Jahre soll sich die Anzahl der Soldatinnen und Soldaten
fast verdoppeln auf 300.000.
Das wäre dann eine der personenstärksten Armeen in Europa. Zum Vergleich,
Deutschland hat nur 183.000 Soldaten.
In Polen ist man zufrieden mit der Kampagne.
Wir sind Ende letzten Jahres davon ausgegangen, dass wir 15.000 Kandidaten für
den freiwilligen Grundwehrdienst rekrutieren können.
Wir wurden positiv überrascht. Mehr als 16.000 haben sich gemeldet.
Und dieses Interesse wächst ständig. Nicht nur bei den Männern,
sondern auch bei den Frauen.
Rekordinflation und drohende Rezession, die spürt auch Kamil Rogacki.
Der 18-jährige Schüler will schon lange zur Armee.
Polen verteidigen im Ernstfall, ja, aber er findet auch die gute Bezahlung attraktiv.
Ja, aber was ist das Szenario? Das ist wirklich ein bisschen unklar.
In Deutschland ist es ja Landesverteidigung. Da haben wir schon drüber gesprochen.
Wenn hier Deutschland verteidigt werden muss, dann bitte richtig mit den Waffen, die wir haben.
Oder der Teilhabeoption. Wozu Atomwaffen, wenn die nicht als Droh macht, dann auch nicht.
Entsprechend genutzt werden, also als Drohmacht genutzt werden.
Als Drohmacht genutzt werden, ja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir den Russen, den Russen in Anführungszeichen einschüchtern,
indem wir jetzt Mobilisierungsfraktionen zeigen.
Naja, stell dir ein Szenario vor, jetzt ich denke auch,
dass wir jetzt nicht nur von der Ukraine sprechen müssen, aber stell dir ein
Szenario vor, bei dem man sagt, also wir haben jetzt Bundeswehrsoldaten in Mali
und das soll jetzt noch ein Jahr so gehen, die werden jetzt so nach und nach da abgezogen.
Und da hat es ja auch in dem Sinne nix gebracht.
Aber es ist ja gut möglich, dass man auf irgendwelchen Atollen im sogenannten
südchinesischen Meer plötzlich auch sagt, da müssen wir mal hin oder man muss da und dorthin.
Also ich halte es für durchaus möglich,
so wie jetzt momentan alle ticken, dass man nicht nur hin und wieder mal ein
Schiff irgendwo hinsendet und dann winken die mal den Chinesen,
sondern möglicherweise geht man da auch noch in andere Konflikte rein.
Ich glaube, dass man schon jetzt gerade Wege sucht. Man sieht das ja auch an,
wie man Atom, also diese diese kleinen Atomwaffen, die nicht gleich Hiroshima
bedeuten, wie man die einsetzen kann.
Ich glaube, es geht schon darum, dass man weiterhin Krieg führen kann.
Und das geht dann über Mensch und Muli.
Und wie da weitere Konflikte möglicherweise entstehen oder dann auch zurechtgebraut
werden, das ist schon vielleicht etwas, dass der Einsatz möglich ist.
Also das glaube ich nicht, dass jetzt Afghanistan eine Ausnahme war.
Und ich möchte mir nicht vorstellen, dass wir jetzt Soldaten,
also klar, dann sind wir im dritten Weltkrieg, wenn wir jetzt in Russland Soldaten
einmarschieren lassen.
Aber dass es da noch andere Konflikte gibt, gerade wenn man das mit China sich
ansieht oder was da in Afrika, wenn da China mehr Begehrlichkeiten plötzlich
hat, als es dem Westen lieb ist.
Also das ist mir Ich würde jedem abraten, sich jetzt gerade bei der Bundeswehr
zu bewerben, da gab es auch mal gemütlichere Zeiten.
Vor allem nicht unter dieser Maxime, hier kannst du dein Land verteidigen und
gerade jetzt in Zeiten des Krieges in Europa, sondern nee, dann musst du mit
dem Gehalt zufrieden sein.
Und dann wird Deutschland aber am Hindu-Kurs verteidigt und nachträglich heißt
es dann, naja, eigentlich haben wir da nur hegemoniale Interessen für andere
noch durchgedrückt und es hat dann irgendwie nicht funktioniert.
Als man noch zurücktreten musste, wenn man sowas sagte, das hat Herr Köhler
gesagt, heute überhaupt kein Problem. Ist das Doktrin von von der Leyen.
Strukturen von Kunden von alleine musste man damals noch zurücktreten.
Die British Army hat schon Recruitment Werbespots 2019 gemacht,
die ganz in dieser Fight Club Logik aufgehen.
Also wir hatten jetzt hier in Polen die soziale Lage, drängt natürlich Leute dahin.
Das kann ja in Deutschland auch nochmal zunehmen. Die Perspektiven für Azubis
sind wahnsinnig schlecht, wie wir wissen.
Also wer als Auszubildender beginnt, bekommt wahnsinnig wenig Geld und dann
kann die Bundeswehr natürlich da leicht attraktiver werden, wie das da bei Otto
Bulletproof schon ausgeführt wurde.
Aber diese Sache, ich brauche mal was sinnstiftendes, dass diese Fight Club
Logik, die haben wir schon bei der britischen Armee 2019 erleben können.
Wir hören hier auch mal einen Spot.
Wir sehen jetzt hier eine junge Frau, die mit dem Einkaufswagen hin und her
fährt, die an der Kasse sitzt.
Draußen läuft jemand den Bogen auf, wir sind im Supermarkt und zugleich wird
das dazwischen geschnitten werden.
Bilder aus einem Einsatz mit einem Helikopter.
Resilienz.
Sie wird auch nicht kriminiert, sie ist P.U.C.
Und wird von ihren Kollegen nicht ernst genommen und dann gibt es aber die Möglichkeit
wirkliche Anerkennung zu finden und wirklich für etwas zu kämpfen.
Und das ist dann die Bundeswehr, das britische Militär, das sogar durchs Feuer
geht, wie wir hier sehen.
Your army needs you, ist der Slogan.
Also, du wirst aus deinem Land, du wirst aus deinem Land exkludiert,
indem du gar nicht als inkludiert wirst.
Ja, du bist da schlecht bezahlt und wirst diskriminiert.
Und deswegen solltest du für dieses Land jetzt in die Armee gehen.
Weil dieses Land dich, ja, das war ja die Carlo Marsala Logik,
dass er, das sind die Premium Patrioten oder so ähnlich hat er sich ausgedrückt,
oder die Premium Deutschen, So hat er sich ausgedrückt.
Das sind die Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund, denen die Mehrheitsgesellschaft
nicht anerkennt, dass sie auch zu diesem Land gehören.
Aber wenn diese von der Mehrheitsgesellschaft Diskriminierten dann zur Armee
gehen und dann bereit sind, sich für dieses Land, das sie gar nicht richtig
akzeptiert, zu opfern, dann sind das für Carlo Massala Premium-Deutsche.
Und hier geht es um die Premium Briten, werden schlecht bezahlt,
bekommen von der Regierung nur Knüppel in den Weg gelegt, aber wenn sie dahin
gehen, wo sie hingehören, find where you belong, search army jobs,
dann ist alles in Ordnung. Wir sehen uns noch einen zweiten Clip an.
Jetzt sind wir hier in einer Bar, es geht jetzt um U-Boote. Dann sehen wir U-Boote.
Ich habe auf Kitt trainiert, die nicht offiziell existiert hat.
Ich habe Missionen erledigt, die nie passiert sind.
Und ich bin in Orte, die man nicht auf einem Map findet.
Weil ich ging, wo ich nicht ging.
Ich habe Tage verbracht, die ich nicht gemacht habe.
Eine Nacht mit Leuten, mit denen ich noch nie war. Das war ein Kumpel.
So, jetzt geht er unter die Kasse.
I was born in Teesside, but that's about as much as I can tell you.
In Teesside wurde er geboren, also nichts, hat kein bedeutsames Leben geführt,
ist kein bedeutsamer Mensch, aber jetzt ist er zum U-Boot-Bataillon oder wie man das nennt,
gegangen, hat dort jetzt sich seine Meriten verdient und kehrt dann in seine
Heimat zurück und wird jetzt in dieser Kneipe, wo sich erst keiner für interessiert
hat, freudig empfangen als Held.
Ja, der Clip geht natürlich nur im James Bond Land, wo man mit der Verlockung,
es ist alles geheim, aber du wirst es erleben, wovon niemand erzählen darf.
Ja, das ist natürlich gut. Bei dem vorigen Clip denke ich mir,
wenn sie ehrlich wären, würden sie einfach sagen, der Krieg ist der große Gleichmacher.
Es ist egal, wie viel Geld du hast, wie viel Familie und so weiter.
Wenn Krieg ist, ist Krieg.
Aber du könntest noch jemand mit einer Waffe in der Hand sein,
während der Krieg alle gleich macht.
Und das würde, glaube ich, einige triggern, die dann sagen, ah ja,
so, okay, gut, dann habe ich eine kleine Vormachtstellung, wenn es hart auf hart kommt.
A. Kleiner Aufstieg. Es ist sehr besorgniserregend,
dass man jetzt diese Logik doch immer häufiger vorfindet und ich glaube,
dass die sozialen Medien da auch einiges zu tun werden, dass wir sicherlich
jetzt nicht unendlich viele Rekruten bekommen, aber dass sich so eine Militarisierung
der Gesellschaft einstellt.
Das haben wir schon erlebt, welche Influencer inzwischen bei der Sicherheitskonferenz
so rumspringen und dass es doch eine sehr, sehr positive Zeichnung gibt.
Ich glaube Otto Ballett-Proof war auch bei OMR.
Also das wandelt sich schon gerade.
Otto Ballett-Proof. Nun gut, nicht nur beim Militär werden Menschen gebraucht,
sondern auch in der Pflege. Klingt nach einem trockenen Thema.
Ich will nur zwei Clips dazu spielen. Sie haben mich wirklich aus den Socken
schießen lassen. Das ist unfassbar.
Der Deutschlandfunk hat eine Tageszusammenfassung zum Thema neues Pflegegesetz
und so weiter. Es gibt ja jetzt mehr finanzielle Unterstützung für Pflege im privaten Raum.
Und wir wissen ja, sehr viel Pflege findet im privaten Raum statt.
Denn wir haben zwar bei der Gesundheitsversorgung eine Vollversicherung.
Also wir sind einfach alle Gesundheitsversicherer. Das ist ja auch soweit Pflicht.
Dann gehen wir zum Arzt und müssen dort eigentlich keine Zusatzleistung machen.
Also wir nehmen so eine IGL-Leistung, von der jetzt wieder gesagt wurde,
neue Studien belegen gar keine Art Sinn.
Nicht mal diese Krebsvorsorgen, die nicht im Katalog stehen,
sondern zusätzlich gemacht werden können.
Ist das so, ja?
Sind alle Quatsch. Sie haben nicht eine IGL-Leistung gefunden und irgendwie
54 untersucht. Na, die IGL ist die Abkürzung für...
I Gesundheitsleistung irgendwas. Das ist das, was die Ärzte noch anbieten dürfen.
Aber nur gegen Barzahlung der
Kassenpatienten. Und dann stehen da immer so Werbeschilder oder Sonstiges.
Wir machen hier die und jene Vorsorgeuntersuchung oder hier mal einen Sporttauglichkeitstest,
wie auch immer. Aber keine davon war sinnvoll, sondern das ist dann nur,
wenn wir den Patienten schon da haben, können wir noch mal ein paar Euro verdienen.
Nun gut, wir haben das bei der Pflege ja nicht, sondern wir bezahlen zwar einen
Pflegebeitrag, Aber der muss am Ende auch beantragt und so weiter.
Es gibt Förderungsgründe.
Man wird nicht einfach ein Pflegefall, also offiziell eingestuft in einen Pflegegrad
und dann wird automatisch bezahlt, sondern es muss alles organisiert werden.
Und wenn man es stationär macht, dann sind das hohe, hohe, hohe Zuzahlungen.
Wird sich das irgendwann mal ändern? Na mal sehen. Wir hören hier Heike Behrens
von der SPD, die zum neuen Pflegegesetz dazu redet im Deutschlandfunk. Das war der Tag vom 26.
Wir haben mit dem Gesetz, das wir heute beschlossen haben, vereinbart,
dass noch vor der Sommerpause ein Expertengremium die Arbeit aufnehmen soll,
um Vorschläge zu machen, wie ein solcher Schritt umgesetzt werden kann.
Das heißt dann ja tatsächlich auch ein grundsätzlicher Wandel in dieser Versicherung.
Also dann würde es nicht mehr um Zuschüsse gehen, sondern dann würde wirklich
jede Leistung abgedeckt.
Und ja, nochmal die Frage, wie kann sowas kommen?
Ja, ob das wirklich in genau diesem Workload kommen wird, muss man mal sehen.
Erst mal brauchen wir eine solche Expertengruppe, die im Grunde ein solches Konzept erarbeitet.
So, man konnte sich also gerade mal durchringend zu sagen, na gut,
wir beauftragen mal eine Expertenkommission, die uns ein Volkpflegesystem,
was soll denn das kosten und so weiter, durchrechnet.
Aber eigentlich hört man hier schon, sie ist skeptisch, das wird man mal sehen,
braucht man das überhaupt? Pflege funktioniert doch in Deutschland,
will sie uns irgendwie sagen.
Und unter dieser Maxime, dass wir jetzt die ganze Zeit die Bundeswehr und die
British Army und so thematisiert haben,
die ja sehr hart an solchen Semantiken arbeiten, warum sollte man da hier Zusammenhalt,
Kameradschaft, selber im Urwald irgendwie über die Runden kommen,
wenn man versprengt wird und naja, das machen, was zählt.
Wir wissen, das ist verlogen, das ist auch nicht sehr schwer zu kommunizieren oder zu argumentieren.
Genauso verlogen ist das, was Heike Behrens hier über die private Pflege in Deutschland sagt.
Wir hören uns das eine Minute 45 Sekunden an. Ich konnte es gar nicht glauben,
denn wir wissen, wie die Realität aussieht.
Familien, denen eigentlich das Wasser bis zum Halse steht. Sie haben eigentlich
gerade noch die Kinder im Haus. Plötzlich werden die Eltern zum Pflegefall.
Der Sohn will es nicht machen, also muss die Schwiegertochter ran.
Sie kennt den Vater gar nicht, den sie da pflegt. Der ist aber dement,
ist die ganze Zeit auch so ein bisschen unnahbar.
Und wenn dann auch körperlich gewalttätig. Alles ist super stressig, super bescheuert.
Und jetzt kommt Heike Behrens und sagt, ist doch alles nicht so schlimm.
Das heißt aber auch, sie setzen weiterhin darauf, dass die Angehörigen die Hauptarbeit machen.
Ich weiß nicht, politisch setzen wir nicht darauf, sondern ich glaube,
es ist so, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, in der Menschen noch füreinander einstehen.
Also wir haben, wenn ich mich erinnere, vor 30 Jahren, vor 20 Jahren wurde diskutiert,
das wird in Zukunft alles so nicht mehr sein, die Angehörigen können das nicht mehr leisten.
Heute haben wir eine völlig andere Situation. Es sind sehr viel mehr Menschen,
die tatsächlich die häusliche Versorgung mit unterstützen, als wir das immer angenommen haben.
Wir haben ja heute den höchsten Anteil an häuslicher Versorgung, den wir je hatten.
Das sind schon an die 80 Prozent derjenigen, die einen Pflegebedarf haben,
werden zu Hause versorgt. Das hängt einfach auch damit zusammen,
dass die Menschen gerne zu Hause bleiben möchten und dass sie nicht gerne nochmal
den Wohnort wechseln wollen.
Und offensichtlich gibt es aber eben nicht nur die Bereitschaft,
sondern auch den Willen dazu, Angehörige, die auf Pflege angewiesen sind, zu unterstützen.
Und das, finde ich, sollten wir fördern. Dafür sollte eine solche Pflegeversicherung auch da sein.
Dann diejenigen, die eine solche Verantwortung übernehmen und die eben Menschen
in einer solchen Lebensphase begleiten und unterstützen, denen sollten wir das leicht machen.
Denen sollten wir helfen und sie eben auch an den Stellen entlasten,
wo es möglich ist. Ich denke, das ist eine Aufgabe für uns als Gesellschaft.
Das ist Ausdruck von Solidarität und ich glaube tatsächlich auch ein Stück Ausdruck von Nächstenliebe.
Sagt Heike Behrens, SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete und für ihre Partei Obfrau im
Gesundheitsausschuss des Deutschen Bundestages.
Also, wir haben ein Pflegesystem, das darauf hinausläuft, dass in Deutschland ungefähr 400.000...
Polnische Frauen und noch ein paar hunderttausend andere Arbeiten,
die von Familien irgendwie so schwarz beschäftigt werden, die dann so mindestens,
zumindest mal für drei, vier Monate im Jahr,
die Familie entlasten, Und jetzt kommt Heike Behrens und sagt, ja.
Es hat sogar noch zugenommen. Das machen immer mehr Leute, weil die das so gern machen.
Sonst würden sie es ja nicht machen. Und dann denke ich so, naja,
eigentlich gibt's da auch ganz schön viele und ich würde mal so Zehntausende,
Hunderttausende in Deutschland, die eigentlich nur auf so einen Tod warten,
weil das auch so ein erlösendes Ding dann irgendwie ist. Also es ist ja wirklich sehr düster.
Eines der größten Tabus überhaupt in Deutschland. Man hat ja auch gesehen bei
Corona, ja, man macht halt so ein Pflegeheim einfach mal zu,
die Angehörigen dürfen nicht hin. Und dann steht man im Bundestag und sagt,
also das war jetzt wirklich das dunkelste, dunkelste Kapitel der letzten Jahrzehnte
in Deutschland, hat absolut recht damit.
Und was so in den privaten Pflegen stattfindet, ist nun wirklich noch mal schlimmer.
Und ja, klar, es gibt natürlich viele, die wie bei der Kindererziehung auch
ihre Kinder einfach lieben und das alles durch.
Bei Kindern ist es immer so eine Aufbaugeschichte, so eine Abbaugeschichte privat
zu managen, wo du echt nur auf so einen Tod wartest.
Das ist wirklich wahnsinnig schwer. Und wir wissen, wie das bei den Kindern
thematisiert wurde, als es dann irgendwie die hieß, ja, Kindertagesbetreuung
wäre schon ganz gut und dann die Bayern so, nein, seid ihr verrückt,
wir müssen doch die Familie und dann gab es so die Herdprämie und hier der ganze Kram und so weiter.
Aber eigentlich pflegt man nicht mal seine Kinder gerne, also im Sinne von dem
Pflegebegriff zu übernehmen, sondern, nee, man geht gerne seinem eigenen Leben
nach und es reicht ja, wenn die Kinder nach Feierabend nach Hause kommen und
einen schönen Tag hatten unter Kindern.
So, und man aus sehr vielen wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten weiß,
man nählt das eigentlich auch ganz gut. Wir müssen ja nicht so die Familie überfordern.
Jetzt überfordern wir die Familie bei der Pflege der Alten einmal komplett.
Legen ganze Volkswirtschaften lahm, zum Beispiel mit Argumentationen wie,
ja sehr viele Frauen arbeiten ja Teilzeit, die könnten ja aufstocken auf Vollzeit.
Und dann denke ich so, ja wer macht denn die Pflege, die dann auch zu Hause
stattfindet, bei 25 Prozent über 65 und so in Deutschland.
Naja, und Heike Behrends, die machen das alle aus Nächstenliebe,
das funktioniert super und umso mehr machen, umso mehr zeigt das halt nur,
dass sie es gerne machen.
Das fand ich wirklich erschütternd.
Es ist auch aus einer volkswirtschaftlichen Argumentation heraus sehr,
sehr eigenartig, denn es ist ja klar, dass wo die Pflege professionalisiert
wird, mehr Leute gepflegt werden können.
So ist es ja so, dass immer nur eine Person eine andere Person pflegt. Genau, eins zu eins.
Das will man ja gerade bei der Kindererziehung nicht.
Deswegen gibt es ja Kindergarten zum Beispiel oder so etwas,
dass nicht einer für einen immer nur da ist, eins zu eins, sondern dass man
eine Person hat, die für zehn oder zwanzig Leute da ist, je nachdem.
Und dann müsste man dafür sorgen, dass das ein sehr fairer Verteilungsschlüssel ist.
Das war ja das große Thema der Pflegestreiks und das ist ja auch sehr zu begrüßen,
wenn sich das da verbessert.
Und ja, es wird natürlich auch Leute geben, die gern zu Hause fliegen und die
das können und das auch mental leisten können und auch ökonomisch sich dann
leisten können, dass sie dann weniger arbeiten und das dann machen.
Aber die Not bei vielen Leuten ist groß.
Hinzu kommt ja auch, dass wahrscheinlich sehr bald so knapp die Betten sein
werden für zum Beispiel Menschen, die dann in Seniorenheim müssen.
Ich hatte mit einem SPD-Politiker, der da auch in so einem Vorstand sitzt,
aus NRW gesprochen, also unserem Vorstand für ein Pflegeheim, der sagt dann auch.
Also in sieben, acht Jahren. Da fehlen eigentlich in so einer mittelgroßen NRW-Stadt
sieben, acht, neun große, große Seniorenheime.
Die werden nicht gebaut. Jetzt durch Zinslast ist das für viele Investoren uninteressant.
Man muss schon fast Angst haben, dass die einem nicht irgendwann den Schlüssel
in die Hand geben und sagen, man betreibt es jetzt selbst. Das lohnt sich für
uns nicht mehr. Die Rendite, die wir uns einst erwartet haben,
kommt jetzt nicht mehr aufgrund von Krise und Energiekosten und dann Zinswende.
Das ist ein ganz großes Problem. So kann man jetzt den Leuten noch mal zurufen,
gell, ihr macht das doch gern, aber das Problem verschwindet dadurch nicht.
Ja, das Problem ist so riesig, so gigantisch und Deutschland ist hier in so
einer Pionieraufgabe, dass wir uns nirgendwo abgucken können,
sondern eigentlich ganz viel auch Forschung dazu brauchen. Ich habe in der alten
Republik diese ganzen Forschungsvorhaben.
In Deutschland gibt es keine Pflegeforschung nennenswert.
Aber es gibt doch Pflege auch als Unistudiengang. Das wundert mich.
Ja, Pflege wird jetzt... Ja, als Studiengang, das wäre natürlich ein echter
Fortschritt. Wir sind ja erst mal dazu übergegangen zu sagen,
die Ausbildung zur Pflege kostet denjenigen, der die Ausbildung macht, nichts mehr.
Aber es gibt schon dann eine Akademisierungswelle.
Ja, aber nicht in dem Ausmaß, dass du jetzt... Genau. Es gibt Pflegestudien,
es gibt Pflegeforschung, es gibt diese Akademisierung auch der Ausbildung.
Aber es gibt keine Pflegeforschung, die für das Ausmaß, für das wir uns jetzt
da vorbereiten müssen, für die nächsten 20, 25, 30 Jahre, da irgendwie nennenswert ist.
Also da sind alle europäischen Länder, selbst die, von denen man es mal wieder
gar nicht glaubt, schon allein, weil das sind noch die Armhäuser Europas,
selbst die unternehmen da irgendwelche Anstrengungen.
Wir sind in Deutschland einfach so richtig blind. Und wir sehen das ja hier
an der Behrendt, die kann das einfach so im Deutschlandfunk sagen.
Ohne dass ein Journalist glaubt,
er könnte da jetzt einfach widersprechen, ohne noch groß erst mal selber Aufklärung
und so betreiben zu müssen, weil wir einfach ein, wie schon häufig von mir gesagt,
demografisch wirklich sehr unaufgeklärtes Land sind.
Das macht einem wirklich Angst, weil man dann, wenn es dann zu Katastrophe kommt,
man dann weiß, dass das da nicht mehr zu retten ist.
Und ja, dann werden da viele einfach nicht ordentlich gepflegt sein und werden
dann so dahinvegetieren und sterben.
Sag mir noch mal kurz, du hattest mir einen Link geschickt, ich hatte es aber
jetzt vergessen mitzubringen.
Das können wir hier mal gut hinbekommen. Das Thema Obdachlosigkeit in Kanada,
das war ja was ganz schockierendes.
Patrick Barnas hat einen Text geteilt von der National Post,
also einer kanadischen Zeitung.
Und ich lese mal einfach, wir können ungefähr uns erahnen, was Patrick Barnas
dazu getwittert hat, aber ich lese mal von Diebel übersetzt den entscheidenden Abschnitt vor.
Einer der umstritternden Aspekte der Sterbehilfe war eine Reihe von öffentlichkeitswirksamen
Fällen, in denen sich schwerkranke Kanadier erst für den Tod entschieden,
nachdem sie jahrelang keine angemessene medizinische Versorgung erhalten hatten.
Die Umfrage von ResearchCO ergab, dass eine knappe Mehrheit der Befragten auch
damit einverstanden war.
51% befürworteten die Unfähigkeit zur medizinischen Behandlung als ausreichenden
Grund für einen assistierten Tod.
Das heißt, du gehst als auch dann als sterbenskrank,
unheilbar krank, was dich zur Sterbehilfe qualifiziert, wenn es zwar eigentlich
medizinische Hilfe gibt, aber du sie dir aus finanziellen Gründen nicht leisten kannst.
Und das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich.
Ja. Für uns hier noch Zukunftsmusik, aber das können wir uns auch schon mal
in Erinnerung Also da vor solchen Szenarien habe ich große Angst.
In Silent Green ist das ja alles schon
mal durchexerziert worden in dem Science-Fiction-Film Ende der 70er Jahre.
Und wir nähern uns der Science-Fiction immer mehr an. mal mehr an.
Ja, es ist wirklich gruselig.
Wenden wir uns mal der künstlichen Intelligenz zu, wenn du nichts dagegen hast.
Gerne.
Gut.
Du bist immer noch gehypt?
Ich bin immer noch wahnsinnig gehypt. Okay. Und wir werden auch im Salon noch
den ein oder anderen Text lesen.
Ich habe es befürchtet.
Naja, wir wollen ja auf der Bühne dann GPT-frei sozusagen uns den menschlichen Tiefen widmen.
Wir bleiben GPT-frei beim Live-Salon.
Genau. Zum einen, und das als Einstieg ins Thema, Mike Elgin macht hier mal
einen Vorschlag, wie man so einen großen Blick auf, na ja, jetzt gibt's GPT. GPT heißt Chat-GPT.
Es steht also irgendwie der Chat, also der Text, der geschriebene und so weiter
hin und her im Mittelpunkt.
Und GPT kann ja viel lesen und kann viel Text generieren. Also steht jetzt der
Text für alle im Mittelpunkt. Wir fragen uns, ja, was bedeutet das jetzt,
wenn jetzt die Maschine mehr, besseren, wie auch immer, was für eine qualitativen
Art von Text liefern kann?
Und er macht einen historischen Vergleich mit der Erfindung der Fotografie und
was es für die Malerei bedeutete.
Und Landschaften von Orten, die weit entfernt sind von dem Ort,
an dem man jemals hingehen würde. Und man würde es anschauen und sagen,
wow, das ist es, was es dort so ist. Das ist unglaublich.
Und so haben wir das Malen als eine Art, um zu beurteilen, was wirklich da war.
Sobald wir Fotos hatten, die wirklich beurteilen konnten, was wirklich da war,
dann plötzlich explodierte das Malen in 1.000 Stile von Surrealismus und all
die verschiedenen Dinge, die wir wirklich lieben.
Es hat Menschen wirklich freigelassen, super kreativ zu sein und Dinge tun,
was Menschen tun können, die Kameras nicht tun können. Also müssen wir nicht
mehr die Klischees schreiben, Die AI wird das tun und wir können etwas originaleres machen.
Sagen wir mal, das ist ein vulgär historischer Blick auf die Tatsache,
dass, ja, wenn wir heute in so ein Schloss gehen, irgendwie in eine Burg,
dann hängen da vor allem Porträts, Herrscherporträts, weil man wollte sich abbilden,
also hat man sich einen Maler geholt, sich irgendwie in die Pose gebracht.
Was war dann doch auch ein bisschen mehr als Abbildung?
Ja klar, es gibt da die, ich würde auch sagen, diese ganzen Erzählungen von
Reisen, da gibt es ja auch am Rhein, im Rheintal einige Schlösser,
die so ein paar Teppiche zeigen, wo dann plötzlich der sechsbeinige Löwe,
von dem man berichtet hat und so, das ganze Seemannsgarn einmal abgebildet wurde.
Aber die Beobachtung würde ich sagen, nehmen wir jetzt mal heuristisch auf.
Erst mit der Fotografie wurde die Malerei so weit befreit, dass man sich so
ein, keine Ahnung, dadaistisches, kubistisches Bild anschauen konnte und dachte,
na, mal gucken, was da so dahinter steckt.
Ich mach mir mal ein paar Gedanken, weil hätte ich ein Foto erwartet,
hätte ich mir eine Fotografie angeschaut, so ungefähr.
Hätte ich was naturalistisches erwartet und jetzt ist ja die
frage wenn jetzt niemand mehr weiß ein anschreiben für die bewerbung eine rede
ein brief eine e-mail wenn jetzt alles assistiert geschrieben wird können wir
dann nicht auch den text einfach mal befreien alles ermöglichen dass man jetzt
mal wild die buchstaben durcheinanderwirbelt und sagt neue poesie
Naja, experimentelle Lyrik hat es ja in Deutschland auch schon viel gegeben.
Aber unter so einer Maßgabe jetzt erst recht. Warum nicht in der Schule? Warum nicht überall?
Man sieht einen echten Text und denkt, ja, den hat ein Computer geschrieben.
Wäre ja Quatsch, wenn ein Mensch dafür seine Kreativität opfert.
Aber Kurt Schwitters, wo du jetzt eben den Dadaismus angesprochen hast,
hat das ja auch gemacht, schon in 20er Jahren.
Ja, aber was wäre jetzt für uns jedermann? Könnten wir nicht demnächst...
Ja, ich meine, du stehst jetzt so auf Gmail, schreibst eine E-Mail und dann
ploppt da unten auf, ah, ich verstehe, was du schreiben willst anhand des Betreffs,
den du schon ausgefüllt hast, soll ich dir die E-Mail formulieren?
Und man denkt sich so, ja, dann kommt natürlich ein sauberer Text raus.
Genauso gut könnte man jetzt überlegen, keine Ahnung, wir haben jetzt Emoji-Tastaturen
und so weiter, brauche ich überhaupt noch Worte? Können wir nicht jetzt alle
mal ein bisschen mehr damit spielen? Vielleicht also noch Prompts schicken?
Wer es ausformuliert haben will, krückt halt selber auf, formulieren wir das
mal aus und sowas. Also dass man jetzt mal in alle Richtungen für alle Mann
sagt, okay, Sprache, Sprache, Sprache wird jetzt mal neu gedacht.
Nun wurde ja Sprache neu gedacht. Du hast es ja schon genannt.
In Deutschland gibt es viele Beispiele, in Amerika ja auch. Es war ja ganz besonders,
dass bei der Biden-Amtseinführung ein Gedicht vorgetragen wurde,
das am Ende die größte Aufmerksamkeit, würde ich mal so sagen,
von Amanda Gorman, genau, weltweit gemacht hat.
Und ausgerechnet jetzt, wo auch noch obendrein der nächste amerikanische Präsidentschaftskandidat,
nämlich Ron DeSantis, ja antritt, gibt es in Florida Folgendes zu vermelden,
auch mit ein bisschen als Lieblingsthema von Carys Wisher, weil sie da auch
immer versucht zu warnen.
Ich möchte mit etwas anfangen, das mir sehr verängstigt, und das ist eines der
vielen Dinge, was ich von Ron DeSantis sprechen kann, dass die Schüler der Florida
Elementary School die Poeme, die Amanda Gorman an der Inauguration des Präsidenten
Bidens gelesen hat, nicht mehr lesen können.
Es war eine wunderschöne Poeme. Die Schule hat die Poeme nach einem einzigen
Befragung von einem einzigen Elternteil beschlossen.
Der Elternbefragung, die Poeme sind nicht wissenschaftlich und beinhalten,
und zwar indirekte Hassgespräche, während sie den Autor Oprah Winfrey missverstehen.
So, eine Person hat ein Gedicht geschrieben und vorgetragen,
also Amanda Gorman, das haben dann Millionen Leute gehört.
Auf der Gegenseite gibt es einzelne Eltern, die dann sagen, das bitte nicht im Lehrplan.
Das bitte da raus aus der Bibliothek, das sollten meine Schüler nicht lesen.
Was nur wieder dazu führt, dass es dann im Podcast thematisiert wird,
woraufhin sich Carol Swisher denkt, na ja, dann spiele ich es jetzt einfach.
Und sie spielt den Auszug von der Originalaufnahme bei der Amtseinführung,
der jetzt für Furore sorgt, weil ein Elternteil, ich nehme an,
ein Vater, der Einspruch einlegte, dem sofort stattgegeben wurde.
Sie spielt also das Beispiel und beschreibt danach nochmal das Phänomen,
das jetzt gerade zu beobachten ist.
Somehow we do it, somehow we've weathered and witnessed a nation that isn't broken.
Und was war jetzt die Argumentation, was es in der Passage anstößt?
Ja, wahrscheinlich dieses Amerika ist eine fortlaufende Geschichte.
Status quo gibt's nicht, sondern wir sehen uns nur.
Im Werben.
Genau. Vorher, nachher, Erwartungen, Erfahrungen.
Was eigentlich einfach logisch ist.
Was irgendwie super logisch ist, aber jetzt ist es halt so interessant.
Wir haben auf der einen Seite, sagen wir mal, elf Leute, die bei Open AI sitzen
und maßgeblich die Technologie vorantreiben und veröffentlichen.
Und auf der anderen Seite elf
Leute, die für die Mehrheit aller Buchzensierungen verantwortlich sind,
weil die immer diese, also sie nennen das dann Serial Complaint Filers,
also die einfach die Beschwerden abschicken und dann wird dem sofort stattgegeben
und dann werden diese Texte aussortiert.
Also wir haben so eine Flut von Textgenerierungen und diese Kunst soll jetzt
langsam aussortiert werden,
was ich super interessant finde, weil mein Verlag Hoffmann & Kampe,
die verlegen ja in Deutschland Amendagormen, die haben uns das Programm für
den Herbst geschickt und das habe ich vorher noch nie so gesehen,
aber es gibt eine extra Beilage nur für sie,
also nur für das deutsche Ding, mehrere Seiten lang, sonst ist das ja einfach
nur ein Durchklappern der Bücher, jedes Buch eine Seite und hier gibt es einfach
noch mal eine extra Beilage von ihr, also da kann man auch mal sehen,
wie unterschiedlich mittlerweile die menschliche Sprache hier so ernst und wahrgenommen wird.
Sollten wir das nicht als eine große Chance begreifen, wenn die Rechten jetzt
wieder zensieren, denn das ist ja staatlich dann durchgesetzt und diese aufständischen
Eltern und das ist alles zu wurg.
Wenn wir die jetzt gerade erleben.
Dann können wir doch jetzt wieder etwas drehen. Ich muss einen Schritt zurück machen.
Es war ja so, dass mit 68, aber auch schon Avantgarde-Künstler davor,
man von, sagen wir, progressiver Seite aus immer gegen Zensur gekämpft hat.
Dann gab es die fröhlichen Neunziger, auch noch die fröhlichen Nullerjahre und
plötzlich drehte sich so ein bisschen etwas,
dass also die Linken warnten vor diesem und jenen und das nicht und sollte man
nicht mal lieber die Werke dieses Künstlers nicht mehr ausstellen,
all diese Kräfte, die es da gab und die es auch nach wie vor gibt.
Denn ich bin nicht derjenige, der wie die linksliberalen Mantra artig wiederholt,
es gibt keine Cancel Culture.
Doch, doch, es gibt schon Cancel Culture. Die Frage ist nur,
ob diese gecancelten dann noch ein anderes Publikum finden.
Und das kann schon gut sein, da man ja andere Distributionswege hat.
Aber sollte man nicht jetzt, wo die Rechten wieder ganz klar als Zensoren auftreten,
also so wie man sie aus den 50er, 60er, 70ern kennt,
Sollte man da nicht sagen, so ab sofort, wir machen jetzt nichts mehr hier mit Zensur,
jetzt nicht mehr irgendwas die ganze Zeit, das und das geht nicht und wir streichen
nochmal irgendwelche Worte aus Roald Dahls Büchern raus, weil er da ein bisschen
diskriminierend über irgendwelche dicken Kinder oder so geschrieben hat.
Sondern wir lassen alles, wir lassen uns davon gar nicht beirren,
wenn uns danach ist irgendwas nicht mehr besonders zu protegieren, kann man es ja machen.
Niemand ist gezwungen in eine Wagner-Oper zu gehen, genauso ist man nicht gezwungen
irgendwelche Songs von weiß ich nicht wem zu hören. und.
Jetzt wieder sagen, nein, wir kämpfen wieder für die Freiheit der Kunst,
kämpfen also jetzt, wenn überhaupt dieser Kulturkampf stattfindet,
immer nur mit dem, die wollen unsere Freiheit einschränken.
Also jetzt gar nicht mehr einlassen auf die Sache, aber jetzt müssen wir auch
mal hier nochmal gucken, wer noch alles raus muss, wer schon mal vor 30 Jahren
irgendwas Böses gesagt hat.
Sondern jetzt einfach wieder sagen Werk und Auto trennen wir sowieso und wir
setzen uns für die Freiheit der Kunst ein, auch wenn es uns weh tut.
Nämlich genau das machen ja die Rechten nicht.
Die wollen ja nur Freiheit der Kunst und Grenzüberschreitung da haben,
wo es den Linken weh tut. Aber sobald dann nur Amanda Gorman irgendwie so eine
fast Binsenweisheit vorträgt, dass eine Nation im Werden ist und nicht vollständig
und abgeschlossen und Status quo.
Aber die Methode ist natürlich entscheidend.
Ja, ja, dass dann sofort die steil gehen.
Deswegen, wir sollten also das als eine herzliche Einladung betrachten, was DeSantis und Co.
Machen und Tilman Kuban, der sich aufregt, wenn irgendwo eine,
was war das, eine Track Queen hat irgendwo aus einem Kinderbuch vorgelesen oder
so ein Unsinn, dass das dann, also, nee, das finde ich nicht Unsinn,
dass die daraus vorliest, aber dass man sich darüber empört, das ist Unsinn, so.
Sobald also so etwas geschieht, kann man immer als Akteur der Freiheit auftreten
und das gilt aber dann auch bei den anderen Sachen. Also dann auch bitte nicht
diese komischen Aktionen.
Ich kann nicht in diesem Kino, weil da auch schon mal ein Roman Polanski Film
gezeigt wurde, einen Vortrag halten oder so.
Also diesen Unfug dann auch lassen.
Den linken Kulturkampf jetzt einfach nicht mehr betreiben,
um diese Angriffsfläche nicht mehr zu bieten und dann kann man als großer Freiheitskämpfer
wieder in Erscheinung treten und dann wird man am Ende auch eine Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung auf seiner Seite haben,
denn das ist ja ein bevormundender Akt und Bevormundung wird eigentlich nicht gern gesehen.
Ich bin dafür ein großes Plädoyer gegen diese Missionierungen,
wenn jemand für sich entscheidet, ich gehe irgendwo nicht hin,
soll er es machen, aber dann keine großen Missionierungen.
Ja gut, ich entscheide mich auch für viel, wo ich nicht hingehe, ja natürlich.
Ja gut, ähm, Künstliche Intelligenz damit als Thema hier gesetzt.
Es gab diese Kongressanhörung von Sam Altman, einer Vertreterin von...
IBM und eines Professors. Bevor wir uns die ein bisschen im Original anhören,
es wurden durchaus ein paar Punkte angesprochen, die sehr interessant sind im
Vergleich zu diesen bisherigen Social-Media-Anhörungen, die wir hörten,
denn der Paradigmenwechsel ist ja doch da.
Hören wir drumherum. Zum einen Casey Newton und Kevin Ruse weisen in ihrem Podcast
Hard Fork, der hier wieder empfohlen ist, mal auf diesen eigentlich viel zu
offensichtlichen Umstand hin.
Congress is paying full attention to this and I think that's a good thing.
Yeah, you know, social media had existed for 10 or 15 years before the first
congressional hearings, where Mark Zuckerberg and other CEOs were called to testify.
Chatty P.D. came out last November and we're already having congressional hearings
about it. This thing is moving so quickly.
Ja, ich würde sagen, okay, das ist gut. Chatty P.D. ist zwar erst seit November
da, Aber es gibt andere künstliche Intelligenz-Sachen, die man auch schon mal
ein paar Jahre und so weiter, also ich würde nicht sagen, wir sind jetzt am
Null, ja, Null, aber, nun gut, bei Social Media hat es alles ein bisschen länger gedauert.
Nun haben aber diese Social-Media-Anhörungen, auch wenn sie erst zehn Jahre
nach dem Facebook-Start, ist ja das dann auch schon wieder zehn Jahre her,
also man kann auch auf Geschichte zurückblicken und sagen, na ja,
viel gebracht hat es nicht.
Amerika hat bis heute kein Privacy-Law, Sondern das ist alles nur kreuz und
quer argumentiert oder über Richtersprüche herbeigeredet.
Klar, manche Sachen wie Roe vs. Wade tragen dann jahrzehntelang und so.
Aber es ist eben nicht wirklich in der Verfassung oder im Gesetzestext festgeschrieben
und damit immer auch unter einer Revidierungsgefahr.
Außerdem droht nicht auch, dass die Leute von OpenAI und so weiter jetzt einfach
gesehen haben, wie die den Kongress bespielen müssen.
Also man guckt sich einfach an, wie Mark Zuckerberg und Eric Schmidt und so
sich da geschlagen haben über die Jahrzehnte und denkt sich so seinen Teil und
lernt einfach, weil wenn man ein was weiß, dann wie bei Open AI,
die ein Wissen darüber haben, wie man etwas lernt.
Die haben es ja immerhin der Maschine beigebracht. Scott Galloway zählt mal.
Lass mich raten, die treten jetzt viel kooperativer auf als ein Mark Zuckerberg.
Lassen wir uns, bevor wir uns das im Original uns anhören von Scott Galloway einschätzen.
Er zählt nochmal seine Erfahrung mit den oder seine Seherfahrung,
seine Rezeptionen mit den Silicon Valley Chefs bisher Social Media auf.
Let's play a game. Who said this? Wir brauchen eine aktive Rolle für Regierung und Regulierung.
Oktober 2020. Mark Zuckerberg oder Sheryl Sandberg. Ok, sie hat gesagt,
Sandberg ruft auf Regulierung der Regierung. Das war im Juni 2019.
Google-CEO Sundar Pichai. Unternehmen wie unsere können nicht nur erforderlich
neue Technologien bauen und
die Marktkräfte entscheiden, wie sie benutzt werden. Das war im Juni 2020.
Twitter-CEO Dorsey. Ich denke, Regulierung ist eine gute Sache.
April 2019. CEO Nick Clegg.
Vieles wurde in den letzten Tagen über Facebook gesagt, aber da ist etwas,
worauf wir einig sind. Congress should pass new internet regulations.
That's October of 20... Snap Spiegel, our guy.
We definitely support thoughtful regulation. That was in May of 2022.
Like, look, I... That is up to Congress not to pass it.
Der Kongress ist schuld, keine Gesetze zu machen. Nee, diese Leute haben vom
Kongress so gesprochen, wir wünschen uns Regulierung, und dann haben sie ihre
Lobbyisten losgeschickt und wir haben das alles torpediert.
Also hier fand Sabotage statt.
Es gab Regulierungen, so wie sie es wollten.
Genau, also das ist dann ein regular catcher.
Es gibt ja keine Nichtregulierung, auch eine große Liberalität für die Silicon
Valley Unternehmen verlangt ja, dass es eine Regulierung in diese Richtung gab.
Genau, und die hat man dann genutzt, um sich die Märkte abzuschotten,
den Nachwuchs, die Emporkömmlinge vor so hohe Hürden zu stellen,
dass am Ende nur die Großen da Bestand hatten.
Scott Galloway fasst seine, sagen wir mal, das eine Jahrzehnt Silicon Valley
Leute vom Kongress zusammen.
Wenn du ein netter, weißer Kind bist, der in der Technologie arbeitet,
wenn du vor dem Kongress stehst, sind die ersten drei Male wirklich nett zu dir.
Gott, ich habe wirklich PTSD von diesem Bullshit. Oder es war Marissa Mayer,
die vor Senator John Kerry sprach über Google.
Und er sagt, die Seattle Post Intelligence ist in etwa zwei Jahren aus dem Geschäft
gegangen, weil ihr klassifiziertes Geschäft weg ist. Und sie meinte,
naja, es ist früh, Herr Senator. Ich meine, wir sind schon hier.
Er hat postromantische Belastungsstörungen davon, die Leute im Kongress zu sehen,
wie sie sagen, es ist alles noch ganz früh, von mir aus Regulierung und so, so, so.
Naja, das droht also wieder und jetzt geht er nochmal ans Eingemachte,
das sollten wir auch im Hinterkopf behalten.
Social Media hat den Menschen vorgegaukelt, enger zueinander zu rücken,
dabei sind sie einfach nur in Beziehungen mit ihrem Bildschirm eingegangen.
So richtig tragfähig war das nicht.
Naja, man hat ja immer noch mit Menschen gechattet, während Dirk Becker damals
in meinem Buch schon 2016 so die These aufstellte, nee, ja, auf der anderen
Seite reagiert ein Mensch, aber eigentlich kommuniziert man mit der Maschine.
Und wenn jetzt künstliche Intelligenz kommt und man weiß, dahinter ist ja gar
kein anderer Mensch und die Maschine macht es mir trotzdem unterhaltsam,
was bedeutet denn das eigentlich?
Wir sind immer mehr und mehr von einander gequetscht. I mean literally the movie Her is playing out.
Wir haben ja in Snapchat das schon eingebaut, also in der Kommunikationsliste
mit den Freunden ist ganz oben angepinnt der AI-Bot, der immer antwortet.
Und nachts warst du auf, hast Langeweile, kannst mit dem chatten.
Nun gut, Scott Galloway. Und jetzt finde ich es auch interessant,
dass wir in diesem Zeitalter sind.
Man kann ja auch mal die Frage stellen, neben feministischen Strömungen und
einer Kritik am Patriarchat,
Gibt es ja vielleicht auch noch andere Phänomene,
die dazu hinführen, dass wir jetzt ja in unseren Beziehungen,
in den erotischen Beziehungen, andere Diskussionen haben, beziehungsweise es
herrscht da eine ganz große Konfusion oft.
Also wie geht man jetzt eigentlich miteinander um, was ist Zwang,
was ist Freiwilligkeit und so weiter.
Und tatsächlich ist es ja auch so, dass durch diese extreme Entfremdung von
den Mitmenschen, die stattfindet durch die Geräte, man in gewisser Weise auch
verlernt, wie geht man eigentlich um miteinander.
Und vielleicht ist sogar so ein Thema, wie wird im öffentlichen Raum mit so
etwas wie stillen Momenten umgegangen, man verhustet sie.
Auch eben eine Frage, wenn man tatsächlich das Mit-der-Gesellschaft-Leben immer
mehr verlernt und das über die Bildschirme regelt und mit Geräten spricht statt mit Menschen,
plötzlich, wenn Menschen aufeinander treffen, miteinander flirten sollen oder
ein Konzert genießen sollen, dies nicht mehr anständig hinbekommen?
Ja, auch beim Daten gibt's ja neuer Dings, Zumindest formulieren es einige so
aus, diese Art von, also zum einen Situationship, hast du bestimmt auch schon gehört, ne?
Situationship?
Ja, während man in einer Situation gemeinsam steckt, verhält man sich wie ein
Paar, aber wenn der andere abwesend ist, halt nicht.
So. Also man verabredet sich, für den Moment ist man dann auch in einer richtigen
Pärchenbeziehung, aber darüber hinaus halt nicht. Also das ist eine neue Sonderbarkeit,
weil man dann auch so eine gewisse Parallelisierung in einem großstädtischen Milieu hinbekommt. Ja.
Und das andere Phänomen ist ja, dass zwischen chatten und daten noch talken
ist, als einzelne Kaskade.
Gerade auf dem Schulhof. Alle Schüler hängen aufeinander, aber dann doch in ihrer eigenen Clique.
In Japan gibt es zum Beispiel auch immer nur, man geht nur als Gruppe aus.
Also dass man zu zweit, müsste man,
also das ist dann schon so kurz vor Liebespaar eigentlich, überhaupt zu zweit
Menschen zu treffen und nicht in so einer Gruppe unterzugehen,
wo jeder für sich im Smartphone drin hängt, weil man keine direkte Verantwortung
für jemanden hat. Weil da kann sich ja jemand anders drum kümmern.
Also es geht drunter und drüber. Und Scott Galloway berichtet.
Ich treffe mich ja lieber eigentlich zu zweit. Also jetzt manchmal hat man eine große Gruppe.
Ja da müsst ihr die einander ausgeliefert haben. Aber eigentlich finde ich es
schöner, wenn ich in Städten bin, wo ich mehrere Freunde und Bekannte habe,
dann mache ich das nicht so, dass ich die alle zusammen karre,
sondern vielleicht ist das dann mein Situation-Ship oder was auch immer.
Ich finde es besser, im Zwei-Stunden-Takt die zu treffen, aber dann immer intensiv
zu zweit. Also immer als Privat-Audienz, wenn ich es so päpstlich sagen darf.
Ja, man kann das ja soziologisch oder mehr so sozialwissenschaftlich,
akademisch, mathematisch irgendwie runterbrechen.
Zu zweit ist es ein Dialog. Zu dritt sind es schon drei Dialoge, aber nacheinander.
Also man kann sich bei einem Dreiergespann schon ein bisschen rausangeln Und
bei vieren ist es noch mal leichter,
bei fünfen kann man schon eine Viertelstunde schweigen, ohne dass jemandem auffällt
und das entspannt zum Beispiel die Japaner sehr, weil sie dann einfach mit sich
mit dem Handy beschäftigen können und so, die dann auch zu fünft die Straße
entlang laufen und einfach schweigen.
Jeder macht das so und deswegen trifft man da nie jemanden einzeln an, um jemanden zu treffen.
Um ein Date zu bitten oder so, also erst mal chatten, dann talken,
dann daten und so, also es ist alles sehr kompliziert.
Man entfernt sich so langsam voneinander und Scott Galloway berichtet hier aus eigener Erfahrung,
ich finde das besonders witzig, weil wir, umso mehr wir dieses ganze Künstliche Intelligenz,
also Social Media sowieso, aber Künstliche Intelligenz-Zeug jetzt auch,
Umso mehr werden ja solche Formate wie ein Podcast oder dann doch mal ein Telefonat
und ein Chat mit jemanden echt Bekannten oder sogar engem Bekannten und so herausgehoben aus dieser,
also wir sind jetzt hier wirklich so im, das ist personal Media,
also hier wird sich AI nicht einmischen und wie auch immer.
Und umso interessanter ist, wie jetzt in solchen Podcasts, die natürlich,
wie unser ja auch, vor großem Publikum abgehört werden.
Aber am Ende hört man es ja doch so als Einerbeziehung und ist so alleine mit
den Hosts, was ja nochmal mehr,
keine Ahnung, Sensibilität für private Anekdoten und so weiter eröffnet.
Und Scott Galloway scheint das schon irgendwie, scheint so eine Sensibilität
dafür zu haben. Er öffnet uns so ein bisschen sein Herzchen.
Es gibt einen Grund, warum romantische Komiks zwei Stunden lang sind, nicht zehn Minuten.
Wir schaffen ein Welt mit niedrigen Kalorien, mit niedrigen Gewinnsituationen,
in dem es keine Hindernisse gibt oder Verleumdungen.
Und das führt zu einem Leidensfehler. Es führt zu einem Leidensfehler der Siegertätigkeit.
Es ist wirklich spannend, für einen Freund zu sprechen, um von einem anderen
Schulabschluss gefragt zu werden, wenn vier Mädchen aus deinem eigenen Schulabschluss
sagen, dass sie dir Nein sagen.
Ja, du hast das gesagt. Ich kann das zuerst einmal sagen. Es ist wirklich spannend,
wenn du vier Mädchen zu deiner Prima an der Universität in der High School fragst
und sie alle sagen Nein, und dann fragst du jemand, ob du zu deiner Prima in
einer anderen Schule warst. Ich habe vier Mädchen gefragt und sie haben Nein gesagt.
Aber das ist das Leben. Das ist das Wunder und die Siegertät des Lebens.
Und stattdessen sagen wir, ich weiß, ich werde eine falsche Beziehung auf einer
digitalen Plattform haben, die von der AI erhöht wird, und ich werde nie wirkliches
Wunsch und nie wirkliches Sieg wissen.
Und Scott, bleib weg von der AI. Das ist alles, was ich sagen muss.
Also das ist ja eine sehr harte, große, gewichtige These, die er jetzt macht.
Wir dachten mit Social Media ist schon alles, aber nein, jetzt mit AI kommt
die echte Entfremdung. Wenn Politiker über Zusammenhalt reden wollen,
müssen sie sich um Sam Altman kümmern.
Und anstatt dann irgendwie mit Akademie und hier und so weiter zu kommen,
kommt die Plausibilisierung über seine eigene Erfahrung von früher.
Und das finde ich irgendwie, das ist so die neue Qualität. Das gibt es nur im Podcast so, ne?
Muss man sich auch in deutschland wieder zutrauen als podcast wir haben ja immer
noch diese programm überladenen dann reden wir jetzt mal mit der beziehungspsychologin
und so weiter darüber und so weiter,
dann lieber einfach sam altman der hier uns kurz, scott galloway der uns kurz
erzählt dass er damals von vier frauen links liegen gelassen wurde,
Also gar erst zu einer anderen Schule zur Prom eingeladen wurde.
Nun gut, Scott Galloway guckt also auch diese Kongressanhörung wie wir gleich
und hat folgende Meinung für uns vorab.
Ich hoffe, dass Sam seine Worte wahrgenommen hat.
Er scheint ein schöner junger Mann zu sein. Ihr mögt ihn. Jeder,
den ich kenne, denkt viel von ihm. Jedes Stück Daten sagt, dass er voll von
Scheiße ist und dass er zwei Waffen von Massentragung benutzt hat,
die uns vorher benutzt wurden.
Eine, die verpflichtet ist, reguliert zu werden, und die neue Waffe von Massentragung
ist, diese Firma als einen Unternehmen zu bezeichnen, als eine Unternehmen, als ein Unternehmen.
Ich denke, dass 100 Mal die ursprünglichen Investitionen zurück zu den Investoren
und der Management gehen, bevor das Geld zurück zu einem Non-Profit geht.
Also sollten sie nicht den Begriff Non-Profit benutzen, wenn sie über diese
Firma sprechen. Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, ich schließe mich schon jetzt Scott Galloway an. Ich sehe das ganz genauso,
würde aber auch wahrscheinlich immer mit Carys Fischer über Kreuz liegen.
Denn ja, das ist wirklich das Gelaber, das ich allzu gut von unseren Influencern
kenne und OMR und weiß ich nicht was.
Und nein, so Leute traue ich, ich traue so Leuten generell nicht.
Dann lieber mit jemanden von irgendeinem schlimmen, schlimmen Unternehmen sprechen,
der ist wenigstens ehrlich.
Also ich bin auch häufig und in diesem Falle besonders ein Anhänger von Scott Galloway.
Ich würde nicht sagen Sam Altman ist full of shit, aber diese Probleme in unserem
sozialen Alltag, die heraufziehen würden, sind wirklich immens.
Also die Leute haben ja bis heute null Reflektionen, null Aufklärung darüber,
wie sehr sie sich schon voneinander verabschiedet und abgeschottet haben im
Vergleich zu, sagen wir mal, vor dem iPhone.
Allein, weil du irgendwo in der Fremde nur noch wie so ein Prepper rumrennst,
der sich die Route vorher bei Google Maps zurechtgeklickt hat,
seine Währung immer dabei hat, jede Informationsfrage über sein Smartphone klären
kann, Obwohl auch einfach ein Gespräch da weiterhelfen könnte und so weiter und so fort.
Also der Fremde ist uns wirklich immer fremder geworden.
Und ich erfahre es ja, wenn ich in der Stadt bin. Ich habe ja kein Smartphone
und ich frage mitunter Leute nach dem Weg, die aus der Stadt sind.
Entweder wissen sie den Weg gar nicht und müssen dann in ihrem Smartphone nachgucken.
Ich hatte in Münster 500 Meter vom Hauptbahnhof gefragt bei einer Dame,
die dort im Geschäft arbeitete, wo der Hauptbahnhof ist. Und sie konnte es mir nicht sagen.
Und ich dachte mir, oh, ja, interessant.
Oder ich frage Leute und die sagen, ja, gucken Sie doch bei Google nach.
Und dann sage ich, ja, schöne Idee, habe aber kein Smartphone.
Damals haben die Leute sich lustig gemacht, dass Leute auf der Straße stehen
und Selbstgespräche führen. Dann hieß es, ha ha ha ha, die telefonieren ja.
Heute wirst du komisch angeguckt, wenn du jemanden ansprichst.
Hör ich Sie doch gar nicht. Können Sie nicht Ihr Smartphone fragen?
Was sind Sie für ein irre, verlorener Typ?
Jaja, also es geht drunter und drüber.
Und ich im Anzug, die denken dann immer, ich will denen jetzt noch Komponenten
und will denen noch eine Religion verkaufen.
Ganz genau, du bist sehr verdächtig. Also wir beginnen,
wir überspringen wie Senator Blumenthal die Eingangsrede, die er hält,
von GPT hat schreiben lassen und von einem Voice AI und so weiter und so fort,
sondern wir steigen direkt bei Mediacres ein.
Congress has a choice now. We had the same choice when we faced social media.
We failed to seize that moment. The result is predators on the Internet,
toxic content, exploiting children, creating dangers for them.
And Senator Blackburn and I and others like Senator Durbin on the Judiciary
Committee are trying to deal with it, Kids Online Safety Act.
But Congress failed to meet the moment on social media.
Jetzt haben wir die Verpflichtung, das an AI zu tun, bevor die Bedrohungen und
die Risiken wirklich wahr werden.
So, bei Social Media hat man den Moment verpasst. Das darf uns nicht noch mal
passieren, sagt sich der Politiker selbst.
Und Josh Hawley sekundiert. in der Psychiatrie, der mir zeigt,
dass die Chat-GPT und generative AI, diese großen Sprachmodelle,
wirklich wie die Erfindung der Internet in Höhe, zumindest, zumindest,
und potenziell viel, viel mehr signifikant als das sind.
Wir könnten uns an eine der größten
technologischen Innovationen in der Menschheitsgeschichte anschauen.
Und meine Frage ist, was für eine Innovation das sein wird.
Also, ist es die größte Erfindung der Menschheitsgeschichte?
Und wenn ja, in welche Richtung wird sie uns vorbringen?
Na gut, Sam Altman bedankt sich natürlich für so viel, was so wichtig bin ich,
finde ich gut, ich finde das auch.
AI wurde auf dem Glauben gegründet, dass künstliche Intelligenz die Möglichkeit
hat, fast jeden Aspekt unseres Lebens zu verbessern, aber auch,
dass es ernsthafte Risiken ergibt, müssen wir zusammenarbeiten, um das zu gestalten.
Wir sind hier, weil die Leute diese Technologie lieben.
Wir glauben, dass es ein Printing-Press-Moment sein kann. Wir müssen zusammenarbeiten, um es so zu machen.
Das ist natürlich ein komischer Begriff, ich habe ihn in Redaktionsschluss damals
schon verwendet, weil die skandinavischen Literaturprofessoren,
die dann in Harvard diese Idee aufwarfen, ihn nannten.
Jetzt habe ich gesehen, Jeff Jarvis hat ein Buch, aktuell, die Gutenberg-Parenthese.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, das zu lesen, ich erwarte mir nicht viel,
er ist ja nun doch einer dieser Social-Media-Lobbyisten und so.
Aber wenn jetzt Sam Altman sagt, es ist ein Druckerpressen-Moment, dann würde ich sagen,
Der Druckerpressen-Moment, den ihr hier meint, also vor 500 Jahren wird die
Druckerpresse erfunden, aus Sprache und Schrift für wenige wird Druckpresse-Erzeugnis für viele.
Das war ja nun wirklich der Moment, in dem die Schriftwerkzeuge uns ermöglichten,
Verwaltungen aufzubauen, Archive aufzubauen, uns als Individuum und Autor ein
bisschen zurückzunehmen, den Text gewähren zu lassen, weil man druckt halt für
Leute, die man gar nicht kennt, die vielleicht 100 ein Buch lesen oder so.
Man hat keine Beziehung zu denen, der Text muss sich bewähren.
Die ganze Moderne, die wir so kennen, hat ja damit zu tun und wahrscheinlich
hat sie auch überhaupt erst diese ganze Bevölkerungsexplosion entfacht.
Also hier einfach zu sagen, das ist ein Druckerpresse- moment ist zum einen,
das ist dann wirklich sehr aufgeladen.
Und zum anderen, wenn es jetzt wieder so ein Druckerpresse-Moment ist und wir
haben schon die Idee der Gutenberg-Parenthese, also also des historischen Einschubs.
Und das könnte jetzt sozusagen das Ende der Gutenberg-Parenthese sein.
Dann hieße das ja wirklich, dass die Literaturwissenschaftler recht hatten.
Bis zur Gutenberg-Erfindung der Druckerpresse standen wir einfach auf dem Feld
rum, haben uns was zugerufen, die Spontanität hat den Tag gestaltet.
Abends ging halt die Sonne unter, also ist man schlafen gegangen,
man wusste ja nichts anderes.
Es gab ja keine Bücher, in denen ratgebermäßig drinsteht, was zu tun ist und so weiter und so fort.
Es wurden keine Eigentumstitel irgendwo festgeschrieben, weil worauf denn?
Auf Pergament, das wurde ja nun Klöstern für religiöse Texte verwendet,
die Idee von Vertragsgestaltung und so weiter bis hin zu Satzung und Verfassung
war einfach nicht vorhanden.
Und wenn jetzt wieder ein Druckerpresse-Moment ist und diese Wissenschaftler
haben Recht, also wir können jetzt wieder darauf verzichten,
diese ganzen Druckerzeugnisse und ihre sozialen Folgen zu nutzen,
sondern wir können uns ja wieder Sachen zurufen.
Wir haben ja Smartphones, künstliche Intelligenz, wir müssen ja gar nichts mehr
planen, wir müssen ja gar nichts mehr organisieren. Wir müssen auch nichts mehr
lernen, weil es ist ja alles auf Zuruf da.
Dann stürzen wir dann wirklich zurück ins Mittelalter, wie ich's im Buch damals
im Redaktionsschluss noch so als, naja, das ist so deren Befürchtung.
Nur wenn die jetzt hier sitzen und sagen, erstens ist es ein guten Presse,
ein guten Berg Presseerfindungsmoment und zweitens,
wir wissen noch nicht genau in welche Richtung diese zweite größte Menschheitsgeschärfe
geht, dann droht uns wirklich, dass wir in 20 Jahren in Idiocracy angekommen
sind, in der wir einfach nur noch so dahin leben für Produktivität.
Dass wir überleben, ist ausreichend gesorgt. Aber es gibt keine Notwendigkeit,
keinen menschlichen Antrieb mehr darüber hinaus, weil macht ja die künstliche
Intelligenz und zwar viel besser als wir selber.
Und wir machen dann was völlig anachronistisches im Salon. Wir lesen noch Bücher.
Wenn es noch welche gibt. Wenn es noch welche gibt, ja.
Es ist ziemlich aufgeladen, was die hier so reden, ohne dass sie wahrscheinlich
selber die, Also, klar, die betonen es so, das könnte die größte Erfindung sein,
aber da gibt's ja wirklich Konzepte dahinter, die man sich mal anschauen muss.
Naja, Sam Altman mal zu seiner Verantwortung.
Das ist das neue Paradigma der Industriepolitik, meines Erachtens,
dass jetzt nicht mehr dieses Libertäre gut ankommt, das wird noch so ein bisschen
gespielt von Peter Thiel, aber auch nur dann, wenn es nicht gerade um Subventionen geht.
Und sonst ist ja auch Peter Thiel jemand, der ganz stark die Nähe zur Regierung
gesucht hat. Nur dann eben zu einer Trump-Regierung und nicht zu einer demokratischen Regierung.
Und jetzt geht es darum, dass man gemeinsam mit der Politik einen Rahmen setzt,
in dem sich das eigene Unternehmen am besten entfalten kann.
Und vor allem Konkurrenz aus dem Ausland verdrängt wird. Das ist ja auch das
Ansinnen eines Mark Zuckerberg, der natürlich am liebsten hätte,
dass der Kongress sich einig darüber wird, dass TikTok verboten wird.
Genau. Und das ist nämlich der Punkt, wenn er hier sagt, wir haben eine Verantwortung,
der wir nachkommen, egal was der Kongress tut.
Er kann nur für sein Unternehmen sprechen. Er kann sich natürlich Ketten anlegen,
aber es gibt ja eine Marktwirtschaft in der Konkurrenz und so weiter.
Und so weiter. Und wenn ihm da der Rang abgelaufen wird, dann weiß man,
diese Ketten sind nichts wert. Also entweder Kongress macht oder nicht.
Nun gut, das erste Thema, über das Sie dann reden, ist allerdings doch neu.
Ich habe das jetzt jedenfalls nicht so im Ohr, dass das auch bei den Social
Media Sachen so eine Rolle spannte.
Es ging um Lizenzierungen und Zertifizierungen, die wir natürlich aus vielen
Bereichen kennen. Also man kann nicht auf der Autobahn mit einem,
keine Ahnung, Erdöl-Tank rumfahren, ohne da ein ein Gefahrgut-Label draufzukleben
und es bedeutet dann noch einiges.
Und Integrität. Meine Frage, um mit Ihnen zu beginnen,
Herr Altmann, ist, ob wir independent testing labs für Schwerpunkte und Nutrition
Labels oder das Äquivalent von Nutrition Labels,
Packaging, die zeigen, ob das Inhalt vertraut ist, was die Zutaten sind und
was das Garbage going in may be because it could result in garbage going out.
Bevor wir seine Antwort hören, die Fragestellung ist ja wirklich interessant,
weil außerhalb der Internetregulierungen ist das völlig gang und gäbe.
In jedem Restaurant kommt natürlich ein Externer und sagt, hier Gesundheitsamt
und so weiter, wir können diesen Betrieb auch stilllegen, Sie haben hier Mitwirkungspflichten,
zeigen Sie uns, wie Sie diese Nudeln kochen.
Überall. Nur im Internet sind wir das so gar nicht gewöhnt. Und die Frage ist
halt, wie schnell können wir uns davon wieder entwöhnen, sodass solche Ideen
ja nicht plötzlich als, oh, das ist aber krass, selbst sowas,
sondern sagen, ja, natürlich.
Also klar fährt da bitte jemand hin und guckt sich das mal an und dann gibt
es eine Behörde dafür, die da einfach mal guckt, wie diese Modelle trainiert werden und so.
Wir hören jetzt Sam Altmans Antwort. Er nimmt den Nutzer mit in die Verantwortung.
Man soll die Nutzerintelligenz nicht unterschätzen. Danach macht er aber noch
eine interessante Anmerkung.
Es macht definitiv Fehler. Wir finden, dass die User sehr sophisticated sind
und verstehen, wo die Fehler sind, die sie vermitteln müssen,
dass sie verantwortlich sein müssen, verifizieren, was die Modelle sagen,
dass sie abgehen und es prüfen.
Ich habe Angst, dass die Modelle immer besser werden und die Nutzer weniger
und weniger von ihrem eigenen Diskriminierungsverhalten haben können.
Aber ich denke, die Nutzer sind mehr kapitalistisch, als wir sie oft für Kredit
geben können in solchen Gesprächen.
Von der ich sagen würde, ja, also da sollte man auch sofort aufpassen und zum
Beispiel im Bildungswesen diese Maschine relativ weit zurückdrehen,
um eben dem Gehirn gar nicht erst, ja, kannst auch einen Taschenrechner nutzen.
Nein, bis zur Prüfung gibt es ja keinen Taschenrechner, erst danach.
Also musst einmal zeigen, dass es geht.
Bildungswesen ist ein gutes Stichwort. Ich bin fast überrascht,
dass du nicht als Thema mitgebracht hast.
Die jungen Menschen, die Viertklässler wurden, glaube ich, getestet,
können immer schlechter lesen und schreiben.
Was ist dazu zu sagen? Das eine ist sicherlich, dass das eine Auswirkung durch
die schlechte Beschulung Corona, aber davor war sie auch schon nicht gut.
Und es hat sich jetzt nochmal verschlechtert und ob jetzt Corona dazu kommt
oder ob man es rausrechnet, generell kann man festhalten, es ist schlechter geworden.
Ich habe dann viel gelesen, also klar sind an den Schulen zu wenige Lehrer,
Unterrichtsausfall. Aber.
Ich fand schon erstaunlich, wie manche sich auch so ganz darum gedrückt haben,
dass es auch mit Smartphones etc.
Zusammenhängen kann. Und dann wird immer gesagt, ja, aber die texten ja so viel.
Ja, aber das ist ja dann doch noch mal was anderes, ob man sich kurze Nachrichten
schickt oder dann ja auch oft Sprachnachrichten oder ob man in der Lage ist,
einen größeren Text zu verstehen und ihn vielleicht in eigenen Worten wiederzugeben
Und auch da grammatikalisches Gespür an den Tag legen kann.
Das wurde aber so ganz ausgeplänet. Ich finde es immer noch verwunderlich,
wir hatten ja irgendwann mal über dieses Buch von Spitzer geredet,
von Manfred Spitzer, Digitale Demenz war das, über das wir gesprochen haben.
Und dass man diesen doch ganz starken Einfluss dieser Geräte in solchen Debatten nur marginal hat.
Oder es gibt dann Einzelstimmen, die den vielleicht ganz stark machen.
Komplett immer mit reingerechnet wird. Denn jeder macht doch diese Erfahrung.
Ich wurde jetzt von jungen Leuten gefragt, die gerade Abi gemacht haben,
wie ich das schaffen würde, so viel zu lesen. Und ich sage, ja,
es fällt mir auch schwerer als noch vor zehn Jahren, als ich noch nicht einen Laptop hatte.
Ich muss also jetzt bewusster den Laptop ausmachen.
Und jetzt lese ich. Und klar, ich kriege dann immer noch viel geschafft.
Aber ich weiß, dass es schon jetzt schwierig ist, wäre ich digital native,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich noch viel größere Schwierigkeiten, mich davon so ganz
loszumachen und sagen, jetzt lese ich ein paar Stunden.
Und das ist doch ein Effekt, den kann man nicht leugnen.
Also auf dieser OMR-Bühne.
Der eine von den beiden war ja ganz erstaunt, dass jetzt die Bewährungszeit,
die ein TikTok-Video hat, bis es vom Nutzer abgelehnt, also weitergeswiped wird,
0,4 Sekunden ist. Und er war ja, oh, das ist ja ganz aufregend, 0,4 Sekunden.
Und ich hab mir nur gedacht, ja, wie nutzt er denn TikTok?
Also guckt er sich das Video bis zu Ende an und scrollt dann erst weiter oder was?
Nein, man scrollt natürlich so durch, bis man irgendwo hängen bleibt.
Also sind das dann im schnitt 0,4 sekunden.
Und wir haben jetzt eben, das ist eigentlich so erstaunlich,
weil du jetzt meinst so lange Texte und so und grammatikalisches Gespür,
das spielt ja in der Grundschule eigentlich gar nicht so die große Rolle,
die lesen ja keine langen Texte, also im Sinne von langen oder schreiben.
Ich meine von der ganzen Seite. Das lesen sie ja schon.
Ja klar, es kommt so vor, nur die werden eben, also sagen wir mal so,
die Bildungserfolge außerhalb des Klassenzimmers durch die Social Media Konzerne ist wirklich immens.
Die Kinder, also denen wurde alles abtrainiert. Die haben ja nun wirklich alle
ab der ersten Klasse zumindest das Handy ihrer Eltern in der Hand oder haben
sogar schon so ein eigenes ab der zweiten Klasse.
Und es verwundert mich, dass überhaupt noch Bildungserfolg bei rumkommt.
Also wenn ich so sehe, was in der Altersklasse meiner Kinder los ist,
das ist unglaublich. Also wenn du da anfängst mit Handy gibt es erst ab der
weiterführenden Schule, also so mit 10 in der vierten Klasse,
dann bist du schon echt spät dran als Eltern.
Das ist wirklich crazy und die haben auch alles auf ihrem Handy.
Also TikTok, Snapchat, der ganze Kram. Wo ich mir echt denke,
ey, dieses Gehirn ist so windelweich im Werden, eine Woche TikTok und das Ding
ist, also das Gehirn meine ich mit dem Ding, das ist verloren.
Aber das ist ein flächendeckendes Phänomen.
Man merkt das ja an sich selbst, wenn man diese App mal nutzt oder ich weiß
das noch bei der Recherche für das Influencer Buch, dass Ono und ich richtig
rammdösig wurden, wenn wir das zwei, drei Stunden machten.
Wer sich dafür interessiert, was bei TikTok los ist, geht zu YouTube,
googelt nach TikTok, guckt euch die Videos an, die ungefähr 20 Minuten lang
sind, da kommen alle wichtigen Memes und so weiter vor. Dann kann man sich einmal
so ein 20 Minuten Video angucken, dann weiß man, was auf TikTok los ist.
Aber dann steht man nicht in Gefahr, die ganze Zeit auf seinem Handy nachzuschauen,
ich will mir mal selber Überblick verschaffen und so.
Einfach wirklich nicht benutzen, löschen.
Aber TikTok ist ja nicht das einzige Ding, sondern bei Instagram haben wir ja
auch eine TikTokisierung,
während TikTok ja immer längere Videos jetzt zulässt, dass man sich schon fast
wieder fragen kann, wird jetzt TikTok einfach ein YouTube, weil eine ganz junge
Generation gar nicht mehr den Weg zu YouTube als erstes sucht,
sondern über TikTok das macht und dann kann man jetzt auch längeres da haben.
Also es gibt jetzt, glaube ich, die Möglichkeit bis 10 Minuten oder gar 15 Minuten
lange Videos hochzuladen.
Also ich denke mir mittlerweile bei allen Diskussionen, man muss jetzt wirklich
mal das große Stoppschild aufstellen.
Wenn man Grundschüler hat, dann haben die irgendwie Klassenlehrerunterricht
und dann so vier Stunden Deutsch und vier Stunden Mathe in der Woche.
Aber der normale Grundschüler guckt zehn Stunden TikTok die Woche.
Also kannst du da mit Unterrichtsstunden.
So Debatten wie im Deutschunterricht werden aber auch so alte Texte gelesen,
als sei das das Problem, dass die dann in der 10.
Oder 11. Klasse mal den Faust lesen, als sei das jetzt abschreckend und jetzt
muss man da mal was suchen, was die jungen Leute erreicht. Ja,
was erreicht denn eine Gruppe von 28 Leuten?
Da sind so viele Individualitäten, die da sitzen, ja?
Was will man jetzt haben? Will man jetzt eine Coming-of-Age-Geschichte haben?
Und dann sagt man, ach, das interessiert die jetzt gerade. Ja,
das interessiert dann vielleicht gerade die Mädels nicht oder die Jungs mehr
oder was auch immer. Das ist also völliger Unsinn. Und das sind aber jetzt diese
Debatten, also das wird bestimmt jetzt noch kommen. Wir müssen mal weg vom Literaturkanon.
Das haben wir ja eh schon die ganze Zeit im deutschen Unterricht.
Es wird ja sowieso immer weniger da auch gelesen, wie man dann so erfuhr von
Statistiken, also wie wenig Zeit eigentlich fürs Lesen aufgewendet wird im Unterricht
und das sind reine Scheindebatten.
Also ich akzeptiere mittlerweile auch niemanden mehr in irgendeiner Diskussion.
Also ich will dann einfach gar nicht mehr darüber reden, wenn jemand anfängt
mit, ne, aber hier und da und TikTok und überhaupt und so.
TikTok ist einfach der größte Büll aller Zeiten. Es macht alle Gehirne zu Matsch.
Es kommt nichts bei rum. Es hat überhaupt gar keine konstruktiven Elemente,
kein sinnstiftendes irgendwas. Also es ist einfach...
Und meinst du, ich sollte die Filmanalyse jetzt auch bei TikTok hochladen,
wenn man da längere Videos hinkriegt?
Nein, es ist alles Schrott. Ja, man kann das selber... Als Zweitverwertung.
Wenn man selber Inhalte reinbringt, kann es für einen noch lukrativ sein.
Aber TikTok passiv zu nutzen, also ich schaue da mal zu und so weiter,
irgendwo scheint noch irgendwo eine Perle versteckt zu sein, aber das ist alles Müll.
Und Scott Galloway sitzt ja mittlerweile auch im Fernsehen bei Bill Maher und so und sagt dann,
ja, also TikTok ist einfach die direkte Anbindung aller amerikanischen Gehirne
an die kommunistische Partei Chinas,
um wenn deren Auftrag es ist, in zehn Jahren dafür zu sorgen,
dass sich Amerikaner jeden Tag ein bisschen schlechter über ihr eigenes Land fühlen.
Dann setzt man ihnen einfach das chinesische Programm von dem amerikanischen TikTok vor.
Dann sehen sie irgendwelche Straßenraudis oder hier und da eine Schlägerei und
sie fühlen sich jeden Tag ein bisschen schlechter.
Und so wird einfach ein ganzes Land demoralisiert. Und ich denke mir dann irgendwie
auf der einen Seite, das klingt schon ziemlich abgespaced.
Auf der anderen Seite, warum nicht? Warum nicht so fantastisch denken?
Alles hypernormalisieren.
Warum sollte das nicht offizielles, internes chinesisches Programm sein?
Spricht da gar nichts dagegen?
Ich halte das für möglich, nur momentan erleben wir bei TikTok eher das Gegenteil.
So das gibt es auch, aber es gibt ja zum Beispiel jetzt, ich sag mal die NATO
kann sich jetzt gerade nicht darüber beklagen, dass es TikTok gibt.
Also wenn ich mir ansehe, wie sehr da ukrainischer Content und wie sehr militärischer
Content von der westlichen Perspektive gehypt wird, dann würde ich sagen, momentan.
Dem nicht so klar ist, dass so manipulierbar. Ich würde einfach sagen,
dass es durch die Form, also diese Form der Kürze und dann das,
was belohnt wird von diesem Algorithmus, man eben dazu kommt,
dass das generell eine unglaubliche Verblödung produziert.
Aber ich sehe nicht den so großen Unterschied zu beispielsweise Instagram.
Ja, das ist eben das zweite.
Also die Leute, die meisten Leute nutzen ja Instagram inzwischen wie TikTok.
Und wir tun das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wenn du bei Twitter ein Video anklickst, kannst du sofort zum nächsten swipen.
Also das ist alles super gefährlich. Ich halte das alles für die komplette Verblödungsmaschine.
Wir haben das jetzt ein oder zwei Jahre, sagen wir mal so seit 2020,
Corona war nur so ein Katalysator.
Aber das ist einfach, also nicht ohne Grund lassen die Leute im Silicon Valley
ihre Kinder nicht an Smartphones und lassen sich von ihren Kinderbetreuungen,
sei es Babysitter oder festangestellte Leute unterschreiben,
in diesem Haushalt darf gar kein Smartphone sichtbar sein.
Lass es im Auto liegen, wenn du meine Kinder betreust, hast du kein Smartphone
in der Hand. Das machen die nicht ohne Grund, die kennen sich da aus.
Die Kinder von Heckler und Koch und Rheinmetall werden wahrscheinlich auch nicht
mit Waffen durch den Garten laufen.
Ganz genau. Also diese Scott-Galloway-These zur direkten Anbindung an die chinesische Partei.
Und auch diese Frage, was sehen eigentlich chinesische junge TikToker?
Die kriegen bestimmt nicht diesen Müll wie in Amerika und in Europa angezeigt,
sondern TikTok ist einfach ein Rapid Hole für alle. Und TikTok ist wirklich
nur das Chiffre für dieses Phänomen der Kurzvideoscheiße.
Das ist auch so leicht erklärbar, wie das hormonell einfach,
also Maschine und Mensch verschmelzen in diesem Moment. Um da einfach so ein
Hormongenerierungsapparat durchzuholen.
Über die Komponente Sex aber, das finde ich schon so interessant,
dass das so ganz stark ist.
Also man darf zwar ja nichts pornografisches zeigen, aber dass das so alles so aufgesext ist.
Total. Also wie dieser Content dort entsteht,
der ja dann entweder zum Onlyfans-Profil überleiten soll oder man generell alles so ein bisschen,
naja, man hatte sowas früher in der Werbung zwar auch, dass jedes Parfum musste
natürlich erotisch präsentiert werden, aber jetzt ist das so alles.
Alles, ja. Es ist also wirklich gruselig und sollte mehr diskutiert werden, aber gut.
Sam Altman vom Kongress, er zieht mal das nächste Horrorszenario auf,
wo er sich sehr besorgt zeigt.
Vielen Dank, Herr Senator Hawley, für die Frage.
Es ist eine meiner größten Sorgen, dass diese Modelle die Möglichkeit haben,
zu manipulieren, zu überzeugen, und eine ein-auf-eine Interaktivkeitsinformation
zu geben. Ich denke, das ist eine breitere Version von dem,
Wir werden nächste Jahr eine Wahl erledigen und diese Modelle werden sich verbessern.
I think this is a significant area of concern.
So, das ist jetzt zweischneidig. Es geht um Wahlbeeinflussung.
Wir kennen ja bisher dieses Targeting.
Du hast deinen individuellen Newsfeed, da wird irgendwas reingespielt.
Und über die Nutzung des Newsfeeds meldet man ja zurück, was man so bevorzugt.
Bisher mussten ja die Newsfeeds irgendwelche Angebote machen,
wie bei TikTok alle 0,4 Sekunden ein neues. Und dann wird bewertet,
was wird häufiger angezeigt und was nicht. Das ist schon rasend schnell.
Jetzt kommt ja hier die Dimension dazu, dass die Nutzer von sich aus losprompten.
Also, sie sind erstens sehr involvierter in dieser Art von, ich lass mich hier informieren.
Und sie zeigen natürlich viel mehr ihre Interessen ganz explizit.
Also, er muss nicht gerätselt und geraten werden, über wie lange lässt man sich
was anzeigen, sondern er hat einfach ausformuliert, was er wissen will.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, das wird zurückgefiedert in diese Maschinen,
wie nutzt man eigentlich diese Daten? Das geht ja über Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Das ist ja das Gute, wenn man manipulieren will.
Man musste ja immer gucken, was wird wahrscheinlich besser sein.
Kommt blau oder rot besser? Wenn ich jetzt aber prompte und nehmen wir mal an,
wir sind jetzt der letzten Generation solidarisch gegenüber.
Dann sagen wir, wir wollen was wissen über die letzte Generation.
Und schreiben die Demonstranten der letzten Generation. Und wenn aber jemand schreibt,
diese Klimakleber, weiß AI Klimakleber ist ein Begriff, der eher in dem und
dem Feld verwendet wird, heißt sehr wahrscheinlich möchte lieber Informationen
zum Thema Habeck enteignet uns durch sein Wärmepumpengesetz.
Also wenn wir uns vorstellen, keine Ahnung, die OpenAI-App ist jetzt schon veröffentlicht,
also man kann es auf dem iPhone benutzen, wie die Google-Suche.
Es ist ein Klick und schon geht das Prompten los.
Man wird ja sehr schnell so eine Promthistorie aufsummieren,
die man nicht einfach privat auf dem Telefon lässt, sondern die muss ja an OpenAI
geliefert werden, weil die müssen ja was mit dem Prompt machen.
Das Modell läuft ja nicht auf dem eigenen Handy. Klar, es gibt da auch Szenarien,
wo das dann irgendwann mal möglich ist, aber noch ist das alles Cloud.
Wir wissen alle intuitiv, meine Prompt-Geschichte bitte nicht,
genauso wie meine Google-Suchen.
Also das ist dann höchstgradig privat. Noch privater als Kommunikation,
Telefonate mit Freunden oder so.
Und jetzt gibt es natürlich Unternehmer wie Sam Ortman, die ganz verantwortungsvoll
sagen, nein, wir gucken uns diese Prompt-Geschichte nicht an,
wir sind ja auch kein Werbe, wir machen ja nur Subscription,
die bezahlen uns, wir machen es für die.
Ich glaube, er gibt jetzt hier mal Google eins mit.
Das geht an die Adresse von Google.
Definitiv.
Wir wissen, wie Google funktioniert. Die interessieren sich,
deswegen haben sie die Bücher alle digitalisiert dafür, wie die Menschen diese Bücher lesen.
Verhaltensüberschuss, so nennt es zu Boff und darum geht es.
Und man produziert beim Prompten unendlich viel Verhaltensüberschuss.
Jede Formulierung, wie man schreibt, macht man Rechtschreibfehler,
sehr, sehr aufschlussreich.
Man macht in einem, also man produziert in einem Übermaß jetzt Informationen
und was für ein Überschuss, wie nennen sie das?
Verhaltensüberschuss.
In einem Ausmaß, das noch nicht mal Google selber weiß. Weshalb die ja gerade
in Algorithmen sitzen und so, wie kann man das dann auch weiter analysieren,
welche Muster sind denn zu entdecken und so.
Es ist doch erstaunlich, wir haben doch jetzt mit diesen großen Enthüllungen
auch prompts gelesen, eigentlich bei Matthias Döpfner.
Diese Zeitenthüllungen, wo er sagt, so macht doch mal die Bild-Zeitung und tut was für die FDP.
Und der Verhaltensüberschuss bei ihm war ja dann nochmal im Speziellmaße alles
klein geschrieben und voller Rechtschreibfehler.
Zum Beispiel, das ist ja alles total ausreichend kräftig.
Das bedeutet natürlich in diesem Falle nicht, Matthias Döpfner kann wohl die
deutsche Sprache nicht, sondern bedeutet, ich bin der Chef.
Ihr glaubt doch nicht, dass ich mir noch Mühe gebe, wenn ich zu euch kommuniziere,
ich schreibe, wie ich möchte.
Diese Form von Signal Intelligence kann Google. Das ist deren Geschäftsmodell.
Und jetzt haben sie überall dieses, du kannst es überall rumpromten.
Also, naja, wir wissen, was er hier meint.
Eine große Unterscheidung zu dem Silicon Valley bisher, dass nämlich die Konzerne
einfach sagen, wir bieten hier nur die Infrastruktur, was da inhaltlich stattfindet,
müssen die Nutzer unter sich klären.
Wenn hier jemand beleidigt wird, ist der Autor dafür verantwortlich,
wir sind es nicht, wir sind nur die Infrastrukturanbieter.
Also vor dieser Verantwortung bewahrte sie diese Section 230,
in dem entscheidenden, ist ja nur so ein dreizeiliges Ding in diesem großen
Gesetzespaket, das da für sie relevant ist.
Was hat sie aus jeder Mitverantwortung befreit?
Was eben für OpenAI bedeuten würde, egal was die Prompts sagen,
was weiß ich, eine Bombenanleitung oder so, damit haben wir nichts zu tun.
Wir haben nur das Modell zurecht geschickt. Wenn der so einen Prompt schreibt,
da können wir ja nichts dafür.
Diese Verantwortung allerdings will OpenAI nicht loswerden.
We decided that in Section 230 that we were basically going to absolve the industry
from liability for a period of time as it came into being.
Well, Mr. Altman,
on the podcast earlier this year you agreed with host Kara Swisher that Section
230 doesn't apply to generative AI and that developers like OpenAI should not
be entitled to full immunity for harms caused by their products.
Also was haben wir von 230 gelernt, das zu Ihrer Situation mit der AI passt?
Danke für die Frage, Herr Präsident. Ich weiß noch nicht genau,
was die richtige Antwort hier ist. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen kooperieren, um es herauszufinden.
So, er wird nochmal von Graham, Lindsay Graham, den wir ja vorhin schon hörten,
festgenagelt auf diese Section 230 Sache.
Bei den Medien ist das Section 230-App-App-App. Es ist verwendet,
um Leidenschaftler für andere Menschen
zu vermeiden, die im Bezug auf ihre Anwendungsgeräte nicht zulassen.
Meine Mutter ruft das Unternehmen an und sagt, dass das App-App-App verwendet
wird, um meine Tochter zu verletzen.
Sie hat mir verloren, dass sie anhand der Anwendungsgeräte verletzungen werden.
Sie ruft drei Mal an, bekommt keine Antwort, und es gibt keine Antwort,
das Kind tötet sich selbst und sie können nicht verurteilen.
Glauben Sie, wir wollen das nicht wieder tun? Ja. Wenn ich kurz reden darf,
gibt es einen grundlegenden Unterschied zwischen dem Produzieren von Inhalt
und dem Generieren von Inhalt.
Ja, aber Sie möchten eine Verpflichtung, wo Menschen verletzt werden? Absolut.
Ja, in der Tat hat IBM öffentlich gebeten, eine Verpflichtung auf einer reasonablen
Pflegestandard zu verleihen. Lassen Sie mich nur versichern,
dass ich die Gesetze, die heute existieren, verstehe.
Herr Altman, danke, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Ihre Firma beurteilt nicht, dass die Artikel 230 the tool you have created.
Ja, wir sagen, dass wir zusammenarbeiten müssen, um einen komplett neuen Ansatz
zu finden. Ich glaube nicht, dass § 230 das richtige Rahmen ist.
Okay, also unter dem Gesetz, das heute existiert, dieses Werkzeug,
das Sie kreiert haben, wenn ich verletzt werde, kann ich Sie verhaften?
Das ist außerhalb meiner legalen Expertise. Wurdest du jemals verhaftet?
Nicht für das, nein. Wurdest du jemals überhaupt verhaftet? Bei Ihrer Firma?
Ja, ich wurde verhaftet.
Ja, wir wurden schon verhaftet. Okay, und wofür?
I mean they've mostly been like pretty frivolous things like I think happens to any company.
So das ist finde ich schon ein Paukenschlag, Section 230 einfach jetzt zu streichen.
Wir übernehmen mit Verantwortung für die Sachen, die wir veröffentlichen.
Die Frage ist jetzt so ein bisschen,
wenn jetzt Open AI, JetGPT einbauen lässt als Co-Pilot für irgendwas,
Dann ist ja zwischen OpenAI und dem Nutzer nochmal ein anderes Unternehmen,
das dann irgendwie ein Chatbot anbietet, aber auch andere Sachen und so weiter.
Also kann man da noch genau nachvollziehen, wer dafür welches generierte Element
verantwortlich, also dass man das dann auch zurechnen kann einfach.
Und wie sieht die Verantwortlichkeit dann aus?
Tja, da sagt er, das muss jetzt neu gemacht werden. Jetzt ist ja die große Frage,
wie er hat zum einen, das überspringen wir aber schon recht weiträumig über
zum Beispiel darüber gesprochen, dass wir so eine Art, er nennt dann auch bewusst
diese Atomaufsichtsbehörde.
Ja, so einen globalen Zugriff auf, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal dahin und gucken
uns die Anlage an. Wir haben die Verdacht, dass hier irgendwas passiert.
Diese Zugriffe sind ja alle soweit geregelt, kommen dann nur in Iran oder so
durch politische Verstrickung nicht zustande.
Und zum anderen diese ganz großen Copyright- und Vergütungsfragen hat er auch
thematisiert und meint dann, jeder Künstler soll das Recht haben, so wie jeder Mensch.
Zu opt-outen. Ich möchte nicht, dass meine Daten mit in das Modell einfließen.
Was auf der einen Seite verständlich ist, weil sie brauchen diese individuellen Sachen nicht.
Sie sind interessiert, dass sie die Wikipedia durchlesen können,
die Bücher und dann auch sehr viele synthetische Texte, die die Nutzer vorher
als, die gefallen mir ganz gut, die könnten vorbildhaft für weitere generierte Texte sein und so.
Das ist alles ganz gut, aber ich hab's mir extra noch mal aufgeschrieben,
Adobe hat ja Firefly veröffentlicht und zwar direkt in Photoshop eingebaut.
Also man geht jetzt in Photoshop und lässt sich da einfach Sachen ins Bild generieren.
Dieser Datenbestand ist alleine mit diesen Adobe-Stock-Fotografien zusammen generiert worden.
Das heißt, niemals steht ein Nutzer von Photoshop, der sich Sachen generieren
lässt, in Gefahr, irgendwo Rechte zu missachten.
Und das fand ich eine der mutigsten unternehmerischen Entscheidungen überhaupt.
Denn damit hat Adobe eigentlich den ganzen Markt erst mal zu sich geholt.
Wer sich Bilder generieren lassen will und die auch kommerziell verwerten will,
darf nicht in die Gefahr kommen, dass irgendwer dagegen klagt und sagt,
also du hast mich hunderttausendfach plakatiert, ich will jetzt mal meinen Anteil und so weiter haben.
Wenn sonst wären sie draußen gewesen, dann hätte man sonst gesagt,
wozu brauche ich eigentlich Adobe?
Also Adobe ist ja eigentlich, könnte man ja als Bearbeitungsprogramm,
braucht man noch Adobe in Zukunft.
Und indem sie sich aber jetzt in dieser Weise da angedockt haben,
sind sie jetzt quasi unentbehrlich geworden.
Sie haben sich jetzt zum unentbehrlichen, aber eben auf Kosten von,
bisher war es ja so, ja gut, dass du Photoshop nutzt, Das kostet so 23 Euro
im Monat, dass du das machst hier und so.
Aber wenn du unsere Stockfotografie nutzen willst, kostet das leicht mal 69 Euro pro Bild und so was.
Und auf diesen ganzen gigantischen milliardenschweren Markt haben sie jetzt einfach verzichtet.
Sie haben ihn komplett geopfert. Das finde ich schon bemerkenswert,
weil eigentlich kennen wir das anders. Kodax sitzt da und sagt,
Digitalfotografie, nee, wir boxen unser analoges Fotografieren durch,
gehen nicht in diese Richtung, die ganze andere Welt aber aussortiert.
Nur stell dir vor, sie hätten auf der Stock-Fotografie beharrt.
Dann hätte man gesagt, kann ja eh jetzt AI generieren, dann werde ich bald diese
Fotos nicht mehr benötigen von Adobe, dann haben die gar kein Geschäftsmodell
mehr und jetzt haben sie es so gemacht. Also klar, es ist ein Riesenschritt, aber es ist an sich.
Also das hat bestimmt einige Tränen gekostet und so auf diese Milliarden Umsätze,
die man da jetzt hatte, zu verzichten, aber damit haben sie jetzt,
indem sie selbst geopfert haben, ihrem Kundenstamm wirklich ein unschlagbares
Angebot gemacht, nämlich wirklich bahnbrechende Bildgenerierung.
Also die Leute sind ja wirklich, das kann man sich auf YouTube mal angucken, hin und weg.
Der neueste Trend ist ja, man nimmt Covers aus der Musikgeschichte und sagt
dann einfach, generieren wir alles drumherum.
Wie sah denn dieses Bild eigentlich aus und so? Und das ist wirklich,
also das ist ja einer der interessantesten Moves überhaupt, der noch gar nicht groß besprochen wurde.
Aber von diesem Adobe Move würde ich sagen, das ist mal ein richtiger Schritt
in die Zukunft gewesen von einem Unternehmen, das einfach mal so eine richtige
Goldgrube begräbt, um eine andere aufzumachen.
Und es scheint bislang gut gegangen zu sein. Mal gucken, was Google noch mit
Bildgenerierung oder OpenAI selber macht mit Dolly und so. Aber...
A. Einmal auf der Hülle von den Rolling Stones hieß ein längst vergessener Titel
von Mike Krüger. Jetzt ist es ohne Weiteres möglich. Ich wollte nur noch anfügen.
Bei den Verlagen ist es ja so, dass sie sich auch das erst mal vorbehalten,
dass es offenbar nicht dieses Scrolling gibt.
Also ich lese hier aus einem Surgkamp Band. Am Anfang steht dort alle Rechte
vorbehalten, wie immer.
Und dann steht jetzt aber auch dort, wir behalten uns auch eine Nutzung des
Werks für Text und Data Mining im Sinne von § 44b Urheberrechtsgesetz und so weiter vor.
Ja, ja. Also wir kennen die Robots TXT, die die Google Crawler und so fernhält
von der eigenen Webseite.
Das wird man jetzt relativ zügig regeln.
Die haben ja ganz viele Fragen. Also wie erkennt der Crawler,
dass er das nicht lesen soll? Dann könnte auf der ersten Seite des Buchs einfach
stehen, ich darf von keinem künstlichen Intelligenzding benutzt werden und dann ist das ein Prompt.
Wird damit auch verstanden. Genau wie diese Diskussion, ich habe sie auch übersprungen
aus Länge jetzt, aber die ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant,
wenn man so darüber nachdenkt. Die sagen ja alle,
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass diese künstliche Intelligenz Textgenerierung erstmal
eine amerikanische Domäne bleibt, weil Amerika ist ja eine Demokratie,
anders als China. Aber wie bringt man denn die demokratischen Werte in die Maschine?
Und die Antwort ist dann einfach, ja, das ist einfach immer standardmäßig im
Prompt mit drin, unsichtbar.
Du hältst dich bitte bei den Antworten an das Gesetz. Und das versteht ja das Gesetz.
Ja, aber das Gesetz ist ja nicht das Gesetz. Wir sehen, Linda Teuteberg und
die letzte Generation haben da unterschiedliche Auffassungen vom Grundgesetz. Was macht man dann?
Genau, aber du hast eben das Gesetz und gleich die ganze Kommentierungsgeschichte
und so weiter, die könntest du als prompt immer mitlaufen lassen oder eben im
Alignment schon mit rein trainieren, sodass es erst gar nicht zu Auswüchsen
kommt, die danach wieder begradigt werden müssen.
Das fand ich irgendwie instruktiv, weil ja auch die ganzen Programmierer mittlerweile
feststellen, ach so, wenn ich ein Plugin für irgendwas haben will,
sage ich nur noch, was es soll.
Also es wird so ganz zielprogrammiert, wird einfach das Ziel ausgegeben und
die Maschine macht das dann schon selber.
Und die weiß ja, jetzt mal bitte nicht halluzinieren, sondern jetzt sollte eins
plus eins schon zwei sein, in den Formulierungen, die ich finde.
Also man hält sich dann streng an die Regeln, die die Scriptsprachen entsprechend
vorgeben, die Programmiersprachen.
Und es klappt ja auch recht zuverlässig. Und so kann man eben auch Code is Law
einfach mit reinprompten,
dass man sich bitte an die amerikanischen Sätze hält und dann wird eben entsprechend,
dann gilt eben auch wieder, ja und ist das Grundgesetz davon gleichrangiger
Bedeutung oder ist das wieder amerikanischer Free Speech und so,
ne? Also diese Diskussion, die wir da bisher auch hatten.
Wie würdest du das einschätzen, ist der Wettbewerbsvorteil für westliche Staaten,
die unser Buchstaben so schrieben haben und dann im Prinzip noch mit dem englischen
Sprache, die relativ einfach von der grammatikalischen Struktur sein kann,
im Vergleich zu den westlichen Staaten?
Chinesischer sprach mit denen ja auch technische herausforderung naja für also
wir wissen ja es ist ja ein ding das auf wahrscheinlichkeit geht wir hatten
das im salon ja mal so so vorgestellt wie denkt ja nicht also tschetschewi t denkt nicht,
Sondern da kommt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, ähm, äh, Stefan hat einen roten und
dann kommt's Mund und nicht Hund.
Obwohl es eigentlich ziemlich gleich ist. Aber im chinesischen System gibt es
ja nun noch viel mehr Variationen als in unserem Buchstabensystem.
Also wie weit auch das äh, eine Rolle spielen kann, dass äh,
gerade hier im mengesprachigen Bereich so viel entwickelt wurde.
Also, wir haben ja vorhin im Sozkever gehört und uns auch darüber gewundert,
es mangelt nicht an Rechenpower, aber an originalen Daten. Also wir können zwar
viel synthetisieren, aber so original menschengemachte Daten, da mangelt's.
Und es mag immer noch verwunderlich klingen, aber ja, sehr viele Menschen reden
und schreiben auf Englisch in der Welt, aber sehr viel mehr auf Chinesisch.
Also diese 1,4 Milliarden Menschen, die das einfach in ihrem Standardalltag drin haben,
Da kommt man mit 500 Millionen Europäern und also sagen wir mal 300 Millionen
Amerikaner, 60 Millionen Engländer, danach sind die Amtssprachen schon andere.
Also man findet gar nicht so viele mega englisch sprechende Länder auf der Welt,
da müsste man eigentlich mit Portugiesisch, Spanisch, Mandarinen vor allem,
kommt man auch ganz schön weit.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass die Amerikaner jetzt einen Vorteil haben.
Du siehst keinen Vorteil in den wenigen Buchstaben, die wir haben in unserer Sprachstruktur?
Also das ist ja diese technische Frage, dass bei uns die Token ein bisschen
besser katalogisiert werden können, weil wir nur 26 Buchstaben haben und nicht
kreuz und quer die Zeichen.
Aber überleg mal, die Chinesen, die machen seit 4000 Jahren dieses Archivwesen.
Die können sich ja jetzt eine Sprachgeschichte da drauf trainieren,
mit jeden kleinen Wandelungen, regionalen Besonderheiten und so weiter und so
fort. Das ist ja wirklich immens.
Also da kann man sowieso nicht vorstellen, dass die Chinesen,
so wie auch bei der Impfstofftechnik, jetzt einfach da sitzen und sagen,
oh, das ist auch cool, was die Amerikaner machen. Sondern die delegieren ja
jetzt ihre Leute da wirklich drauf und sagen, schau dir das an.
Nur noch nicht mit diesen Erfolgen.
Und es muss halt da echt nicht veröffentlicht werden. Also da muss kein Atombombentest
irgendwo sichtbar stattfinden.
Aber die GPT-Variationen aus China waren ja alle nicht überzeugend.
Zumindest Jürgen Morozov hat getestet.
Noch nicht, aber mal abwarten. Die von Google war auch erst nicht überzeugend.
Und jetzt mittlerweile, ein Monat später, sieht es schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Naja, das sind alles eben selbstlernende
Maschinen. Da geht es immer schneller, als die selber glauben.
Graham fragt jetzt mal, nachdem die das ja vorher aufgeworfen haben,
Lizenz- und Regulierungssysteme.
Naja, bitte nur global.
Übrigens ganz interessant, ich saß im Zug, habe dann aus Versehen irgendeine
Taste gedrückt, dass die Tonspur, die ich geschnitten habe, scharf geschaltet
wurde, weshalb wir Huster gleich hören.
Denn es wurde direkt auf diese Tonspur mit aufgenommen, bevor ich gesehen habe,
ah ja, ich wollte dann die Datei nicht neu runterladen, weil die war dann einmal
mit dem Huster verseucht. Wir hören also gleich einen Huster aus dem Zug.
Vielleicht wird es das tun, aber wenn man nicht etwas über die China-Aufgabe
macht, wird man das nie richtig verstehen.
Glaubst du das? Das ist der Grund, warum ich denke, dass es nicht unbedingt
eine Weltorganisation sein muss, aber es muss eine Art, und es gibt hier viele
Möglichkeiten, es muss eine Art Standard sein, eine Art Kontrolle,
die einen globalen Effekt hat.
Ja, weil andere Leute das tun. Ich habe hier 15... Militärapplication.
Wie kann AI die Kriegswehr verändern? Und Sie haben eine Minute.
Ich habe eine Minute? Das ist eine schwierige Frage für eine Minute.
Das ist sehr weit weg aus meinem Bereich der Expertise. Ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel, ein Drohnen.
Man kann ein Drohnen an eine Koordinierung anpassen, es kann fliegen,
es geht über dieses Ziel und es droppt ein Missil auf diesem Auto,
der auf der Straße fährt, und jemand schaut es an.
Könnte AI eine Situation schaffen, in der ein Drohnen das Ziel selbst wählen
kann? Ich denke, das sollten wir nicht erlauben. Kann das nicht getan werden?
Also hier keine falschen Vorstellungen von.
Überlegt schon mal was.
Sicherheit.
In China noch so.
Jaja eben. Also da muss man die Uiguren nicht mehr einsperren,
sondern dann kann man die alle so in Schach halten.
Senator Coons erinnert nochmal, oh man, wir sind so krass an Social Media gescheitert.
So, es geht also um sehr viel größere Fragen als bei Social Media,
sagt er. Und Sam Altman, und das ist wirklich mal eine Service-Dienstleistung,
er nennt jetzt mal die drei wichtigsten Baustellen für die Politik?
Dass ein Modell überprüft werden muss, bevor es in die Welt eingeprüft werden kann.
Und drittens brauche ich unabhängige Auditen. Also nicht nur von der Firma oder
der Agenzie, sondern Experten, die sagen können, ob das Modell in Verbindung
ist mit diesen Staats- und Sicherheitsgrenzen Performance on question X or Y.
So Lizenzsysteme, darüber hat er vorher schon gesprochen, dann hat er noch mal
darauf hingewiesen, keine automatische Replikation der Technik.
Obwohl der Suizkäfer uns ja gesagt hat, das machen die selber die ganze Zeit.
Also dass sie da mit einem System das nächste System anlernen und die so miteinander verschachteln.
Das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall so eine automatische Replikation von allem
dann darstellt. Also zumindest so eine integrementelle Fortentwicklung des Systems und externe Audits.
Und da würde ich sagen, ja, beim Social-Media-Kram hat man es ja gerade so hingeschafft,
dass Facebook mal für eine Weile ein paar universitäre Forschungseinsträge nicht abgelehnt hat.
Aber hier finde ich, sollte wirklich bewaffnetes Behördenpersonal einfach davorstellig
werden können, um sich die Sachen anzuzeigen.
So wie man bei der Steuerbehörde eben auch losrennt und fragt,
was ist das für ein Geschäftsmodell? Jetzt erklären Sie uns das mal.
Naja, mal gucken, wie weit Sie es da treiben.
Die Lizenzierung ist allerdings gar nicht so einfach, oder doch.
Es ist so ein bisschen merkwürdig herauszuhören, wie genau diese Lizenzstufen
gestaltet werden könnten.
We consider for the purposes of this definition.
I would love rather than to do that off the cuff to follow up with your office with like a follow up.
Well, perhaps opine. Opine understanding that you're just responding and you're not making law.
Alright, in the spirit of just opining, I think a model that can persuade,
manipulate, influence a person's behavior or a person's beliefs,
that would be a good threshold.
I think a model that could help create novel biological agents would be a great threshold.
Worauf will er denn jetzt hinaus?
Also um Techniken, die verschiedene Fähigkeiten haben.
Da würde ich sagen, ist eigentlich egal, was er jetzt hier,
worauf er hinaus will, sondern dass damit ja so ein Regime installiert würde,
dass man als Unternehmen beweisen muss, dass manche Fähigkeiten nicht vorhanden
sind, weshalb man unter Lizenzradar durchsegeln kann.
Und das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, weil damit muss man den Beweis antreten,
während dann die Behörden einfach kommen. Aber wenn wir das und das prompten,
dann passiert aber das und das. Und die so, ah ja, Mist und so.
Also, dass man die Dinger dann entweder mit Absicht dumm macht oder gar nicht
erst sofort entwickelt, sondern weil man weiß, okay, dieser Film muss ab sechs
Jahre, und da gucken fremde Leute hin und sagen dann, ja, okay, geht noch und so, ne?
Also, dass man da solche Regime irgendwie aufbaut.
Nun gut, Sie bedauern alle zusammen, dass es bisher kein Privacy-Law gibt in
Amerika, Aber wie gesagt, er sagt dann schon, dieses Recht auf Vergessen oder
gar nicht erst mit mir soll nicht trainiert werden.
Das sollte jedem möglich sein. Also opt out ist natürlich die Frage,
wo man diese, wo man seine Daten dann wie labelt und rauszieht,
damit die dann nicht mitbenutzt werden.
Nach diesem Section 230 Ding ist hier so ein zweiter kleiner Paukenschlag oder eben doch nicht.
Eine große Kritik am Social-Media-Zeug ist ja, dass es Werbe finanziert.
Also das Repetol musste von YouTube
gebaut werden, weil die wollen ja viel Aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen.
Und dann zeigt man den Leuten lieber Verschwörungstheorien, bevor sie irgendwo anders hinschauen.
Das kommt alles über Werbefinanzierung. Er will es nicht ganz ausschließen.
Ich denke, es gibt Leute, denen wir auch Service anbieten wollen und es gibt
kein anderes Modell, das funktioniert.
Aber ich mag es wirklich, dass wir ein subscription-basiertes Modell haben.
Wir haben API-Developer, die uns bezahlen und wir haben Chachipiti-Konsumenten,
die uns bezahlen. Okay, dann kann ich nur kurz einsteigen.
Ja, ich meine, das wundert uns aber auch nicht. Der Markt ist so riesengroß,
der Werbemarkt, und der Markt ist so klein. der Leute, die jetzt wirklich Chachibiti,
Für ein Bezahlabo abschließen, das ist einfach nicht genug für die,
was die da eigentlich haben wollen. Was heißt genug?
Sie wollen mehr. Und sie haben als Konkurrenten Google. Google wird das KI-Programm
mit der normalen Google-Suche verbinden.
Google hat das zur Perfektion getrieben.
Microsoft hatte immer das Problem, dass sie Bing haben. Das ist einfach eine
ganz grauenhafte Suchmaschine.
Also ich bin immer wieder verblüfft darüber, wie schlecht die ist.
Manchmal gerate ich mal aus Versehen darauf.
Und es ist, wenn du da George Clooney eingibst, dann bekommst du wahrscheinlich
nicht den George Clooney, an den wir alle denken, eingezeigt als erstes,
sondern vermutlich bekommst du irgendeinen Forscher aus dem 17.
Jahrhundert, der auch George Clooney hieß. Und dann kommt George Clooney.
Also ich finde diese wirklich eine grauenhafte Suchmaschine.
Und wenn die das jetzt damit optimieren könnten und dann auch eigentlich dieses
Google-Modell ein bisschen für sich spielen können, dann wird das selbst reden
kommen. Und dann gibt es für die professionellen Nutzer in den Unternehmen natürlich
noch verschiedene Premium-Staffelungen.
Also ich würde auch sagen, wir haben jetzt diese erste Stufe hinter uns,
wo ChatGBT für uns alle zur Verfügung steht als Chat-Klient.
Aber deren Ziel ist natürlich selber
als Dienstleister sehr viele andere Unternehmen einfach aufzutreten.
War doch klug jetzt erst mal so über E-Mail-Anmeldungen und das reicht.
So schnell ist da noch nie was gewachsen. Dagegen ist doch das Wachstum von
TikTok geradezu langsam.
Genau. Und alle Unternehmen, die jetzt sagen, wir sind jetzt AI-powered oder
sowas, also wir bauen es jetzt bei uns mit ein, keine Ahnung,
man sucht eine Reise und macht dann diese Reiseplanung, solche Modelle,
die Seiten werden ja alle mit Werbung finanziert.
Und da muss ja nur OpenAI sagen zu Booking.com, ja, wir können das gerne einfach
mit einbauen, kostet halt 780 Millionen im Jahr oder so.
Und da werden die jetzt sagen, aber wir wollen nichts an der Werbung verdienen.
Und die schreiben ja dann Booking nicht vor, dass da keine Werbung angezeigt werden soll.
Also das wird, würde ich auch sagen, durch die Werbung genauso verseucht wie
das ganze Social Media. Also so gut das ist, die Section 230-Verantwortung komplett
bei sich zu lassen, so gruselig ist hier diese Werbeaussicht.
Zum Finale, gegen Ende, Altman äußert mal so seine Sorgen allgemein und danach
kommt mal dieser Professor, von dem wir jetzt wenig gehört haben,
weil er auch nicht sehr viel Interessantes gesagt hat, und sekundiert nochmal.
Die Gefahr oder Risiken erhöhen,
die Resultate von noch komplexeren und kapitaleren AI-Mechanismen werden sicherlich
viel näher sein, als viele Menschen es wünschen.
Lassen Sie mich nur noch sagen, dass ich neben Sam sitze, näher als ich jemals
war, nur einmal in meinem Leben.
Seine Ehrgeiz und seine Angst, darüber zu,
sprechen, ist sehr offensichtlich, physisch, in einer Art und Weise, die nicht nur auf dem,
Televisionschirm kommuniziert, sondern auch von hier aus. Wir können uns ja
alle daran erinnern, sechs Monate erstmal stoppen und so weiter.
Ich hätte ja reingeschrieben, bitte keine Werbefinanzierung und Section 230
Verantwortung bitte übernehmen oder sowas. Aber nein, die haben ja gleich über
die Stränge geschlagen.
Sie haben über die Stränge geschlagen, damit sie genau das nicht reinschreiben müssen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Das wäre ja mal konkret und würde einen ja doch limitieren. Aber wenn ich jetzt
einfach sage Hilfe, wie ich finde es schön, wenn mal kurz die Welt still stehen
könnte, dann könnten wir über alles nachdenken. Das ist ja so ein Stoßgebet,
das kann man mal loslassen.
Also das kann man ruhig nochmal sagen, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Damals hat die New York Times irgendwann so einen Text gemacht,
wo sie festgestellt haben,
Also wenn wir jetzt bei jeder Edwards-Noten-Veröffentlichung immer dazu schreiben,
das ist so schlimm, das hat man noch nie gesehen, dann sehen die Leute irgendwann,
ah ja, gut, okay, wieder mal was so Schlimmes, das haben wir noch nie gesehen,
sondern nein, bitte eine politische Forderung, die handfest ist,
die praktikabel ist und so weiter.
Und das passiert mir so oft in diesen linken Diskursen, dass,
keine Ahnung, irgendwas ist bei der Bahn hier, Stau da, Streik da,
nichts funktioniert. Und dann, ja, das Problem ist doch auch,
dass wir keine Utopie haben. Und ich so, wir brauchen keine Utopie.
Die Diskussion geht jetzt um 10% mehr Lohn oder nicht? Aber nicht um eine Utopie.
Wenn du jetzt da reingehst und sagst, wir brauchen eine Utopie,
ist zerstört. Dann macht die CDU den Sektkorken auf und dann besaugen die sich.
Die prima, debattiert doch mal über eine Utopie.
Da wollte jemand mit Rasta wieder eine Utopie.
Geh zum Berliner Ensemble irgendwie auf die Bühne, da kann man mal darüber reden.
Genau, und das triggerte mich gerade, weil du meintest, der Moratoriumsbrief,
ja, die sechs Monate sind total bescheuert. Wir brauchen kein sechsmonatiges
Moratorium. Wir brauchen hier Werbefreiheit.
Das ist eine Forderung, die legitim ist.
Verantwortungsübernahme, Lizenzsysteme, Audits, diesen ganzen Kram,
den man einfach mal, Wenn alle Amy Klobuchar's Buch gelesen hätten zum Thema,
dann wäre das auch weitergekommen, als zu sagen, die sind so groß,
die Unternehmen, die sind ja teuflisch.
Also diese ganze Diskussion. Also in deren Sicht bitte konkret Forderungen stellen
und nicht immer dieser ganze Blödsinn. Blödsinn, naja, innerhalb dieser Diskussion,
um die sechs Monate, wurden jedenfalls noch ein paar interessante Sachen müsste
man mal überlegen, was das so bedeutet.
Für sechs Monate, dann bin ich mir nicht sicher, was wir dann machen.
Wird es noch eine 6? Und dann kommt man auf ein paar Regeln.
Erstens, was macht man denn in diesen sechs Monaten? Dann sagt er,
wir haben uns mehr als sechs Monate Zeit gelassen zwischen Entwicklung,
also Training von GPT-4 und Veröffentlichung.
Und wir machen auch jetzt gerade sechs Monate lang keine und planen auch nicht
in den nächsten sechs Monaten, GPT-5 zu trainieren. Was mir auch zeigt,
okay, die sind jetzt auch erst mal am Ende der Fahnenstange angekommen.
Mit den größten Computern, die sie verfügbar hatten, haben sie den größten Datensatz,
den es gibt, nämlich alles, einmal GPT-4 trainiert.
Alles andere ist so Ingenieurskunst drumherum.
Wie verschachtelt man die Dinger und so weiter und so fort. Aber es droht jetzt
erst mal kein GPT 5, das sozusagen neu trainiert von Grund auf mit Erfahrung
bisher und dann powert es richtig durch. Sondern wir sind jetzt schon in so
einer Moratoriumsphase.
Wir haben jetzt einmal mit allen Daten, die wir haben auf den größten Kommunen
der Welt durchtrainiert.
Selbst Google übertroffen. Google holt jetzt so langsam auf,
aber die kommen dann auch an diese gläserne Decke erst mal. Und das scheint
jetzt vielleicht auch erst mal der Zustand für die nächsten Jahre zu sein.
Also jetzt Moratorium, also macht gar keinen Sinn.
Wer soll es einleiten? Das ist ja alles Unsinn.
So, Finale, letzter Clip. Ortman betont nochmal die Macht, die er jetzt hat.
Ist nicht das, was es sein sollte, wenn man große Verwaltungskräfte hat,
die das Spiel hier auch beeinflussen können. Hast du irgendwelche Sorgen um
das in dieser nächsten Ära der technologischen Innovation?
Ja, das ist so viel, warum wir OpenAI gestartet haben. Wir haben große Sorgen
um das. Ich denke, es ist wichtig, die Inputs zu diesen Systemen zu demokratisieren,
die Werte, die wir an diese Systeme einigen werden. Und ich denke,
es ist auch wichtig, dass wir Menschen diese Tools weiterverwenden.
Als wir die API-Strategie gestartet haben, was ein großer Teil davon ist,
wie wir unsere Systeme für alle nutzen können, gab es eine große Menge Skepsis
darüber. Und es kommt mit Herausforderungen vor, das ist sicher.
Aber wir glauben, dass das in die Hände vieler Menschen und nicht nur ein paar
Firmen handelt, wirklich sehr wichtig ist. und wir haben das Resultat der Innovation gesehen.
Okay, mir ist der Mann zu sehr in seiner Betroffenheitspose.
Ich glaube ihm kein Wort,
denn er hat nun andere Interessen, als die, die er da vorgibt zu haben und ich
möchte eigentlich nicht in dieser Weise angesprochen werden,
immer mit diesem Stirnrunzeln, also ja ich mache mir da auch unglaubliche Sorgen,
vielen Dank für diese Frage, das ist auch etwas, was mich unglaublich umtreibt,
nein, das tut es nicht, beziehungsweise das ist das Geschäftsmodell,
wir sind schon am Ende angekommen, das heißt schon, wir überziehen wieder maßlos,
ich möchte aber mit einem Clip unseren Podcast beenden, denn wir wollen es natürlich
nicht versäumen zu erwähnen, dass Henry Kissinger 100 geworden ist.
Und er ist eine Stimmefigur und man kann das ja auch alles in der Kissinger-Biografie
von Bernd Geimann nachlesen, die ich mal glaube ich im Salon empfohlen hatte.
Ja, die hatte ich mal im Salon empfohlen.
Aber wir wollen einen Clip hören, denn wir haben jetzt ja Biden, der wieder antritt.
Trump will auch wieder. DeSantis hat es bei Twitter versucht anzukündigen,
möchte aber jetzt wohl auch dabei sein. Aber nehmen wir mal an,
es wird jetzt doch zwischen den alten ausgetragen, Trump und Biden.
Dann könnte man doch auch sagen, sollen wir noch mal die ganz alten aktivieren,
dass die vielleicht auch noch mal in den Dienst kommen.
Und wir hören jetzt hier einen Auszug, da war ein Reporter, ich glaube von irgendeinem
amerikanischen Fernsehsender bei Kissinger zu Hause und haben nachgefragt.
Wenn du einen deiner Helfer hier hättest, würdest du die Telefonnummer aufnehmen
und Beijing anrufen und sagen, dass Dr. Kissinger mit Präsident Xi sprechen
möchte. Würde er deinen Anruf nehmen?
Es ist eine gute Chance, dass er meinen Anruf nehmen würde, ja.
Was ist mit dem russischen Präsidenten, Vladimir Putin?
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Wenn ein Präsident zu dir gekommen wäre,
Und sagen, Henry, würdest du nach Moskau fliegen und mit Putin sprechen?
Ich wäre bereit, das zu tun, ja. Aber ich wäre ein Advisor, nicht ein aktiver
Mensch. Ich dachte nicht daran, dich als Staatssekretär zu verantworten.
Natürlich wärest du ein Advisor. Ja, absolut.
Nur als Berater steht er zur Verfügung, aber nicht mehr ein offizielles Amt.
Das will der 100-jährige Kissinger nicht mehr ausüben. Ich finde,
das sind gute Nachrichten.
Wir weisen noch mal darauf hin, dass man den Salon wie gewohnt buchen kann über
Patreon, Apple und von uns präferiert Steady.
Steady kann man auch erreichen, wenn man unseren Podcast über Spotify hört und
man kann monatlich oder jährlich diesen Podcast, also den Salon buchen.
Und es gibt jetzt in diesem Monat, im Juni, die Möglichkeit für dann 30 Tage
den Podcast zum Kennenlernen gratis zu buchen.
Wenn man dann nicht kündigt, dann bleibt man dabei. Oder man kann dann auch
wieder kündigen, wenn man sagt, um Gottes Willen.
Also wenn man innerhalb der Zeit kündigt, dann ist man wieder draußen,
wenn man sagt, was reden die denn da im Salon.
Wir sprechen, wir haben gesprochen zuletzt über das Stuttgart-Barre Buch,
man kann sich auch durch den Salon dann so ein bisschen mal reinhören,
verschiedene Folgen, alles ist ja dann verfügbar.
Bei Apple ist das Archiv nicht ganz so groß wie bei Steady, aber auch schon
sehr reichhaltig, nämlich jetzt über 14 Monate sind da schon drin.
Bei Steady ist das vollständige Archiv dann da und wir sprechen im nächsten
Salon dann über das Buch, das ein unglaublicher Bestseller ist von Dirk Oschmann,
der Osten eine westdeutsche Erfindung.
Wir müssen also diskutieren über,
Deutsch, deutsche Identitäten. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich habe außerdem noch
zwei interessante Bücher, über die ich sprechen möchte, die ich gelesen habe.
Einmal von Arnold Stadler, einem wunderbaren Schriftsteller, irgendwo aber am Meer.
Ein Autor, der auf Lesereise ist, der plötzlich vorgeworfen wird,
dass er alt Männergeschwätz von sich gibt.
Und man denkt, hat Arnold Stadler jetzt so ein Roman geschrieben,
so ein Boomer-Roman, wo er sagt, mich hört ja keiner mehr. Nein,
Es beginnt erst so scheint es
und dann ist es aber sehr viel cleverer und führt uns wo ganz anders hin.
Sehr überraschend, sehr, sehr tiefgründig.
Und was machen eigentlich Reinigungskräfte, zum Beispiel die Reinigungskräfte,
die ein, zwei, drei, vier Stockwerke unter dem Potsdamer Platz arbeiten?
Das hat sich Jana Kostas gefragt.
Und zwar hat sie eine große Studie gemacht.
Sie hat, sie ist Professorin für Personal, Arbeit und Management in Frankfurt
an der ODA und sie hat dort gearbeitet,
hat also teilnehmende Beobachtung gemacht und hat da ein sehr interessantes Buch geschrieben,
das nicht so ist, jetzt gut, dass wir mal Awareness geschaffen haben für den,
denen es wirklich schlecht geht, sondern im Minusbereich ist ein Buch,
das sehr toll diese Welt der Reinigungskräfte und die Widersprüche, äh.
Interessanter Titel auch.
Ja, im Minusbereich ist manchmal, weil man unter der Erde arbeitet.
Ich bin ja kein großer Fan von Reportagen, habe aber mal eine schreiben müssen
im Zuge des Volontariats bei der FAZ.
Da bin ich dann in die Hauptwache gegangen, also einem großen S-Bahnhof,
wo sehr viele unter Tage arbeiten. Ich habe das dann die Unterirdischen genannt.
Das erinnert mich, ich bin sehr gespannt, was im Minusbereich bei den Unterirdischen
stattfindet. stattfindet. Ich hab nur einen Text schon ausgesucht bei mir fest.
Den hatte ich irgendwie übersehen, aber im Februar hat Steven Wolfram,
den man ja kennt von Wolfram Alpha, der so schon seit einem Jahrzehnt oder so
diese Mathe-Seite, auf der man einfach, wenn man sie klug formuliert,
seine mathematischen Probleme lösen lassen kann, inklusive allem, was dazugehört.
Und Wolfram Alpha gibt's jetzt auch als Plug-in in GPT.
Jetzt wurde ja GPT lange gesagt, kann's ja gar kein Mathe, Das ist ja nur statistisches
Auszählen von Token und so. Und jetzt kann man also ...
Grob formulierte, ich hab mal so eine Idee, und dann macht GPT den richtigen
Prompt raus, dass Wolfram Alpha auch versteht, um was es geht und so.
Also eine schöne Verkoppelung. Und dieser Steven Wolfram hat einen Text darüber
geschrieben, wie GPT funktioniert.
Und ich dachte mir, na ja, gut, wir haben's jetzt schon ein paar Mal thematisiert,
aber da ja die Open-AI-Leute selber grade erst lernen, lernen,
wie ihre Maschine funktioniert und alle davon überrascht sind,
wie gut sie eigentlich funktioniert.
Gucken wir uns auch die Stephen Wolfram Argumentation nochmal an. BWL.
Wunderbar, dann sehen wir uns im Salon und wir sehen uns dann zwei,
drei Wochen später noch im Live Salon. Bis dahin einen schönen Monat.
Haut rein!